you might have heard of several cyber
attack cases where companies have lost
their crucial data money reputation and
customer trust
these attacks are carried out by hackers
who exploit weaknesses in a computer
network to gain unauthorized access to
vital information
however hacking is not always bad as
there are hackers who work with
different motives
white hat hackers also known as ethical
hackers hack with permission to defend
an organization this form of hacking is
legal it is known as ethical hacking
ethical hacking is distributed into six
different phases the first phase is
reconnaissance where you collect all the
required information
next is the scanning phase where you try
to spot any system vulnerability
following this is the gaining access
phase where the spotted vulnerabilities
are exploited
in the next stage known as maintaining
access you try to maintain your access
for future attacks by installing back
doors
the fifth phase is clearing tracks where
you clear all the evidence of the hack
and finally in the reporting phase you
document the summary of the entire
attack
there is and there will always be high
demand for ethical hackers who can
safeguard organizations from cyber
attacks
so what are you waiting for get
certified with simply learn and become
an ethical hacker and put an end to the
cyber attacks in the world this was
ethical hacking in short when most
people hear the expression hacking they
see someone attacking their computer
with a virus crashing a network and
stealing money or enslaving a firm with
ransomware
most people are unaware that ethical
hackers are paid to think like a hacker
or bad actors
they methodically explore a company's
system for flaws and bring them to the
notice of the management before the bad
actors use them
ethical hacking is an investment that
modern businesses cannot afford to
ignore
hackers will spend countless hours
understanding every bid and bite to
circumvent and breach systems
they become specialists in the business
systems gathering all the information
they can discover and utilizing all they
learn to construct a complex assault
based on a series of activities
these activities then inflict
significant harm to the company's
systems and overall organizations all of
these acts cannot be replicated by
automated technologies on their own in
contrast to humans who can watch
recognize learn and adjust an automated
forensics tool cannot discover a
scenario that it has not been designed
to locate
this makes the ethical hacking industry
an absolute necessity
today we're going to take you through
the field of ethical hacking teaching
the inside out mechanism of this
profession we start by learning about
the basics of ethical hacking and the
multiple applications of penetration
testing in the iit sector we take a look
at the most infamous hacks and hackers
that made headlines on a global scale
due to the criminal activities in the
cyber world
next we learn about the best tools and
programming languages being used by
professional ethical hackers on a daily
basis
these are the same tools being used by
the malicious actors when trying to
breach confidential barriers and
firewalls
moving on we read about a couple of
operating systems that are catered
specifically to ethical hackers or
penetration testers
relax based distributions by nature
these operating systems come with all
major ethical hacking tools and scripts
pre-installed making everyday work
easier for the professionals
in the next section we learn about the
most well-known cyber attacks like
ransomware and ddos attack being
employed on a daily basis by malicious
hackers
these attacks affect the general
consumer in order to steal private
information to battle these threats we
are going to have a look at some tools
which can do the same for users like
vpns and the tor network finally we go
over the multiple roles in a cyber
security team and the popular
certifications along with the relevant
study materials with regards to
beginners in ethical hacking
we humans are highly tech savvy in
today's times
with the extensive use of the internet
and modern technologies there is a
massive challenge in protecting all our
digital data such as net banking
information account credentials and
medical reports to name a few have you
heard about the deadly wannacry
ransomware attack
the attack happened in may 2017 in asia
and then it spread across the world
within a day more than 230 000 computers
were infected across 150 countries
the wannacry cryptoworm encrypted the
data and locked the users out of their
systems
for decryption of the data the users
were asked for a ransom of 300 to 600
dollars in bitcoin
the users who used the unsupported
version of microsoft windows and those
who hadn't installed the security update
of april 2017 were targeted in this
attack
the wannacry attack took a toll on every
sector top tier organizations like
hitachi nissan and fedex had to put
their businesses on hold as their
systems were affected too
now this is what you call a cyber attack
to prevent such attacks cyber security
is implemented we can define cyber
security as the practice of protecting
networks programs computer systems and
their components from unauthorized
digital attacks
these illegal attacks are often referred
to as hacking
hacking refers to exploiting weaknesses
in a computer network to obtain
unauthorized access to information a
hacker is a person who tries to hack
into computer systems
this is a misconception that hacking is
always wrong there are hackers who work
with different motives
let's have a look at three different
types of hackers
black hat hackers are individuals who
illegally hack into a system for
monetary gain on the contrary we have
white hat hackers who exploit the
vulnerabilities in a system by hacking
into it with permission in order to
defend the organization this form of
hacking is absolutely legal and ethical
hence they are also often referred to as
ethical hackers
in addition to these hackers we also
have the grey hat hackers as the name
suggests the color gray is a blend of
both white and black
these hackers discover vulnerabilities
in a system and report it to the
system's owner which is a good act
but they do this without seeking the
owner's approval
sometimes grey hat hackers also ask for
money in return for the spotted
vulnerabilities
now that you have seen the different
types of hackers let's understand more
about the hacking that is legal and
valid ethical hacking through an
interesting story dan runs a trading
company he does online training with the
money his customers invest everything
was going well and dan's business was
booming until a hacker decided to hack
the company's servers
the hacker stole the credentials of
various trading accounts he asked for a
lump sum ransom in exchange for the
stolen credentials dan took the hacker's
words lightly and didn't pay the hacker
as a result the hacker withdrew money
from various customers accounts and dan
was liable to pay back the customers
dan lost a lot of money and also the
trust of his customers
after this incident dan gave a lot of
thought as to what could have gone wrong
with the security infrastructure in his
company he wished there was someone from
his company who could have run a test
attack to see how vulnerable systems
were before the hacker penetrated into
the network
this was when he realized he needed an
employee who thinks like a hacker and
identifies the vulnerabilities in his
network before an outsider does
to do this job he hired an ethical
hacker john
john was a skilled professional who
worked precisely like a hacker in no
time he spotted several vulnerabilities
in dan's organization and closed all the
loopholes
hiring an ethical hacker helped dan
protect his customers from further
attacks in the future
this in turn increased the company's
productivity and guarded the company's
reputation so now you know hacking is
not always bad
john in this scenario expose the
vulnerabilities in the existing network
and such hacking is known as ethical
hacking ethical hacking is distributed
into six different phases let us look at
these faces step by step with respect to
how john our ethical hacker will act
before launching an attack the first
step john takes is to gather all the
necessary information about the
organization system that he intends to
attack this step is called
reconnaissance he uses tools like nmap
and h-ping for this purpose
john then tries to spot the
vulnerabilities if any in the target
system using tools like nmap and expose
this is the scanning phase
now that he has located the
vulnerabilities he then tries to exploit
them
this step is known as gaining access
after john makes his way through the
organization's networks he tries to
maintain his access for future attacks
by installing back doors in the target
system
the metasploit tool helps him with this
this phase is called maintaining access
john is a brilliant hacker hence he
tries his best not to leave any evidence
of his attack
this is the fifth phase clearing tracks
we now have the last phase that is
reported
in this phase john documents a summary
of his entire attack the vulnerabilities
he spotted
the tools he used and the success rate
of the attack
looking into the report dan is now able
to take a call and see how to protect
his organization from any external cyber
attacks
don't you all think john is an asset to
any organization if you want to become
an ethical hacker like john
then there are a few skills that you
need to acquire
first and foremost you need to have a
good knowledge of operating environments
such as windows linux unix and macintosh
you must have reasonably good knowledge
of programming languages such as html
php python sql and javascript
networking is the base of ethical
hacking hence you should be good at it
ethical hackers should be well aware of
security laws so that they don't misuse
their skills
finally you must have a global
certification on ethical hacking to
successfully bag a position of an
ethical hacker like john
few examples of ethical hacking
certification are certified ethical
hacker certification ceh comptia pentest
plus
and license penetration tester
certification to name a few
simply learn provides a cyber security
expert master's program that will equip
you with all the skills required by a
cyber security expert you could have a
look at it by clicking the link in the
description so here's a question for you
in which phase of ethical hacking will
you install back doors in the target
system
a scanning
b
maintaining access
c
clearing tracks
d
reconnaissance
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comments section below the
endless growth of technologies in this
area is directly proportional to the
number of cyber crimes cyber crimes are
estimated to cost six trillion dollars
in 2021
hence to tackle these cyber crimes
organizations are continuously on the
lookout for cyber security professionals
the average annual salary of a certified
ethical hacker is 91 000 in the u.s and
approximately rupees seven lakhs in
india
so what are you waiting for get
certified and become an ethical hacker
like john and put an end to the cyber
attacks in the world computers have made
our lives more effortless than ever
however computer viruses have been
trouble since day one
on that note hey guys welcome to yet
another exciting video by simply learn
this video brings you the top six most
dangerous computer viruses of all time
but before we begin if you're new here
and haven't subscribed already make sure
to hit the subscribe button and the bell
icon for interesting tech videos every
day so moving on here's a list of the
most dangerous computer virus let's see
what we have at number one
at number one we have my doom
my doom was one of the worst computer
virus outbreaks in history in 2004. this
malware is technically a worm spread by
mass emailing
it broke previous marks set by the so
big worm and i love you to become the
fastest spreading email worm ever email
spammers appear to have hired my doom to
spread spam by a compromised pcs
users will open an attachment named mail
transaction fails that will be sent to
the victim its objective was to take
down popular websites like google and
lycos
my doom cost estimated damage of 38
billion dollars in 2004 but its
inflation adjusted cost is 52.2 billion
us dollars
by that figure my dome has taken on a
life of its own infecting enough poorly
protected machines to send 1.2 billion
copies of itself per year 16 years after
its creation my doom one of the most
widely distributed viruses infected one
out of every 12 emails at its height
my doom hit companies like google seo
group and microsoft with the distributed
denial of service attack in 2004 16 to
25 percent of all emails had been
infected by my doom on that note here's
a question for you which is the latest
deadly computer virus you have heard of
do let us know in the comment section
below
at number two we have i love you the i
love you virus of 2000 spread by
delivering a fake love letter that
appeared to be a harmless text file this
attacker like my doom sends copies of
itself to all of the email addresses on
the infected machine's contact list it
had spread to over 10 million pcs within
a few days after its may 4 release
arnold d gusbin a college student from
the philippines invented the virus he
created the wires to collect credentials
to log into internet sites he wanted to
utilize for free since he was shot on
cash according to reports he had no clue
how far his work would travel love
letter is another name for this virus
at number three on the list of dangerous
computer viruses we have code red code
red was a computer worm that emerged in
july 2001 and infected computers running
microsoft's iis web server
the code red worm had been released on
july 13th but on july 19 2001 another
variant of the worm spread rapidly and
was reported to infect over 250 000
computers in just nine hours on that day
the total number of infected hosts
reached 359 000.
the worm defaced the affected websites
to display the hacked by chinese text
string it was the first large-scale
thread that could successfully target
enterprise networks in august 2001 the
guardian reported that the fbi had
issued serious warnings to organizations
asking them to safeguard themselves
against this worm at number four we have
crypto locker
the crypto virus popularly known as
crypto locker is a ransomware virus that
encrypts files on a computer and demands
a ransom in return for a decryption code
the crypto locker malware spread between
early september 2013 and late may 2014.
the primary means of infection was via
phishing emails with malicious
attachments it was identified as a
trojan virus that targeted computers
running different versions of the
windows operating system once the crypto
locker is launched it encrypts many
files on a user's computer or hard
drives servers and other storage devices
throughout the organization
crypto virus attacks are rising with
over 4000 attacks each day as per the us
government estimates more than one
billion dollars is paid in ransom each
year
at number 5 we have melissa the melissa
virus was one of the biggest and
earliest cyber threats in history
released in march 1999 melissa started
spreading via email infecting thousands
of computers within ours
the wires were sent in a file called
list.doc which contained passwords to
censored websites so when users
downloaded the file and opened it in
microsoft word a macro inside the
document was executed and emailed the
list stock file to 50 people listed in
the user's email alias file email
servers at more than 300 companies and
government agencies worldwide became
overloaded and some had to be shut down
entirely as per the usfpi report the
estimated cost for cleaning and
repairing affected computer systems was
18 million dollars and finally at number
six on the list of most dangerous
computer viruses we have slammer
on saturday january 25th 2003 the
internet was hit by a vicious computer
worm known as sql slammer it brought
down most of the world's sql servers and
slowed down internet traffic
bank atms were down slammer was 376
bytes of malicious code that attempted
to connect to every computer it could
find over ms sql udp port 1434 causing
heavy network traffic it is believed to
have infected over 75 000 systems within
10 minutes sql slammer was the fastest
spreading computer worm in history the
new york times reported that microsoft
admitted that some of its machines had
gone unpatched and that its msn internet
service also had significant slowdowns
due to the slam over according to cyber
security ventures the global cyber crime
cost is expected to grow and reach
10.5 trillion us dollars by 2025. that's
the cost we have to pay for cyber crimes
in this video we bring you the top 10
dangerous computer hackers of all the
time at number 10 we have johnson james
ancher in the year 2006 charleston james
anchetta of towney california was
charged for controlling huge number of
botnets in other words hijacked
computers
this was the first time that a hacker
was sent to prison for the use of
partner technology and should i use
botnets to compromise more than 400 000
computers advertising companies paid him
to install adware or bots on specified
systems
it is also noted that ancieta advertised
the sale of spartnets to those
interested in sending spam or launching
diro's attacks without being identified
he was also pleaded guilty for infecting
machines at two u.s military sites which
earned him more than sixty one thousand
dollars johnson james and cheddar was
captured in a well-planned and elaborate
sting operation when fbi agents coaxed
him in their office on the pretext of
collecting computer equipment
he was sentenced to nearly 60 months of
imprisonment and was ordered to pay 15
000 u.s dollars to the u.s federal
government for hacking their military
computers
at number nine we have anon lamo lamo
began his hacking journey by hacking
games
he was more likely a grey hat hacker who
wanted people to understand the
importance of internet security
however it went far ahead when he hacked
the new york times internet in 2002 he
was called the homeless hacker for his
transient lifestyle and he often had no
fixed address he used to hack top-notch
accounts by sitting in cafeterias
libraries and so on he was convicted for
compromising security at the new york
times microsoft and yahoo to name a few
he later gained the batch of an american
threat analyst he also appeared on good
morning america fox news democracy now
etc as an expert on net centric crime
and incidents larmo died in the year
2018 at the age of 37. at number eight
we have kevin paulsen a former american
black hat hacker in the hacker community
he is better known as dark dante
at the age of 17 he hacked the us
department of defense but he was left
with a warning as he was a minor later
in 1990 he propelled to stardom for
infiltrating a radio show call-in
contest and guaranteeing that he will be
the 102nd caller to win the brand new
porsche 944s 2. the fbi stated
perceiving paulson and was soon arrested
and sentenced to a five years of
imprisonment
he was also barred from using a computer
or internet for three years post his
release
later he took into white hat hacking and
journalism in the year 2005 he became a
senior editor of wired news at number 7
we have the famous american hacker
jonathan james better known as comrade
he was the first juvenile in the united
states to be sent to prison for hacking
this famous hack was his intrusion into
the defense threat reduction agency or
dtra computers a division of the united
states department of defense
he installed a back door on its servers
this enabled him to access over 3000
messages from government employees
various user names passwords and other
confidential data
this helped james steal a piece of nasa
software and this forced nasa to shut
down computers for three weeks to fix
the issue at an estimated cost of 41 000
american dollars he was sentenced to six
months arrest in 2000 he carried out his
hacking using the alias comrade he
specialized in hacking high-profile
garment systems however he had a bitter
ending in 2008 moving on to a hacker at
number six
at number six we have anonymous
the anonymous group is an international
decentralized hacktivist movement that
is widely known for its cyber attacks
against several governments its agencies
and the church of scientology this group
is focused on the concept of social
justice the members of this group known
as anons are recognized in public by
wearing guy fox masks however some
members cover their face without using
the well-known masks as well they are
known as being the digital robin hood
amongst its supporters
one of the noted incidents was in the
year 2008 when the group took up issue
with the church of scientology and began
to disable their websites they are also
known for hacking vatican the fbi paypal
sony the cia mastercard visa the israeli
chinese tunisian and ugandan governments
while the law enforcement agencies and
fbi have tracked down a few of the
group's members the lack of any proper
hierarchy makes it almost impossible to
distinguish or eliminate the anonymous
groups as the whole at number five we
have the british du matheman and richard
price in 1994 the do hacked into
multiple u.s military systems including
the defense information system agency
griffis air force base and the korean
atomic research institute they
infiltrated into foreign systems by
transferring critical data of korean
atomic research institute into the
united states air force system in 1996
bavin was arrested for hacking incidents
related to u.s air force defense
manufacturer lockheed nasa and nato
the pentagon described breven as the
number one threat to u.s security and
possibly the single biggest threat to
world peace since adolf hitler however
baven claims he was looking to prove a
ufo conspiracy theory in 1997 price was
fined 1200 pounds after pleading guilty
to 12 offenses of gaining unauthorized
access to computer assistance in march
and april 1994. having malicious
purposes or not beaven and price
displayed that even military networks
are vulnerable now moving on to our
hacker at number four
at number four we have astra
this hacker is a tad bit different from
the others on this list as he has never
been publicly identified the pen name of
this hacker astra is a sanskrit word for
a weapon in 2008 it was reported that
the authorities apprehended him at that
time he was known as a 58 year old greek
mathematician he had into france's
distort group systems and got his hands
on vulnerable weapons technology data
and then sold it to different countries
for a long period astra was reported to
have sold the data to nearly 250 people
from across the world this in turn cost
the salt 360 million us dollars of
damage
while the astra's real identity was
never discovered officials have said
that he had been wanted since the year
2002.
at number three we had the famous
american computer hacker albert gonzalez
he was responsible for carrying out
multiple hacks
he is accused of masterminding the
biggest fraud in history that is the
combined credit card theft and reselling
of nearly
170 million car and atm numbers from the
year 2005 to 2007. this shows how unsafe
internet banking can be at times this
was recorded to be one of the biggest
credit card thefts in history he carried
out this by installing a sniffer albert
gonzalez is also said to have been the
mastermind of the tjx companies hack
wherein 45.6 million debit and credit
numbers were stolen later in 2010 he was
sentenced to 20-year in federal prison
moving on to a hacker at number two at
number two we have gary mckinson he is a
scottish systems administrator and
hacker accused of carrying out the
biggest military computer hack of all
time
in 2002 he identified himself as solo
through an odd message on a u.s army
computer it was later found to be gary
mckinson he was accused of infiltrating
97 united states military and nasa
computers by installing virus and
deleting a few files over 13 months
between february 2001 and march 2002
this was the biggest military computer
attack of all time they shut down the
u.s military's washington network for 24
hours what is fascinating is his reason
that much of his hacking was in search
of information on ufos
that he believed the u.s government was
hiding in its military computers and
finally let's see who we have at number
one at number one we have kevin mitnick
the now affluent american entrepreneur
was one of the most wanted cyber
criminal of us once upon a time kevin
who is currently a security consultant
was once convicted of hacking motorola
nokia and pentagon kevin mastered
computer hacking and social engineering
early and got his start as a team in
1982 he had the north american defense
command this achievement inspired the
1983 film war games in 1989 he had
digital equipment corporations network
and main copies of their software it's
largely believed that he once obtained
full control of pacific bell's network
to merely prove that it could be done he
never exploited the data he obtained
according to reports mitnick gained
unauthorized access to a dozens of
computer networks while he was a
fugitive after five years of
imprisonment mitnick started afresh and
became a security consultant his knack
with computers is still remembered all
of these hackers were unbelievably
skilled in cyber code few of them faced
jail in time a few of others ever since
put their cyber skills to better use by
becoming security advisors and helping
humankind hacking skills aren't a form
of criminal behavior if it is put to
good use
so with that we have come to an end of
this video on top 10 dangerous hackers
of all time in this video we bring you
the top 10 computer hacks of all time
let's see what we have at number 10.
from april 27 2007 estonia the european
country faced a series of cyber attacks
that lasted for weeks
this happened when the estonian
government decided to move the bronze
soldier from talon center to a less
prominent military cemetery located on
the city's outskirts
unprecedented levels of internet traffic
took down estonian banks online services
media outlets broadcasters and
government bodies
botnets sent massive waves of spam and
vast amounts of automated online
requests
according to researchers the public
faced ddos attacks there were conflicts
to edit the english language version of
the bronze soldier's wikipedia page as
well
although there is no confirmation russia
is believed to be behind these cyber
attacks that largely crippled the
estonian society
let's now move on to the next attack on
december 23 2015 several parts of
ukraine witnessed a power outage and
this was not a typical blackout it was
indeed the result of a cyber attack
information systems of three energy
distribution companies in ukraine were
compromised it is the first known
victorious cyber attack on a power grid
it is said that here hackers sent out
phishing emails to the power companies
30 substations were switched off and
about 230 000 people were left in the
dark for about one to six hours u.s
investigators believed that russia-based
hackers were responsible for this
experts have warned that other countries
could also be vulnerable to such attacks
let's see what we have at number eight
in the year 1999 a cyber attack caused a
21 day shutdown of nasa computers
unbelievable isn't it the hacker was
none other than the then 15 year old
jonathan james he first penetrated u.s
department of defense division's
computers and installed a back door on
its servers
this allowed him to intercept more than
a thousand government emails including
the ones containing usernames and
passwords
this helped james steal a piece of nasa
software and crack the nasa computers
that support the international space
station which cost the space exploration
agencies 41 thousand dollars as systems
were shut down for three weeks
he was the first person to carry out a
computer hack against the american space
agency let's now move on to the next
attack
in late november 2014 there was a leak
of confidential data from the film
studio of sony pictures
information about sony pictures
employees their emails copies of the
then unreleased sony films future
propositions and other crucial data were
leaked
this cyber attack was carried out by a
hacker grouped named guardians of peace
so what did the hackers want
well they demanded that sony withdraw
its then upcoming movie the interview
this movie was a comedy story line to
assassinate the north korean leader kim
jong-un sony then decided to cancel the
film's theatrical release due to the
threats at cinema screening the movie
it is indeed hard to trace the roots of
a cyber attack in this case after
evaluation the us intelligence officials
arrived at the theory that the attack
was in a way related to the government
of north korea
however north korea had denied the same
moving on to our number six
in december 2006 tjx the u.s retailer
company identified that 45.6 million
debit and credit card details were
stolen
this happened from one of its systems
over 18 months by an unknown number of
intruders it was one of the first
largest ever cyber attacks involving the
loss of personal data
as a result banks in the affected
regions had to reissue and block
thousands of payment cards a group of
hackers did this albert gonzalez being
the mastermind the group was from miami
the place where the tjx heist was
believed to have originated
reports said that the tjx data breach
occurred because of weak web encryption
at two of its marshall stores in miami
next moving on to our top five let us
see what we have at number five
the year 2010 witnessed the discovery of
the deadly computer worm stuxnet
this malware's motive was unlike any
other usual cyber attacks it aimed at
destructing the equipment the computers
controlled
stuxnet came for deadly purpose of
damaging iran's nuclear infrastructure
it infected more than 200 000 computers
including 14 industrial sites and a
uranium enrichment plant in iran
stuxnet initially spread via microsoft
windows and targeted siemens industrial
control systems
although it was discovered only in 2010
it is believed to have been silently
sabotaging iran's nuclear facilities
it was one of the first discovered
malware that was capable of hampering
hardware systems it largely damaged the
centrifuge of the iranian reactors this
is believed to be a cyber weapon created
by the us and the israeli intelligence
although there is no documented evidence
or acceptance by either of the countries
for the same
moving on to number four in the year
2014 home depot was the victim of one of
the deadliest cyber attacks
56 million payment cards were
compromised along with 53 million
customer email address is stolen
this security breach happened from april
to september 2014.
criminals were believed to have used a
third-party vendor's username and
password to enter the perimeter of home
depot network
the attackers were then able to deploy
custom-built malware on its
self-checkout systems in the us and
canada
moving on to our top three
as you might be aware the playstation
gaming system is one of sony's most
popular products unfortunately in april
2011 sony executives witnessed abnormal
activity on the playstation network this
resulted in the compromise of
approximately 77 million playstation
users accounts and prevented users of
playstation 3 and playstation portable
consoles from accessing this service
this forced sony to turn off the
playstation network on april 20th on may
4th sony confirmed that personally
identifiable information from each of
the 77 million accounts had been exposed
the outage lasted for 23 days sony
released almost daily announcements
concerning the system outage in the end
sony is believed to have invested
approximately 170 million dollars to
improve the network security to
investigate the attack and to cover the
expenses of caring for the consumers
that had been affected let's now move on
to the next attack at number two in may
2017 one of the most dangerous cyber
attacks took place
it was known as the wannacry ransomware
attack caused by the wannacry crypto
worm the victims were the users that
used the unsupported version of
microsoft windows and those who hadn't
installed the new security update
this did not take place through phishing
like other attacks but through an
exposed vulnerable smb port
the attack originated in asia and then
eventually spread across the globe in a
day more than two 000 computers were
infected across 150 countries
the wannacry crypto worm locked the
users out of the targeted systems and
encrypted their data the users were
asked for a ransom of 300 to 600 dollars
which had to be paid via bitcoin in
exchange for their data this attack took
a toll on both private and government
organizations it resulted in damages
from hundreds of millions to billions of
dollars
in a matter of few days the emergency
patches released by microsoft halted the
attack
also the discovery of a kill switch
prevented the infected computers from
spreading the crypto worm security
experts and a few countries believed
that north korea was behind this attack
and finally let's see what we have at
number one
more than two decades ago in march 1999
the melissa virus a mass mailing macro
virus was released
it targeted microsoft word and outlook
based systems and created considerable
network traffic
melissa virus infected computers via
emails the email would look like an
important message well yes it was fake
if the recipient opens the attachments
in the mail and downloads the document
and then opens it with microsoft word a
virus was released on their computers
this would then mass mail itself to the
first 50 people in the victims contacts
list and then disable multiple safeguard
features on microsoft word and microsoft
outlook this began spreading like a
wildfire across the internet david l
smith released the virus the virus
caused nearly 80 million worth of
damages it did not steal data or money
however it caused a havoc almost 1
million email accounts were disrupted
worldwide agencies were overloaded and
some had to be shut down entirely and
internet traffic in some locations were
slowed down
so with that we come to the end of this
video on the top 10 computer hacks of
all time
do you agree with our list if you're
aware of any other great interesting
computer hacks in history do let us know
in the comment section below hey
everyone
welcome to this video where we look into
the rampant spyware program that is the
pegasus service before we learn about
the pegasus platform let us understand
what spyware is and it's working spyware
is a category of malware that can gather
information regarding a user or a device
straight from the host machine it is
mostly spread by malicious links via
email or chat applications when a link
with the malware is received clicking on
this link will activate the spyware
which allows the hacker to spy on all
our user information
with some spyware systems even clicking
on the link isn't necessary to trigger
the malicious payload
this can ultimately cause security
complications and further loss of
privacy
one such spyware system that is making
the rounds in the tech industry today
is pegasus the pegasus is a spyware
system developed by an israeli company
known as the nso group it runs on mainly
mobile devices spanning across the major
operating systems like the apple's ios
and iphone and the standard android
versions this is not a newly developed
platform since pegasus has existed since
as early as 2016.
a highly intricate spyware program that
can track user location
read text messages scan through mobile
files access device camera and
microphone to record voice and video
pegasus has all the tools necessary to
enforce surveillance for any client that
wishes to buy its services
initially the nso group had designed the
software to be used against terrorist
factions of the world
with more and more encrypted
communication channels coming to the
forefront pegasus was designed to
maintain control over the data
transmission that can be a threat to
national security
unfortunately the people who bought the
software had complete control over who
how and up to what level they can put
surveillance limits on
eventually the primary clients became
sovereign nations spying on public
information that is supposed to stay
private became really easy with this
service
multiple devices can be effect with the
same spyware system to create a network
information this network keeps feeding
data to the host to understand how a
network can be created let's know how a
mobile device can be affected by pegasus
we all communicate with friends and
family over instant messaging
applications and email in some instances
if you check your inbox on a regular
basis you must have noticed that we
receive some spam emails that the mail
providers like gmail and yahoo can just
filter into the spam folder some of
these messages bypass this filter and
make their way into a person's inbox
they look like generic emails which are
supposed to be safe the pegasus spyware
targets such occurrences by passing
malicious messages and links which
install the necessary spy software on
the user's mobile device be it android
or an iphone
this isn't unique to the email ecosystem
since it's equally likely to be targeted
by sms tags whatsapp instagram or even
the most secure messaging apps like
signal and 3ma
once the malicious links are clicked a
spyware package is downloaded and
installed on the device after the
spyware is successfully installed the
perpetrator who sent the payload to the
victim can monitor everything the user
does
pegasus can collect private emails
passwords images videos and every other
piece of information that passes through
the device network all this data is
transmitted back to the central server
where the primary spying organization
can monitor the activities at a granular
level this is not even surface level
since complex spyware software like
pegasus can access the root files on our
mobiles
these root files hold information that
is crucial to the working of the android
and ios operating systems
leaking such private information is a
massive blow to the security and the
privacy of an individual
the information that may seem trivial
like the name of your wi-fi connection
or the last time you ordered an item
from amazon are indeed all valuable
information this exploitation is
primarily possible due to the zero-day
vulnerabilities known as bugs in the
software development process
the zero-day bugs are the ones that have
just been discovered by some independent
security company or researcher
once they are found reporting these
vulnerabilities to the developer of the
platform which would be either google
for android or apple for ios is the
right thing to do
however many such critical bugs make
their way onto the dark web where
hackers can use them to create exploits
these exploits are then sent to innocent
users with a link or a message like we
had discussed before
pegasus was able to affect the latest
devices with all the security patches
installed but some bugs are not reported
to the developers or this cannot be
fixed without breaking some core
functionality
these become the gateway for spyware to
enter into the system
you can never be 100 safe but you sure
can give it all in protecting yourself
the one thing where pegasus stands out
is a zero click action picture usually
in spam emails the malicious code is
activated when the user clicks the
malware link a user doesn't need to
click the link in the new version of the
pegasus and a few other spyware programs
once the message arrives in the inbox of
whatsapp gmail or any other chat
applications the spyware gets activated
and everything can be recorded and sent
back to the central server the primary
issue with being affected by spyware as
a victim is detection unlike crypto
miners and trojans spying services
usually do not demand many system
resources which makes them tough to
detect after they have been activated
since many devices slow down after a
couple of years any kind of performance
set due to such spyware is often
attributed to poor software longevity by
the users they do not check meticulously
for any other causes that is causing the
slowdown
when left unchecked these devices can
capture voice and video from the mobile
sensors while keeping the owner in the
dark let's take a moment to check if you
are well aware of the causes of such
attacks
how do users fall prey to such spyware
programs a by installing untested
software
b by clicking on the third party links
from email and messages
c by not keeping the apps and phones
updated or d all of the above let us
know your answers in the comment section
below and we will revisit the correct
answer next week but what about the
unaffected devices the vulnerable ones
while we cannot be certain of our
security there are a few things we can
do to boost our device
be it against pegasus or the next big
spyware on the market
let's say we are safe now and we have
the time to take the necessary steps to
prevent a spyware attack what are the
things we can go for
a primary goal must always be to keep
our apps and the operating system
updated the latest security patches the
vulnerabilities that the exploits target
are often discovered by developers from
google and apple which send the security
patches quickly
this can be done for individual apps as
well so keeping them updated is of
utmost importance
while the most secure devices have
fallen prey to pegasus as well a
security patch from developers may help
in minimizing the damage at a later
stage or maybe negate the entire spyware
platform altogether
another big factor is the spread of
malware is the trend of side loading
android applications using dot apk files
downloading such apps from a third party
website have no security checks involved
and are mostly responsible for adware
and spyware invasions on user devices
avoiding the side loading of apps would
be a major step in protecting yourself
we often receive spam emails or text
from people we may not know on social
medias they are accompanied with links
that allow malware to creep into our
device we should try to follow the
trusted websites and not click on any
links that redirect us to unknown
domains
spyware is a controversial segment in
governance
while the ramifications are pretty
extreme in theory it severely impacts
user privacy against authoritarian
regimes
sufficient resources and a contingent
plan can alter the false will of
democracy altogether
even if our daily life is rather
simplistic we must understand that
privacy is not about what we have to
hide instead it portrays the things we
have to protect it stands for everything
we have to share with the outside world
both historically and literally if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
in this video we are going to discuss
what is ethical hacking now take this as
an example there is an organization that
keeps on getting compromised or keeps on
getting attacked repeatedly every month
and they're at a loss of why exactly
this is happening so an employee comes
up with a brilliant idea of hiring an
ethical hacking or hiring an ethical
hacker to test the security systems the
bosses agree and the company ends up
hiring ethical hacker now what this
hacker does is they try to test all the
security controls that the organization
has implemented all the applications uh
maybe even the databases and then they
start giving a report so here you can
see that they are trying to test the
firewall
maybe fire viruses malicious query
stores the firewall hack the company's
website test the company's websites any
applications that the company is
utilizing and try to analyze the
responses that they're going to get so
they're trying to emulate a hacker
scenario where a hacker is trying to
attack and trying to figure out the
vulnerabilities and the areas for
compromise into the organization's
infrastructure so once the report is
ready they would be submitting the
report to the organization and they
would then give recommendations of how
to enhance the security posture of the
organization once the security posture
is enhanced the likelihood of the
organization getting compromised reduces
drastically thus the organization
becomes a lot more secure than it was
before and this is what we are going to
discuss in this video so first and
foremost we are going to discuss uh what
is ethical hacking we are going to talk
about the types of hackers we are
looking at phases of ethical hacking
common types of attacks that are
possible on networks and other systems
and then we are talking about
certification and job roles in the cyber
security space as well so what exactly
is ethical hacking ethical hacking is
locating weaknesses or vulnerabilities
of computers and information system
using the intent and actions of a
malicious hacker now the difference here
is the intent a malicious hacker will
try to gain something for their own
personal gains or try to cause damage to
the other organization here the intent
of the ethical hacker is to identify
possible flaws and vulnerabilities
weaknesses and then try to enhance the
security on those weaknesses by
mitigating those weaknesses thus
preventing malicious hackers from
getting access so the intent is the
complete other way around where a
malicious hacker may be looking at
gaining personally from these attacks
where ethical hacker would prevent the
vulnerability does prevent the hack from
happening in the first place an ethical
hacker is an expert who penetrates a
computer system or network on behalf of
its owners to find security
vulnerabilities that the hacker can
exploit so the difference between the
hacker and ethical hacker here is that a
hacker is not authorized by the
organization whereas in case of ethical
hacker it's the organization themselves
who have hired the services of the
ethical hacker to test the security
controls to test the network to test
applications and find out flaws within
them so that they can be fixed ethical
lacker is also known as a penetration
tester so the job rule here is to find
vulnerabilities and to fix them so that
malicious hackers may not be able to
misuse them what are the advantages of
hiring an ethical hacker in an
organization first and foremost ethical
hackers can emulate or simulate the
scenarios that a hacker would they have
the same knowledge might use the same
tools except for the intent so they will
be able to identify the security threats
for the organization once the security
threats have been mitigated the
organization can actually focus on their
business and increase productivity once
the attacks have been mitigated and the
compromises have been minimized the
organization can full-fledge work
towards their goals their objectives of
the business and be more productive the
reputation of the company can be
safeguarded we obviously don't want to
deal with organizations that keep on
repeatedly getting hacked and compromise
our data we wouldn't trust those
organizations with our private and
personal data in the first place which
means that this is going to inspire
customer confidence the customer would
feel that if the organization is secure
and is able to protect themselves they
would be able to protect the customers
data and customers uh private
information as well which is the
protection for your customers or clients
so this can be advertised as by the
organization saying we have ethical
hackers we do proactive approach towards
our security measures we have integrated
security mechanisms in place we are safe
we have been tested and we can prove
that we are security compliant once the
customers come to know about this
customers would feel a lot more safer to
deal with such organizations after
discussing the advantages of hiring an
ethical hacker let's discuss the types
of hackers the first classification is
of a black hat hacker these people are
individuals with extraordinary computing
skills which means they are very
intelligent they can program quite a bit
they know everything about hacking and
these guys are experts however the
intent is malicious or destructive in
nature they would want to harm the
victim and gain possibly monetarily from
these kind of activities some of these
people would do it for fun and ego boost
if you will the second classification is
of a grey hat hacker these are
individuals who work offensively as well
as defensively so at times they can
for an agenda become a black hat hacker
gain out of it hack without
authorization and at times they can
actually accept a contract from an
organization to help them enhance the
security of that organization and then
there are white hat hackers these are
individuals professing the same skills
that offer black hat or a grey hat they
might use the same tools possess the
same knowledge except for the intent
their intent is not to cause harm but to
protect the organization and enhance the
security skills these are people like us
these are ethical hackers who
essentially
try to emulate or simulate the attacks
from a black hat hacker's perspective to
find out the flaws and then try to
mitigate them try to enhance the
security portion of the organization to
prevent that organization from getting
hacked and then there are suicide
hackers these are individuals who bring
down critical infrastructure for a cause
the main difference between the black
hat hackers and suicide hackers is that
black hat hackers will try to hide their
identity suicide hackers do not in fact
they will claim responsibility for the
attacks that they have done then we have
script kitties these are unskilled
hackers they have no idea what they're
doing they may not be technically very
adept but they rely on tools already
created by black hat hackers and then
try to use those tools and leverage them
to try to hack an organization a cyber
terrorist would be any organization or
individual who are motivated by
religious or political beliefs and they
try to create fear by large scale
disruption of computer networks so they
might attack countries they might attack
organizations to promote their political
or religious causes and might create
harm to the population at large
state-sponsored hackers are individuals
who are employed by the government to
spy on neighboring countries or
their enemies the attempt is to gain top
secret information that would be
damaging to other governments which
would enhance the security portion of
one or one's own country now this is not
an official job profile but it's a known
fact that most of the governments have
hired hackers to spy on other countries
and other organizations then there are
activists individuals who want to
promote a political agenda by hacking
and defacing websites these guys do not
[ __ ] infrastructure they just hack
websites deface them put their own
propaganda on the face of the website to
promote whatever political messages that
they want to promote now let's talk
about the phases of ethical hacking
ethical hacking is distributed into five
different phases they are the
requirements phase scanning gaining
access maintaining access and covering
tracks the first phase the
reconnaissance phase is all about
information gathering here you are
trying to identify the target trying to
get to know the target gathering
information about the target could be
digital in nature could be any personal
information or organizational
information that you can leverage later
on for social engineering attacks as
well here you might try to find out from
a technical perspective the ip addresses
domain names subdomains
email addresses phone numbers of people
working in the organization once you
have all this information you would then
proceed to the scanning phase we are
going to actively scan for devices that
are live and can you can interact with
then you are going to scan those live
devices to identify ports protocols and
services running on those systems now
these ports or protocols these would be
your entry points to try to gain access
to that system it is here where those
flaws would exist so in this phase
you're basically identifying which ports
are open which services are running on
top of them what protocols are being
utilized by the machine once you've
identified this you might want to
enumerate them by gathering more
information from a specific protocol and
then you might want to go into the
vulnerability scanning phase where
you're going to scan these services
protocols for vulnerabilities trying to
create a list of all the possible
vulnerabilities in that system once you
have the list of possible
vulnerabilities you're going to move on
to the gaining access phase where you're
going to attack those vulnerabilities
try to exploit them and try to gain
access or embed a trojan virus keylogger
or any software that can spy on the
victim once you have hacked into this
machine you're going to try to maintain
access maintaining an access is you're
trying to retain those access for a
longer period of time so you can spy on
the device spy on the user uh try to
collect more information as time goes on
you're not going to rely on the hack
forever because the hack may no longer
work after a period of time especially
if the system gets patched up or
somebody runs an antivirus scan or
figures out something is wrong
maintaining access is where you're going
to install a back door an unauthorized
back door obviously without the
knowledge of the victim which will allow
you to interact with the machine or
gather information from the machine
without any hindrance once you have
installed these kind of softwares you
don't want them to be discovered that's
where the covering tracks come into the
picture when you have installed a
rootkit a trojan a spyware it will
create directories it will create files
in this phase the covering tracks you're
going to try to erase the trace of the
creation of these files when you're
accessing something while maintaining
access or gaining access there would be
logs that would be created by the
applications which would announce what
you've been doing in the coverage
covering tracks phase you will be trying
to delete those logs and try to erase
the traces of your activity as well so
in these five phases the entire gambit
of ethical hacking is covered let's move
on to discuss the common types of
attacks the first and foremost and the
most common attack in today's world is a
denial of service attack or a
distributed denial of service attack
this attack is launched by an attacker
not to not for personal gain but to harm
the other organization by crashing those
services or making the services
unavailable for legitimate users thus
causing monetary harm and reputational
harm to the organization they actually
try to restrict the access to these
resources for legitimate users by
consuming all the bandwidth or the
resources made available then there are
password attacks these attacks are
essentially where you're trying to crack
the password of a user so that you can
get access to their account and through
their access you can then leverage those
access and capture data that you
wouldn't have otherwise gotten access to
then man in the middle attack is where
you are trying to capture data packets
over the network that are flying between
the victim and the target server so
you're essentially placing yourself
between the communication channel that
has been opened between the victim and
the targeted server and you're trying to
capture the data packets you're trying
to analyze those data packets and
capture any secret information like
usernames passwords any other
transactions that the user might be
doing then you have email attacks the
attacker sends bait offer in the form of
an email so these would be a phishing
attacks that would come under the gambit
of social engineering phishing attacks
are nothing but fake mails that look
very genuine to the end user and thus
persuade them to click on links that
lead to malicious servers thus
compromising the device of the victim
sql injection attacks are normally
targeted to websites or web applications
that but that have a database connected
to them the database and the application
interact with each other using sql
language or structured query language if
not configured properly and if there are
no firewalls watching a user can craft
malicious sql queries which can then
dump data or give out unwanted
information to the hacker that should
have been protected in the first place
and then if you have the eavesdropping
attack where the attacker observes the
traffic on the system and works and the
work you are doing on your computer
eavesdropping could be where you're
trying you're tracking wipe calls or you
have installed a trojan on somebody's
mobile phones and you're trying looking
at all that information let's look at
the certifications that are available in
this field the foundational knowledge
that you would require is a graduate in
computer eye science or any it
security-related field most of the
universe universities nowadays provide
this kind of certifications you should
have solid grounds united i.t
fundamentals that means you should be
technically very adept you should
understand how protocols work how
networking works you should be
somewhat conversant with some scripting
languages and should be able to
understand programming knowing
networking and mastering networking is a
very fundamental requirement even if you
later on decide to go into application
security and you're looking at
programming languages applications still
work over the network and you need to
know how these networks are going to be
configured and how data is going to be
transmitted over this network coding
skills like i said programming not from
a developer's perspective but at least
good enough to understand how the
program functions what the flaws may be
in the programming code that has been
given and how you can break that
particular code that is what is required
a few scripting languages like php perl
python ruby they would be a lot helpful
at this point in time maybe bash
scripting or powershell scripting as
well and then our understanding of the
architecture of an operating system we
just don't want to know how the
operating system works and how it
functions we should be able to
troubleshoot the operating system to
recover from errors flaws and we should
know how the operating system works
stores data and interacts with the
hardware in at the first place with
everything there is now cloud and cloud
is gaining traction a lot we got public
clouds like amazon microsoft and google
we got private clouds like vmware uh
microsoft again citrix and so on so
forth most of the organizations in
today's world have a hybrid environment
where they've got a part physicality
infra and part cloud infrastructure so
learning what cloud is the nuances of
cloud the services that a cloud can
provide software as a service
infrastructure as a service and platform
as a service understanding them and then
knowing how you can secure these or what
the vulnerabilities are in the first
place and then trying to secure them is
of very much a sense in today's world
over a period of time you will have to
learn cloud security to be relevant in
today's world especially with iot
artificial intelligence and machine
learning uh picking up pace and then
malware analysis and reverse engineering
so let's say there's a new virus that
has been released and there's an
antivirus company who's working to
figure out how the virus works what are
the signatures that are created by the
virus and this is where those malware
analysis skills come into the picture
even in real terms or in normal terms if
you are working in an organization and
if a machine has been infected or is
suspected of an impact infection you
need to investigate the machine to
identify whether it was a worm virus or
a trojan and need to take effective
action to prevent further compromise
from happening and that is why
malware analysis is of importance as
well the certifications that you have
certified ethical hacker it will train
you in reverse engineering so this is
where you basically look at offensive
security this is where you're looking at
hacking and you're looking at how the
methodologies the five steps that we
have talked about and this course deals
with each and every one of those five
steps and helps you analyze and
understand the tool sets and the skills
that are required for each of that
particular step salaries may range
between 71 000 us dollars and above in
the u.s market and around around 5 lakh
rupees and more in the indian market
after ceh we've got the ecsa slash lpt
course ecs is the ec council certified
security analyst course once you get
certified on that you can then apply for
the lpt which is the licensed
penetration tester so it's for ceh then
ecsa ec council certified security
analyst and then lpt licensed
penetration tester this gives certified
penetration testers the opportunity to
practice their skills and gives you a
license where you have a certificate
that proves that you have understood the
methodology and are very adept at the
skills of hacking when we hear the term
hacker we may picture a dangerous cyber
criminal however not all hackers are
inherently bad they are powerful
individuals who use their technical
skills to break into computer networks
and bypass security measures
hacking is not always bad and it is to
be noted that the world of computers is
actually safer to an extent because of a
particular type of hacker
a hacker is deemed to be good or bad
depending on their motive and whether or
not they are breaking the law
in this video we will acquaint you with
the differences between a white hat
hacker black hat hacker and a grey
attacker through a short story hackers
are basically categorized by the type of
metaphorical hat they tone white hat
grey hat and black hat
hackers can either be a black hat or a
white hat or a grey hat
hackers can be good or bad depending on
which color hat they decide to wear and
by this we mean their hacking motifs and
obviously not in the sense of creating a
fashion statement here
let's have a look at our story
our story here revolves around dan who
is the owner of a company that provides
a platform for video conferencing
his platform enables online
communication for video meetings audio
meetings and webinars
just like other video conferencing
platforms his platform too has built-in
features like chat recording screen
sharing and so on
everything went well and his business
increased tremendously with the onset of
the covet 19 pandemic
kowitt 19 accelerated the rise of the
worldwide digital economy and it made
people rapidly adopt video conferencing
tools and apps
in a contactless world starting from
employee interactions to family get
togethers to virtual workout classes
everything happened virtually dance
video conferencing platform enabled long
distance communication and enhanced
collaboration
so now you might be wondering what could
have gone wrong well there are many
risks involved when it comes to the
safety of these online platforms
online meeting rooms are susceptible to
a number of digital threats
dan received complaints from his
customers that his platform was insecure
and safe anymore
little did dan know that the popularity
of his video conferencing platform made
hackers eager to disrupt the virtual
meetings and hijack the conferences
his platform witnessed complaints like
the addition of an unknown participant
in every meeting room someone covering
up information that is being presented
and also unknown screen recording of a
meeting to name a few
these intruders were sneaky hackers who
tried to gain access to sensitive
information and who tried to disrupt
meetings
and how did these hackers manage to do
all this
well this was done by exploiting
weaknesses in dan's computer network in
order to obtain unauthorized access to
crucial data and sensitive information
this is known as hacking and the
individuals who carry this out are known
as hackers
in this form of hacking that dan
witnessed hackers exploited dan's
company's security posture by
identifying weaknesses in it in order to
intrude into the meetings and gain
access to business data or personal data
and this form of hacking is definitely
bad and unethical the hackers who
carried this against dance company are
known as black hat hackers
these hackers are cyber criminals who
carry out cyber attacks with a negative
intention
these attacks can be in the form of
trojan virus malware attacks phishing
attacks ddos attacks man in the middle
attacks sequel injection attacks and so
on
so who exactly is a black hat hacker
like in the case of dance organizations
cyber attack
blackhead hackers are highly skilled
cyber criminals who break into computer
systems and networks with malicious
intent
they illegally hack into a system and
this is obviously without the system
owners approval
such hackers do not abide by the laws
they violate laws and disrupt networks
the motive behind these attacks vary
from monetary gains to personal profit
usually they are for monetary gains
black hat hackers may violate the
confidentiality integrity or
availability of a company's systems and
data they may also use malware to
destroy files or steal passwords credit
card numbers and other confidential
information
black hat hackers are also sometimes
called crackers
so this is who a black hat hacker is
moving back to dan's story
black hat hackers disrupted his business
and he lost his customers as nobody
wished to communicate on an unsecure
platform
it is but true right would you be okay
to use a platform that is unsafe
none of us want to have unknown people
in our meetings right this is how dan's
customers felt too and this news spread
and his company's reputation took a bad
hit
that is when ted approached dan so who
is dead let's have a look at that now
ted who was unknown to dan explained to
him that he found dan's network to be
weak
ted told dan that he has identified
vulnerabilities in dance systems and
networks and he will fix them provided
dan pays him well
dan had nothing to lose and without any
further delay he paid ted a good amount
of money to fix the vulnerabilities in
dance networks
on receiving the money ted began his
work and he fixed all the issues and
vulnerabilities in dan's network he made
sure that nobody can exploit dan's
network vulnerabilities again and this
way he safeguarded dan's network for the
time being
so who is dead
well he's called a grey hat hacker as
they say not all things are black and
white so is the concept of grey hat
hackers as fascinating as the name
sounds let us dive deep into
understanding the role of a grey hat
hacker a grey hat is a security expert
who may at times violate the laws or the
ethical standards
however they do not carry a malicious
intent unlike a black hat hacker
hence they are known to work both
defensively and offensively
they land between the good and the bad
gray hat hackers look for
vulnerabilities in a system without
permission but with good intentions
just like how ted informed dan about how
he could exploit dan's system
vulnerabilities grey hat hackers inform
an organization the same and in return
ask for a fee to fix it
in some cases when the organization
doesn't comply grey hat hackers may
become black hat hackers
although a grey hat hacker's intention
might not be bad what they do is still
illegal since they do not have
permission to break into another system
back to our story
although dance issue was sorted by ted
for the time being he had a few concerns
his first concern was history repeating
itself yes he was worried about what if
black hat hackers hack into his systems
again
although his system vulnerabilities are
fixed at the moment it was a matter of
time before they could be exploited
again with new hacking techniques
his next thought was to have a
professional who could constantly keep a
tab on his networks and protect it from
hackers don't you think his concerns
were justified yes it was as this was
the only way he could provide a safe and
secure video conferencing platform in
the long run
that is when dan stren came to his
rescue and introduced anne the ethical
hacker to him
and being an ethical hacker assured dan
that she would scan and identify his
network for system vulnerabilities
before an outsider exploits it and she
would fix those vulnerabilities on a
regular basis
such ethical hackers like anne are
called white hat hackers
now that we saw who black hat hackers
and grey hat hackers were it is time we
learn about our third type of hacker who
is a white hat hacker
a white hat hacker gains access to
networks with an intention to fix the
identified weaknesses
they also perform penetration testing
and vulnerability assessments and break
into systems with permission
they search for loopholes or
vulnerabilities in any given piece of
technology just like how a black hat
hacker would do
however white hat hackers harden their
organization system before the bad guy
can get in
their goal is to spot system and network
vulnerabilities in order to improve
system security
white hat hackers are also known as
ethical hackers since they obey the law
of the land and follow a code of ethics
many companies and government
organizations employ white hat hackers
to help them secure their systems
these hackers are typically hired by
organizations to look for
vulnerabilities in a system like other
hackers
the only difference being they are given
permission to break in
once dan spots the vulnerabilities she
documents her findings and gives dan
advice on how to fix them or she'll even
take it up to fix them so that an
outsider cannot spot it in the future
and does this on a regular basis as
system updates happen regularly and it
is imperative to be on track with it and
fix new vulnerabilities
this made sure dan's network is now safe
and secure gradually he regained his
customers trust and his platform got
back to being one of the best and safest
platforms for video conferencing
this resulted in a huge business growth
and dan was very happy
just like how ann put an end to dance
business problems there are many white
hat hackers out there who are in great
demand by organizations to safeguard
their networks from cyber attacks
and if you are interested in a career in
ethical hacking then simply learn can
help you fulfill your dreams
simply learn ch version 11 certification
provides you the hands-on training
required to master the techniques
hackers use to penetrate network systems
and fortify your system against it
this ethical hacking course is aligned
with the latest ch version 11 by ec
council and will adequately prepare you
to increase your blue team skills
so what are you waiting for get
certified with simply learn and become a
certified ethical hacker and put an end
to the cyber crimes in the world
remember the more active white hat
hackers are the fewer opportunities
black hat hackers have for system
exploitation cyber security has become a
struggle for organizations in 2021.
recent trends the side effects of a
global pandemic and cybersecurity
statistics reveal a huge increase in
hacked and breached data for
increasingly common sources in the
workplace like mobiles and iot devices
on top of this the covert 19 has ramped
up remote workforces making inroads for
cyber attacks
this kind of growth would not have been
possible if not for several reliable
tools and services
from scripts that find intricate details
of companies to software that can brute
force servers with a single command
today's lesson is all about such tools
that make an ethical hacker effective
let's learn about what is ethical
hacking ethical hacking involves an
authorized attempt to gain unauthorized
access to a computer system application
or data
carrying out an ethical hack involves
duplicating strategies and actions of
malicious attackers
often carried out in the form of
security audits ethical hacking is
extremely beneficial to organizations
who are looking to secure the data from
falling in the wrong hands
there are three variants of hackers
while a black hat hacker is notorious
for criminal activities white hat is an
ethical hacker or a computer security
expert who specializes in penetration
testing and other testing methodologies
that ensure the security of an
organization system
there are a few that fall under the gray
hat hacker umbrella where the hacker
occasionally have not authenticated
themselves before attempting to hack an
organization while sometimes requiring a
small fee to report the vulnerability to
the developers directly
the purpose of ethical hacking is to
improve the security of the network or
the systems by fixing the
vulnerabilities found during testing
ethical hackers may use the same methods
and tools used by the malicious hackers
but with the permission of the
authorized person for the purpose of
improving the security and defending the
systems from attacks
ethical hackers are expected to report
all the vulnerabilities and weaknesses
found during the process to the
management directly
ethical hacking has proven itself to be
quite a productive career option for
many ambitious individuals the demand
for its courses today is at an all-time
high and rightfully so it provides you
with an engaging job that never gets
tedious some certifications like the
comptia plus ceh and cisco ccna are
highly acclaimed and will teach a
learner all there is to know before
dipping their toes in the industry
when it comes to web app hacking it
generally refers to the exploitation of
applications by http which can be done
by manipulating the applications via its
graphical user interface this is done by
tampering with the uniform resource
identifier also known as a uri or
tampering with the http elements
directly which are not a part of the uri
the hacker can send a link via an email
or a chat and may trick the users of a
web application into executing actions
in case the attack is on an
administrator account the entire web
application can be compromised
anyone who uses a computer connected to
the internet is susceptible to the
threats that computer hackers and online
predators pose
these online villains typically use
phishing scams spam email or instant
messages and bogus websites to deliver
dangerous malware to your computer and
compromise their computer security
computer hackers can also try to access
your computer and private information
directly if you are not protected by a
firewall they can monitor your
conversations or peruse the back end of
your personal website
usually disguised with a bogus identity
predators can lure you into revealing
sensitive personal and financial
information
a web server which can be referred to as
the hardware the computer or the
software which helps to deliver content
that can be accessed through the
internet
the primary function of a web server is
to deliver these web pages on the
request to clients using the hypertext
transfer protocol or http
so hackers attack the web server to
steal credential information passwords
and business information by using
different types of attacks like ddos
attacks syn flooding ping flood port
scan and social engineering attacks
in the area of web security despite
strong encryption on the browser server
channel web users still have no
assurance about what happens at the
other end
although wireless networks offer great
flexibility they have their own security
problems a hacker can sniff the network
packets without having to be in the same
building where the network is located
as wireless networks communicate through
radio waves a hacker can easily sniff
the network from a nearby location
most attackers use network sniffing to
find the ssid and hack a wireless
network
an attacker can attack a network from a
distance and therefore it is sometimes
difficult to collect evidence against
the main hacker
social engineering is the art of
manipulating uses of a computing system
into revealing confidential information
which can be later used to gain
unauthorized access to a computer system
the term can also include activities
such as exploiting human kindness greed
and curiosity to gain access to
restricted access buildings or getting
the users to installing backdoor
software
knowing the tricks used by hackers to
trick users into releasing vital login
information is fundamental in protecting
computer systems
coming to our main focus for today let
us have a look at the top 5 most
essential ethical hacking tools to be
used in 2021
at the top of the chain lies nmap
nmap which stands for network mapper is
a free and open source utility for
network discovery and security auditing
many systems and network administrators
also find it useful for tasks such as
network inventory managing service
upgrade schedules and monitoring host or
service supply
it is most beneficial in the early
stages of ethical hacking where a hacker
must figure the possible entry point to
a system before running the necessary
exploits thus allowing the hackers to
leverage any insecure openings and thus
breach the device
nmap users draw ib packets in novel ways
to determine what hosts are available on
the network what service they are
running what operating systems are
installed what type of packet filters
and firewalls are in use and dozens of
the characteristics it was designed to
rapidly scan large networks but works
fines against single host as well
since every application that connects to
a network needs to do so via a port the
wrong port or a server configuration can
open a can of worms which lead to a
thorough breach of the system and
ultimately a fully hacked device
next on our list we have metasploit
the metasploit framework is a very
powerful tool that can be used by cyber
criminals as well as ethical hackers to
probe systematic vulnerabilities on both
networks and servers
because it's an open source framework it
can be easily customized and used with
most operating systems
with metasploit the ethical hacking team
can use ready-made or custom code and
introduce it into a network to probe for
weak spots
as another flavor of threat hunting once
the flaws are identified and documented
the information can be used to address
systemic weaknesses and prioritize
solutions
once a particular vulnerability is
identified and the necessary exploit is
fed into the system there are a host of
options for the hacker depending on the
vulnerability hackers can even run root
commands from the terminal allowing
complete control over the activities of
the compromise system as well as all the
personal data stored on the device
a big advantage of metasploit is the
ability to run full-fledged scans on the
target system which gives a detailed
picture of the security index of the
system along with the necessary exploits
that can be used to bypass the antivirus
software
having a single solution to gather
almost all the necessary points of
attack is very useful for ethical
hackers and penetration testers as
denoted by its high rank in the list
moving on we have the acunetix framework
acunetix is an end-to-end web security
scanner which offers a 360 degree view
of an organization security
it is an application security testing
tool that helps the company address
vulnerability across all their critical
web assets
the need to be able to test application
in depth and further than traditional
vulnerability management tools has
created a market with several players in
the application security space
acunetix can detect over 7000
vulnerabilities including sql injections
cross-site scripting misconfigurations
weak passwords exposed database and
other out-of-band vulnerabilities
it can scan all pages web apps and
complex web applications running html5
and javascript as well it also lets you
scan complex multi-level forms and even
password-protected areas of the site
acunetix is a dynamic application
security testing package which has
definite births over status application
security testing frameworks which are
also known as sasd scanners
sast tools only work during development
and only for specific languages and have
a history of reporting lot of false
positives whereas dynamic testing tools
also known as dst have the ability to
streamline testing from development to
deployment with minimal issues
next on our list we have airgarden
this is a multi-use bash script used for
linux systems to hack and audit wireless
networks like our everyday wifi router
and its counterparts
along with being able to launch denial
of service attacks on compromised
networks this multi-purpose wi-fi
hacking tool has very rich features
which support multiple methods for wi-fi
hacking including wps hacking modes wp
attacks handshake captures evil twin and
so much more
it usually needs an external network
adapter that supports monitor mode which
is necessary to be able to capture
wireless traffic that traverse the air
channels thanks to its open source
nature
air garden can be used with multiple
community plug-ins and add-ons thereby
increasing its effectiveness against a
wide variety of routers both in the 2.4
gigahertz and the 5 gigahertz band
finally at number 5 we have john the
ripper
john the ripper is an open source
password security auditing and the
password recovery tool which is
available for many operating systems
john the ripper jumbo supports hundreds
of hash and cipher types including for
user passwords of operating systems web
apps database servers encrypted keys and
document files
some of the key features of the tool
include offering multiple modes to speed
up the password cracking automatically
deselecting the hashing algorithm used
by the passwords and the ease of running
and configurating the tool to make it
password cracking easier
it can use dictionary attacks along with
regular brute forcing to speed up the
process of cracking the correct password
without wasting additional resources
the word list being used in these
dictionary attacks can be used by the
user's end allowing for a completely
customizable process
we also have a few honorary mentions in
our list that just miss the card
netsparker for instance is an automated
yet fully configurable web application
security scanner that enables you to
scan websites web applications and web
services the scanning technology is
designed to help you secure web
applications easily without any fuss so
you can focus on fixing the reported
vulnerabilities
the burp suit professional is one of the
most popular penetration testing and
vulnerability finder tools and is used
for checking web application security
the term burp as it is commonly known is
a proxy based tool which is used to
evaluate the security of web-based
application and to do hands-on testing
moving away from websites and
applications wireshark is a free and
open source packet analyzer which was
launched in 2006.
it is used for network troubleshooting
analysis software and communications
protocol development and education
it captures network traffic on the local
network and stores data for offline
analysis
wireshark captures network traffic from
ethernet bluetooth wireless networks and
frame relay connections
now that we learn about the different
types of tools that can be used when
conducting an ethical hacking audit
let's learn about some potential
benefits of such campaigns and why
organizations prefer to pay for such
audits
being able to identify defects from an
attacker's perspective is game changing
since it displays all the potential
avenues of a possible hack
one can only prepare for the known
vulnerabilities as a defensive
specialist but proactively trying to
breach a network or device can make
hackers think of techniques that no
defense contractors can account for
this kind of unpredictability goes a
long way in securing a network against
malicious actors
another advantage of hiring ethical
hackers is the ability to preemptively
fix possible weak points in a company's
network infrastructure
as seen on many occasions a real breach
will cause loss of data and irreparable
damage to the foundation of an
organization
being able to gauge such shortcomings
before they become public and can be
used exploited is a benefit most
organizations make use of
this is not to imply that such security
audits are only beneficial to the
organization paying for it when coming
across companies that provide certain
services a reliable third party security
audit goes a long way in instilling
trust and confidence over their craft if
the ethical hackers cannot find any
major vulnerabilities that can be
leveraged by hackers it just accentuates
the technical brilliance of the
organization and its engineers thereby
increasing the clientele by a
substantial amount with the rise in
censorship and general fear over privacy
loss consumer security is at an all-time
high risk technology has made our life
so much easier while putting up a decent
target on our personal information it is
necessary to understand how to
simultaneously safeguard our data
and be up to date with the latest
technological developments maintaining
this balance has become easier with
cryptography taking its place in today's
digital world so here's a story to help
you understand cryptography
meet ann
ann wanted to look for a decent discount
on the latest iphone she started
searching on the internet and found a
rather shady website that offered a 50
discount on the first purchase
once and submitted her payment details a
huge chunk of money was withdrawn from a
bank account just moments after
devastated and quickly realized she had
failed to notice that the website was a
http web page instead of an https one
the payment information submitted was
not encrypted and it was visible to
anyone keeping an eye including the
website owner and hackers had she used a
reputed website which has encrypted
transactions and employs cryptography
our iphone enthusiast could have avoided
this particular incident
this is why it's never recommended to
visit unknown websites or share any
personal information on them
now that we understand why cryptography
is so important let's take a look at the
topics to be covered today
we take a look into what cryptography is
and how it works
we learn where cryptography is being
used in our daily lives and how we are
benefiting from it
then we will understand the different
types of cryptography and their
respective uses
moving on we will look at the usage of
cryptography in ancient history and a
live demonstration of cryptography and
encryption in action
let's now understand what cryptography
is
cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand the message as an essential
aspect of modern data security using
cryptography allows the secure storage
and transmission of data between willing
parties
encryption is the primary route for
employing cryptography by adding certain
algorithms to jumble up the data
decryption is the process of reversing
the work done by encrypting information
so that the data becomes readable again
both of these methods form the basis of
cryptography
for example when simply learn is jumbled
up or changed in any format not many
people can guess the original word by
looking at the encrypted text
the only ones who can are the people who
know how to decrypt the coded word
thereby reversing the process of
encryption
any data pre-encryption is called plain
text or clear text
to encrypt the message we use certain
algorithms that serve a single purpose
of scrambling the data to make them
unreadable without the necessary tools
these algorithms are called ciphers
they are a set of detailed steps to be
carried out one after the other to make
sure the data becomes as unreadable as
possible until it reaches the receiver
we take the plain text pass it to the
cipher algorithm and get the encrypted
data this encrypted text is called the
ciphertext and this is the message that
is transferred between the two parties
the key that is being used to scramble
the data is known as the encryption key
these steps that is the cipher and the
encryption key are made known to the
receiver who can then reverse the
encryption on receiving the message
unless any third party manages to find
out both the algorithm and the secret
key that is being used they cannot
decrypt the messages since both of them
are necessary to unlock the hidden
content
wonder what else we would lose if not
for cryptography
any website where you have an account
can read your passwords important emails
can be intercepted and their contents
can be read without encryption during
the transit
more than 65 billion messages are sent
on whatsapp every day all of which are
secured thanks to end to end encryption
there is a huge market opening up for
cryptocurrency
which is possible due to blockchain
technology that uses encryption
algorithms and hashing functions to
ensure that the data is secure if this
is of particular interest to you you can
watch our video on blockchain the link
of which will be in the description
of course there is no single solution to
a problem as diverse as explained there
are three variants of how cryptography
works and is in practice
they are
symmetric encryption asymmetric
encryption
and hashing
let's find out how much we have
understood until now
do you remember the difference between a
cipher and ciphertext
leave your answers in the comments and
before we proceed if you find this video
interesting make sure to give it a
thumbs up before moving ahead
let's look at symmetric encryption first
symmetric encryption uses a single key
for both the encryption and decryption
of data it is comparatively less secure
than asymmetric encryption but much
faster
it is a compromise that has to be
embraced in order to deliver data as
fast as possible without leaving
information completely vulnerable
this type of encryption is used when
data rests on servers and identifies
personnel for payment applications and
services the potential drawback with
symmetric encryption is that both the
sender and receiver need to have the
same secret key and it should be kept
hidden at all times
caesar cipher enigma machine are both
symmetric encryption examples that we
will look into further
for example
if alice wants to send a message to bob
she can apply a substitution cipher or a
shift cipher to encrypt the message but
bob must be aware of the same key itself
so he can decrypt it when he finds it
necessary to read the entire message
symmetric encryption uses one of the two
types of ciphers stream ciphers and
block ciphers
block ciphers break the plain text into
blocks of fixed size and use the key to
convert it into ciphertext
stream ciphers convert the plain text
into ciphertext one bit at a time
instead of resorting to breaking them up
into bigger chunks
in today's world the most widely used
symmetric encryption algorithm is aes
256 that stands for advanced encryption
standard which has a key size of 256 bit
with 128 bit and 196 bit key sizes also
being available
other primitive algorithms like the data
encryption standard that is the des the
triple data encryption standard 3des and
blowfish have all fallen out of favor
due to the rise of aes
aes chops ups the data into blocks and
performs 10 plus rounds of obscuring and
substituting the message to make it
unreadable
asymmetric encryption on the other hand
has a double whammy at its disposal
there are two different keys at play
here a public key and a private key the
public key is used to encrypt
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the information
post transit if alice wants to
communicate with bob using asymmetric
encryption
she encrypts the message using bob's
public key
after receiving the message bob uses his
own private key to decrypt the data this
way nobody can intercept the message in
between transmissions and there is no
need for any secure key exchange for
this to work since the encryption is
done with the public key and the
decryption is done with a private key
that no one except bob has access to
both the keys are necessary to read the
full message
there is also a reverse scenario where
we can use the private key for
encryption and the public key for
decryption
a server can sign non-confidential
information using its private key and
anyone who has its public key can
decrypt the message
this mechanism also proves that the
sender is authenticated and there is no
problem with the origin of the
information
rsa encryption is the most widely used
asymmetric encryption standard it is
named after its founders reversed shamir
and edelman and it uses block ciphers
that separate the data into blocks and
obscure the information
widely considered the most secure form
of encryption albeit relatively slower
than aes it is widely used in web
browsing secure identification vpns
emails and chat applications
with so much hanging on the key secrecy
there must be a way to transmit the keys
without others reading our private data
many systems use a combination of
symmetric encryption and asymmetric
encryption to bolster security and match
speed at the same time
since asymmetric encryption takes longer
to decrypt large amounts of data the
full information is encrypted using a
single key that is symmetric encryption
that single key is then transmitted to
the receiver using asymmetric encryption
so you don't have to compromise either
way another route is using the
diffie-hellman key exchange which relies
on a one-way function and is much
tougher to break into the third variant
of cryptography is termed as hashing
hashing is the process of scrambling a
piece of data beyond recognition it
gives an output of fixed size which is
known as the hash value of the original
data or just hash in general
the calculations that do the job of
messing up the data collection form the
hash function
they are generally not reversible
without resilient brute force mechanisms
and are very helpful when storing data
on website servers that need not be
stored in plain text
for example many websites store your
account passwords in a hashed format so
that not even the administrator can read
your credentials
when a user tries to log in they can
compare the entered passwords hash value
with the hash value that is already
stored on the servers for authentication
since the function will always return
the same value for the same input
cryptography has been in practice for
centuries
julius caesar used a substitution shift
to move alphabets a certain number of
spaces beyond their place in the
alphabet table
a spy can't decipher the original
message at first glance for example if
he wanted to pass confidential
information to his armies and decides to
use the substitution shift of plus 2 a
becomes c b becomes d and so on the word
attack when passed through a
substitution shift of plus 3 becomes dw
defn
this cipher has been appropriately named
the caesar cipher which is one of the
most widely used algorithms
the enigma is probably the most famous
cryptographic cipher device used in
ancient history
it was used by the nazi german armies in
the world wars they were used to protect
confidential political
military and administrative information
and it consisted of three or more rotors
that scrambled the original message
depending on the machine state at that
time the decryption is similar but it
needs both machines to stay in the same
state before passing the cipher text so
that we received the same plain text
message
let's take a look at how our data is
protected while we browse the internet
thanks to cryptography here we have a
web-based tool that will help us
understand the process of rsa encryption
we see the entire workflow from
selecting the key size to be used until
the decryption of the cipher text in
order to get the plain text back
as we already know rsa encryption
algorithm falls under the umbrella of
asymmetric key cryptography
that basically implies that we have two
keys at play here a public key and a
private key
typically the public key is used by the
sender to encrypt the message and the
private key is used by the receiver to
decrypt the message there are some
occasions when this allocation is
reversed and we will have a look at them
as well
in rsa we have the choice of key size we
can select any key from a 512 bit to
1024 bit all the way up to a 4096-bit
key
the longer the key length the more
complex the encryption process becomes
and thereby strengthening the cipher
text
although with added security more
complex functions take longer to perform
the same operations on similar size of
data we have to keep a balance between
both speed and strength because the
strongest encryption algorithms are of
no use if they cannot be practically
deployed in systems around the world
let's take a 1024 bit key over here
now we need to generate the keys
this generation is done by functions
that operate on pass phrases the tool we
are using right now generates these
pseudorandom keys to be used in this
explanation
once we generate the keys you can see
the public key is rather smaller than
the private key which is almost always
the case
these two keys are mathematically linked
with each other
they cannot be substituted with any
other key and in order to encrypt the
original message or decrypt the cipher
text this pair must be kept together the
public key is then sent to the sender
and the receiver keeps the private key
with himself
in this scenario let's try and encrypt a
word simply learn
we have to select if the key being used
for encryption is either private or
public since that affects the process of
scrambling the information since we are
using the public key over here let's
select the same
and copy it and paste over here
the cipher we are using right now is
plain rsa there are some modified
ciphers with their own pros and cons
that can also be used provided we use it
on a regular basis and depending on the
use case as well
once we click on encrypt we can see the
ciphertext being generated over here
the pseudorandom generating functions
are created in such a way that a single
character change in the plaintext will
trigger a completely different cipher
text this is a security feature to
strengthen the process from brute force
methods
now that we are done with the encryption
process let's take a look at the
decryption part
the receiver gets this cipher text from
the sender with no other key or
supplement
he or she must already possess the
private key generated from the same pair
no other private key can be used to
decrypt the message since they are
mathematically linked
we paste the private key here and select
the same
the cipher must always so be the same
used during the encryption process
once we click decrypt you can see the
original plain text we had decided to
encrypt this sums up the entire process
of rsa encryption and decryption
now some people use it the other way
around we also have the option of using
the private key to encrypt information
and the public key to decrypt it this is
done mostly to validate the origin of
the message since the keys only work in
pairs if a different private key is used
to encrypt the message the public key
cannot decrypt it conversely if the
public key is able to decrypt the
message it must have been encrypted with
the right private key and hence the
rightful owner
here we just have to take the private
key
and use that to encrypt the plain text
and select the same in this checkbox as
well
you can see we have generated a
completely new cipher text
this cipher text will be sent to the
receiver and this time we will use the
public key for decryption
let's select the correct checkbox and
decrypt
and we still get the same output
now let's take a look at practical
example of encryption in the real world
we all use the internet on a daily basis
and many are aware of the implications
of using unsafe websites
let's take a look at wikipedia here
pretty standard https website where the
h stands for secured
let's take a look at how it secures that
data
wireshark is the world's foremost and
most widely used network protocol
analyzer it lets you see what's
happening on your network at a
microscopic level
and we are going to use the software to
see the traffic that is leaving a
machine and to understand how vulnerable
it is
since there are many applications
running in this machine let's apply a
filter that will only show us the
results related to wikipedia
[Music]
let's search for something that we can
navigate the website with
okay once we get into it a little you
can see some of the requests being
populated over here
let's take a look at the specific
request
these are the data packets that
basically transport the data from our
machine to the internet and vice versa
as you can see there's a bunch of
gibberish data here that doesn't really
reveal anything that we searched or
watched similarly other secured websites
function the same way and it is very
difficult if at all possible to snoop on
user data this way
to put this in perspective
let's take a look at another website
which is a http web page
this has no encryption enabled from the
server end which makes it vulnerable to
attacks
there is a login form here which needs
legitimate user credentials in order to
grant access
let's enter a random pair of credentials
these obviously won't work but we can
see the manner of data transfer
unsurprisingly we weren't able to get
into the platform
instead we can see the data packets
let's apply a similar filter that will
help us understand
what request this website is sending
these are the requests being sent by the
http login form to the internet if we
check here
see whatever username and password that
we are entering we can easily see it
with the wireshark
now we used a dummy pair of credentials
if we select the right data packet we
can find our correct credentials
if any website had asked for a payment
information or a legitimate credentials
it would have been really easy to get a
hold of these
to reiterate what we have already
learned we must always avoid http
websites and just unknown or not
trustworthy websites in general because
the problem we saw here is just the tip
of the iceberg even though cryptography
has managed to lessen the risk of cyber
attacks it is still prevalent and we
should always be alert to keep ourselves
safe online due to the increase in the
network transactions
in the modern era there are often cases
when we face some problems regarding
network issues
but
are they exactly network issues or is
somebody spying on us
well such cases are regarded as network
sniffing cases
but how exactly a hacker hack into a
network system
well for today's topic we'll understand
the same
let's take a look at network sniffing
to access the network related
information between devices to gain
profit or use the hacked data for
illegal purpose is known as network
sniffing
this is a process where a hacker or a
measures programmer
spy into the network devices of our
system
they can access different websites that
we visit often
or see our network habits
let's take a look at different tools
that are suitable for sniffing purpose
network sniffing tools are software's
that are available on the internet that
can be used to sniff into the network
let's take a look at some of the famous
network tools
first one is awake
this is a networking sniffing tool which
has specialization in intelligent
analysis for network packets
next is wireshark this software tool is
best to look into protocol related data
packets that are often transmitted over
the network
and lastly we have solar wind network
packet sniffer
where the performance of this sniffing
tool is best where the performance
management is to be looked into
let's take a look at the wireshark
sniffing tool this is an open source
network sniffing software which is
specifically designed to attack data
packets during the transmission over the
network
this type of software uses different
color combinations to represent
different packets and protocols let's
take a look at some of the uses for the
sniffing software
the first uses it is used to analyze
network packets whereas it can also be
used to troubleshoot different network
issues which are often used by different
engineers to test whether the software
or a network device is susceptible to an
attack
and lastly it is also used to check
malicious and hacking possibilities on
the network
now that we are completed with the
briefing for the software that is known
as wireshark let's take a look at the
actual demo how exactly network sniffing
is done
you can directly access
the wireshark software website
where you can find the download option
and download the most suitable
version for your laptop or computer
device
after downloading the software when you
install it
you will get something like this
as we can see these connections are the
connections that are connected to my
laptop right now
and the difference in the graph that we
can see over here represent the traffic
on the network that is present
to much better understand what exactly
is going on the network we can access
one of them let's access the wi-fi
network on my laptop
after accessing the network
we can see some packet settings like
this
these represents the packet transaction
that has been made on my network through
the internet
and this is how a hacker or a cyber
criminal knows how exactly we use a
network services
this part of the wireshark represents
different detail information about the
transaction that has been made
and the last section represents some raw
data or garbage data
but how exactly a hacker use all this
jumbled data and hack into a system
well
to clarify this there's an option that
can be used that is known as display
filter on the wireshark software
if you want to search for a specific
protocol for example tcp
we can write tcp in the search filter
and search
and now as we can see
we only get the protocols that are
related to tcp
this is how we can differentiate
different protocols and access some of
them to gain knowledge about what
exactly is going on in the network
let's try accessing some other protocol
now
for example
dns
and as we can see
only the protocol and the data packet
that is related to dns protocol is
visible to us
to further enhance the display filter
let's try accessing a
different page on the web browser for
example
simplylearn.com
when we access the simply learn website
we can see the professional courses that
are available
but let's take a look at the changes
that has been made on the y shark
to know this let's write
tcp and a keyword included contains
and one more thing to include over eis
during the display filter if you write
something that is related to the
software it will represent in a green
color
like this
but if you write some error related
keywords like this it will represent in
the red
let's continue with the search setting
including the contains keyword and
writing
simply learn
and entering
now as we can see these two related data
packets represent the simply learn
website that we access just now
where the source destination ip address
represent
my system address whereas the
destination that is
13.224.21.74 represent the simply learns
ip address let's take a look
and in the garbage area or the raw data
we can take a look simply learn website
to see some more details regarding the
same
you can access the transport layer
security
and the transmission control protocol
where we can see the source port the
destination port which is always 443
as well as
the flag
and the time stamp for the same
this is how hackers get the data about
our network settings
but if we want to search for more data
related to simply learn website that we
visited just now
there's an another filter that we can
use
for example
using ip.addr
space equal equal and writing the ip
address for the website simply learn
that is
30.224.21.74
and when we press enter we get all the
related data for the simply learn
website
and this is how we can see the related
data
to much further enhance our display
settings let's try another example
access your internet browser
and access some other website for
example
dot
for example the state university
and access the allahabad state
university and
some other part in it for example the
university state
pdf
let's see the changes in our wireshark
settings
and try using http
when we write this we get the data that
is related to the http but what is the
use for the same
when you access this
and right click on the same
and choose the option follow
and http stream
and over here we can take a look at the
host that is
the website that we just visited
now imagine if we were a hacker and we
knew all this
we can access any website that our user
visited
and we can hack into his system through
the website
guys but the point that has to be noted
over here is if we use the network
sniffing tool wireshark or some other
tool that is
available on the internet for research
purpose or experimental use that's fine
but we shouldn't use all these softwares
for any malicious activity because that
is illegal
now
some of the options that we can see are
the red box
this action is used if we want to stop
the traffic connection that means if we
press this option
and clear this
and press enter
this shows
that the network settings has stopped
receiving any traffic that is available
on the network but if we want to access
them again
we can choose this bluefin
option continue without saving
and the software against
start recording the websites
or the data packets that are available
on the network
now let's take a look at an example as
we all know we often visit different
websites and there are some cases we
often see when the chrome represent a
non-secure option
that represents that the website is
unprotected against network attack
for example we can access our
experimental website
this is a website that allows us to
access the non-secure part of a website
if we write for username as
admin1213
and for password as
simply learn
and login
as this is an experimental website it
says
it's sorry and the login has failed
let's see the changes in a wireshark
software
now as we already did earlier if we want
to access a specific website we should
write
tcp
contains and the keyword of the website
that was
admin
through this we can see this was the
website that we visited just now
but if we want to access the actual
important data that was the password
that we typed
we can use this option
and over here we can see the simply
learn
which was encrypted earlier in the
website
this is how a hacker or a cyber criminal
use different sniffing softwares and
gain data about different users
in this video we bring you the best
programming languages for hacking here
we will give you the top 5 programming
languages that will help you enhance
your hacking skills
first let's understand the importance of
knowing programming for hacking
you might wonder if programming is a
necessity to become a hacker as you
might be aware hacking involves breaking
the protocols and exploiting a network
thus being a hacker requires you to
understand the languages of the software
that you are focusing on
hence it is required that a hacker knows
coding having zero coding knowledge will
definitely limit your opportunities in
the future
knowing different programming languages
is undoubtedly an asset for hackers
everyone wants to become a hacker today
however it is not as easy as it is shown
in numerous movies it takes plenty of
practice and programming knowledge to
become an ethical hacking expert
if you want to become a hacker it is
imperative that you have a knack for
programming languages it is a known fact
that some of the world's best hackers
started off as programmers
if you know how to program you will be
able to dissect a code and analyze it
you can write your scripts or malware
that can be used on the victim yes there
are several ready-made scripts available
today however you might need to apply
your skills in case the available
scripts don't work well for you
sometimes when script modification is
required you should be in a position to
do that in such a scenario zero
knowledge of the respective programming
language will definitely be a hindrance
programs can also help you automate
multiple tasks which would normally take
a lot of time
codes allow you to penetrate different
fields you want to hack it will help you
identify the plan behind an attack and
defend against deadly hacking techniques
and make your cybersecurity career
worthwhile
it will help you understand the working
of the target system or application
before carrying out an exploit
now that we have an idea as to why
programming is important for hackers let
us understand which programming
languages should a hacker learn
there are several programming languages
for hacking and it might be overwhelming
to choose from the endless list
here we are to help you with that
do keep in mind that your choice of
programming language will also depend on
the type of system you are targeting and
your strategy
let us now move on to the list of the
top programming languages that are
extensively used by hackers around the
world
as you see on your screens here we have
the top 5 programming languages for
hackers let us go through them one by
one
number one on our list is one of the
most popular programming languages today
that is python
python is a general purpose programming
language and in the field of hacking it
is mainly used for exploit writing
it is referred to as the de facto
hacking programming language it plays a
crucial role in writing hacking scripts
exploits and malicious programs
one great feature that makes hacking
easy with python is the availability of
ready-made modules
for example os modules are available if
the target is a native operating system
for networking there is a socket module
and a lot more
python socket programming can be used
for discovering vulnerabilities in a
system since python code helps in
checking the security integrity of
systems and it can also be used to
exploit them
python has a massive community that
helps with third party plugins every day
it is also an easy to read language with
a simple syntax this will be helpful for
beginners you can easily write
automation scripts using python and it
also makes prototyping much faster
moving on to our second programming
language we have javascript
currently javascript is one of the best
programming languages for hacking web
applications
a good understanding of javascript
allows a hacker to discover
vulnerabilities and carry web
exploitation since most of their web
apps use javascript or one of its
libraries
knowing javascript will help you
discover flaws in web applications
javascript can be used to read saved
cookies and security experts also use
javascript to develop cross-site
scripting programs for hacking
javascript is known for carrying out
attacks like cross-site scripting
javascript can also be used to spread
and reproduce malware and viruses easily
initially javascript was a client-side
scripting language however with the
release of node.js it now supports
back-end development this implies a
larger field for exploitation
a hacker can now use javascript to snoop
the type towards inject malicious code
and track browsing history to name a few
number three on our list is php
hypertext preprocessor or php is a
dynamic server-side programming language
that is used to build websites
hackers should understand php as it will
help them understand web hacking
techniques better
especially if you are into web hacking
then getting your hands on php would be
an asset
php is used in server-side scripting
using php you could write a custom
application that modifies settings on a
web server and makes a target server
susceptible to attacks
with the help of php you can also
eliminate any vulnerabilities in your
code php is one of the most powerful
server side languages used in most of
the web domains
this shows how learning php can help you
with web hacking and also help you fight
against malicious attackers
popular contact management systems run
on a foundation of php hence having a
strong knowledge of php can help you
protect or compromise such websites
next on a list of the best programming
languages for hackers is sql
sql is the acronym for structured query
language
although sql is not a traditional
programming language it is a language
used for only communicating with
databases
several systems like mysql postgresql
store their data in databases
sql is used to interact with such
databases in order to organize add
retrieve delete or edit data from a
database
having an in-depth knowledge of sql lets
you comprehend the structure of a
database thereby helping you decide
which scripts or tools to deploy
sql is used for the purpose of web
hacking sql is undoubtedly the best
programming language when it comes to
hacking into large databases
it will be impossible to counteract
database attacks without a good
understanding of sql
using sql hackers can perform an attack
known as sql injection attack such an
attack enables hackers to access
confidential information from databases
sql is used by hackers to develop
various hacking programs based on sql
injection
sql injection is used to bypass web
application login algorithms that are
weak
such an attack can also help a hacker
view and modify confidential information
from databases
finally at number 5 we have the c
programming language
it is no surprise that we have c the
mother of all programming languages on
our list
it is used massively in the security
field it helps with exploit writing and
development
the low level nature of c provides an
edge over other programming languages
used for hacking
a hacker can use the c programming
language to his or her advantage when it
comes to accessing low-level hardware
components such as the ram
security professionals mostly uc when
they are required to manipulate system
resources and hardware
c also helps penetration testers write
programming scripts
most operating systems and computer
programs are coded in c language hence
learning c you will help hackers get an
overview of the structure of operating
systems
c is also used to create shell codes
root kits exploits built undetectable
malware keyloggers and much more
sometimes it is also advisable to learn
both c and c plus plus as they both come
in handy for hackers
so those were our top five programming
languages for hackers do keep in mind
that the most important step of becoming
a hacker is to learn various programming
languages it will be great if you can
master a variety of programming
languages as your target will not be the
same always
on that note in addition to previously
mentioned programming languages we have
an additional list of languages that are
also well recognized for hacking let's
have a look at our honorary mention
first we have ruby the ruby programming
language has been used for exploitation
for quite some time now
there can be a close comparison drawn
between ruby and python based on its
syntax
however ruby is more web focused
ruby can be used to write either small
or large scripts and can be used
interchangeably with bash scripting
it offers good flexibility while writing
exploits ruby has been used by several
hackers to exploit corporate systems it
is not that easy to master ruby and that
is one reason why mncs look for
professionals who know ruby
second we have pearl
although pearl has lost its old fame it
still holds value in the hacker
community for exploit writing
there are systems that still run on
pearl as it was the go-to solution once
it is a great language that can help you
manipulate linex text files and help you
create tools and exploits
perl code bases still do occupy a
considerable portion of corporate tools
third on our list is html
many of you might have wondered why we
didn't mention html yet
yes no programming list is complete
without mentioning html
the hyper text markup language html is a
standard markup language used for
creating web pages
it glows the whole internet together and
it is the language of the web this shows
the importance html has
an understanding of html is vital to
play with web applications
html also finds its use in developing
hybrid mobile and desktop apps
html is a must if you want to master
this field having said that html is not
that tough for language to learn hence
it is advised to master html if you want
to compromise web applications
and finally at 4 we have assembly level
language
it is undoubtedly one of the most
powerful yet hardest programming
languages to learn
it is a complicated low-level
programming language
for hacking primitive systems assembly
is one of the best programming languages
the best part of assembly is that you
can instruct machine hardware or
software using it
assembly language helps a hacker
manipulate systems straight up at the
architecture level
it is also the most suited coding
language to build malware like viruses
and trojans
it is considered to be the best language
for jobs that are time critical
reverse engineers use assembly language
for example if you're interested in
software cracking and if you want to
reverse engineer a piece of software
that has already been compiled assembly
is the go-to choice
as complicated as a language sounds the
results it produces are highly fruitful
so those were the additional programming
languages that can help you become a
skilled and successful hacker we should
keep in mind that a strong understanding
of programming languages help cyber
security professionals stay on top of
cyber criminals
the day is 26 february 2022
the world is hit with breaking news that
russian state tv channels have been
hacked by anonymous a hacktivist
collective and movement who have made a
name taking part in multiple cyber wars
in the past decade
this was in response to the russian
aggression on ukrainian territory in the
hopes of annexation
anonymous hacked the russian state tv
networks to combat propaganda in russia
and highlight the damage to life meted
out by the kremlin in ukraine
they also hacked 120 000 russian troops
personal information and the russian
central bank stealing 35 000 files
this served as a clear indicator of how
cyber war can change the momentum in
battle something which people have never
seen so closely
so what is cyber war
a digital assault or series of strikes
or hacks against a country is sometimes
referred to as a cyber war it has the
ability to cause havoc on government and
civilian infrastructure as well as
disrupt essential systems causing state
harm and even death
in this day and age the internet plays a
bigger role than just watching videos
and learning content
it's where you have your personal data
and carry financial transactions so
rather than resorting to physical
violence cyber wars become the new means
to cause havoc considering the
vulnerability of the data passing
through the internet
in most circumstances
cyber warfare involves a nation-state
attacking another
in certain cases the assaults are
carried out by terrorist organizations
or non-state actors pursuing a hostile
nation's aim in june 2021 chinese
hackers targeted organizations like
verizon to secure remote access to their
networks
stuxnet was a computer worm designed to
attack iran's nuclear facilities but
evolved and expanded to many other
industrial and energy producing sites in
2010
since the definition of cyber war is so
vague applying rules and sanctions based
on digital assault is even tougher
making the field of cyber warfare a
lawless land not bound by any rules or
policies there are multiple ways in
which these attacks can be carried out
a major category of cyber attack is
espionage
espionage entails monitoring other
countries to steal critical secrets
this might include compromising
vulnerable computer systems with botnets
or spear phishing attempts before
extracting sensitive data in cyber
warfare
the next weapon in cyber war is sabotage
government agencies must identify
sensitive data and its dangers if it is
exploited
insider threats such as disgruntled or
irresponsible personnel or government
staff with ties to the attacking country
can be used by hostile countries or
terrorists to steal or destroy
information
by overwhelming a website with bogus
requests and forcing it to handle them
denial of service attacks prohibit real
users from accessing it
attacking parties may use this form of
assault to disrupt key operations and
systems and prevent citizens military
and security officials and research
organizations from accessing sensitive
websites
but what benefits does cyberwar offer in
contrast to traditional physical warfare
the most important advantage is the
ability to conduct attacks from anywhere
global without having to travel
thousands of miles
as long as the attacker and target are
connected to the internet organizing and
launching cyber wars is relatively less
tedious than physical warfare
people living in or battling for a
country are subjected to propaganda
attacks in an attempt to manipulate
their emotions and thoughts
digital infrastructure is highly crucial
today's modern world
starting from communication channels to
secure storage servers crippling a
country's footprint and control on the
internet is very damaging
but what are some of the ways we as
citizens protect ourselves in the case
of a cyber war in the unfortunate event
that your country is involved in warfare
be sure to fact check every piece of
information and follow only trusted
sources in that frame of time
even conversations online should be
limited to a need to know basis
considering propaganda campaigns have
the power to influence the tide of war
drastically
it is highly crucial to follow basic
security guidelines to secure our
devices like regularly updating our
operating systems occasionally running
full system antivirus scans etc
if your country organization is being
attacked having devices segregated in a
network goes a long way in bolstering
security
try to avoid sharing a lot of personal
data online
in this era of instagram and facebook
divulging private information can be
detrimental to keeping a secure firewall
for your data
the more information an attacker has
access to the higher his chances of
being able to devise a plan to
infiltrate defenses
kali linux is an operating system that
has become a well-known weapon in this
fight against hackers a linux
distribution that is made specifically
for penetration testers let's start by
learning about kali linux in general
kali linux which is formerly known as
backtrack linux is an open source linux
distribution aimed at advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing
it contains several hundred tools that
are targeted towards various information
security tasks such as penetration
testing security research computer
forensics and reverse engineering
kali linux is a multiple platform
solution accessible and freely available
to information security professionals
and hobbyists
among all the linux distributions kali
linux takes its roots from the debian
operating system
debian has been a highly dependable and
stable distribution for many years
providing a similarly strong foundation
to the kali desktop
while the operating system is capable of
practically modifying every single part
of our installation the networking
components of kali become disabled by
default this is done to prevent any
external factors from affecting the
installation procedure which may pose a
risk in critical environments
apart from boosting security it allows a
deeper element of control to the most
enthusiastic of users
we did not get kali linux since the
first day how did it come into existence
let's take a look at some of its history
kali linux is based on years of
knowledge and experience in building
penetration testing and operating
systems
during all these project lifelines there
have been only a few different
developers as the team has always been
small
the first project was called vorpx which
stands for white hat nopex
as can be inferred from the name it was
based on the nopix operating system as
its underlying os
topics had releases ranging from version
2.0 to 2.7
this made way for the next project which
was known as wax or the long hand being
white hat slacks the name change was
because the base os was changed from
nopix to slacks
wax started at version 3 as a nord it
carrying on from warpex
there was a similar os being produced at
the same time auditor security
collection often being shorted to just
auditor which was once again using nopex
its efforts were combined with wax to
produce backtrack
backtrack was based on slackware from
version 1 to version 3 but switched to
ubuntu later on with version 4 to
version 5.
using the experience gain from all of
this kali linux came after backtrack in
2013.
kali started off using debian stable as
the engine under the hood before moving
to debian testing when kali linux became
a rolling operating system
now that we understand the history and
the purpose of kali linux let us learn a
little more about its distinct features
the latest version of kali comes with
more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed
after reviewing every tool that was
included in backtrack developers have
eliminated a great number of tools that
either simply did not work or which
duplicated other tools that provided the
same or similar functionality
the kali linux team is made up of a
small group of individuals who are the
only ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the depositories all of
which is done using multiple secure
protocols
restricting access of critical code
bases to external asset greatly reduces
the risk of source contamination which
can cause kali linux users worldwide a
great deal of damage as a direct victim
of cyber crime
although penetration tools tend to be
written in english the developers have
ensured that kali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in their native language and
locate the tools they need for the job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a strong
hold over the configuration and the
device in general
since arm based single board systems
like the raspberry pi are becoming more
and more prevalent and inexpensive the
development team knew that kali's arm
support would need to be as robust as
they could manage with fully working
installations
kali linux is available on a wide range
of arm devices and has arm repositories
integrated with the mainline
distributions so the tools for arm are
updated in conjunction with the rest of
the distribution
all this information is necessary for
users to determine if kali linux is the
correct choice for them
if it is what are the ways that they can
go forward with this installation and
start their penetration testing journey
the first way to use kali linux is by
launching the distribution in the live
usb mode this can be achieved by
downloading the installer image file or
the iso file from the kali linux website
and flashing it to a usb drive with a
capacity of at least 8 gb
some people don't need to save their
data permanently and a live usb is the
perfect solution for such cases
after the iso image is flashed the thumb
drive can be used to boot a fully
working installation of the operating
system with the caviar that any changes
made to the os in this mode are not
written permanently some cases allow
persistent usage in live usbs but those
require further configuration than
normal situations
but what if the user wants to store data
permanently in the installed os
the best and the most reliable way to
ensure this is the full fledged hard
disk installation
this will ensure the complete usage of
the system's hardware capabilities and
will take into account the updates and
the configurations being made to the os
this method is supposed to overwrite any
pre-existing operating system installed
on the computer be it windows or any
other variant of linux
the next alternative route for
installing kali linux would be to use
virtualization software such as vmware
or virtualbox
the software will be installed as a
separate application on an already
existing os and kali linux can be run as
an operating system in the same computer
as a window
the hardware requirements will be
completely customizable starting with
the allotted ram to the virtual hard
disk capacity
the usage of both a host and guest
operating system like our linux allows
users a safe environment to learn while
not putting the systems at risk
if you want to learn more about how one
can go forward with this method we have
a dedicated video where kali linux is
being installed on vmware while running
on a windows 10 operating system you can
find the link in the description box to
get started with your very own virtual
machine
the final way to install kali linux is
by using a dual boot system
to put it in simple words the kali linux
os will not be overwriting any
pre-installed operating system on a
machine but will be installed alongside
it when a computer boots up the user
will get a choice to boot into either of
these operating systems
many people prefer to keep both the
windows and kali linux installed so the
distribution of work and recreational
activities is also allotted effectively
it gives users a safety valve should
their custom linux installation run into
any bugs that cannot be fixed from
within the operating system there are
multiple ways to install kali linux we
can either install it on a normal hard
drive in a virtual machine software such
as vmware or virtualbox or we can do
that in hard bare metal machines now for
the convenience of explanation we're
going to install kali linux today on a
virtual machine software known as vmware
vmware is able to run multiple operating
systems on a single host machine which
in our case is a windows 10 system
to get started with kali linux
installation
we have to go to the website
to download an image file
we go to get kali
and as you can see there are multiple
platforms on which this operating system
can be inverted
as per our requirement we're going to go
with the virtual message section as you
can see it is already recommended by the
developers
this is the download button which will
download a 64-bit iso file we can
download 32-bit but that is more
necessary for
hard metal machines or if you're going
to use it for older devices which do not
support 64-bit operating systems yet
after clicking on the download button
we can see we have a window archive
which will have the iso files
for now we have downloaded the iso file
and it is already present with me so we
can start working on the vmware side of
things
once the iso file is downloaded we open
up vmware workstation
go to file
and we create a new virtual machine
in these two options it is highly
recommended to go with the typical setup
rather than the custom one the custom is
much more advanced and requires much
more information from the user which is
beneficial for developers and people who
are well versed with virtualization
software but for 90 of the cases typical
setup will be enough
here we can select the third option
which will be i will install the
operating system later
in some operating systems we can use the
iso file here directly and vmware will
install it for us but for right now in
the case of kali linux the third option
is always the safest
kali linux is a linux distribution so we
can select linux over here and the
version as you can see here
have multiple versions such as the
multiple kernels
every distribution
has of a parent distribution for example
kali linux has debian and there are
other distributions which are based or
forked from some parent distribution
kalinas is based off debian so we can go
with the highest version of debian which
is the debian 10. x 64-bit
go on next we can write any such name we
can write
kali linux so that it will be easier to
recognize the virtual machine among this
list of virtual machine instances
the location can be any location you
decide to put by default it should be
the documents folder but anywhere you
put it will hold up all the information
of the operating system all the files
you download all the configurations you
store everything will be stored in this
particular location that you provide
when we go next
we are asked about the disk capacity
this disk capacity will be all the
storage that will be provided to your
virtual machine of kali linux think of
your windows device
if you have a one terabyte of hard drive
you have the entirety of the hard disk
to store data on how much data you give
here you can only store up to that
amount of data not to mention some
amount of capacity will be taken up by
the operating system itself to store its
programs and applications
for now we can give around let's say 15
gb of information or if it's recommended
size for debian is 20 you can just go
ahead at 20. it depends all on the user
case if you are going to use it
extensively you can even go as high as
50 or 60 gb if you have plans to
download many more applications and
perform multiple different tests
another option we get over here is
storing virtual disks as a single file
or storing them into multiple files
as we already know this virtual machine
runs entirely on vmware
sometimes when transferring these
virtual machine instances let's say from
a personal computer to a work computer
we're going to need to copy up the
entire folder that we had mentioned
before over here
instead all virtual machines have a
portability feature now this portability
feature is possible
for all scenarios except it is much
easier if the split the virtual disk
into multiple files
now even if this makes what
porting virtual machines easier from
either
system to system or
software to software let's say if you
want to switch from vmware to virtualbox
or vice versa the performance takes a
small hit it's not
huge but it's recommended to go with
storing the virtual list as a single
file if you have no purposes of ever
moving the virtual machine even if you
do it's not a complete stop that it
cannot be ported it's just easier when
using multiple files but in order to get
the best performance out with the
virtual machine we can store it as a
single file over here
this is a summary of all the changes
that we made and all the configurations
that have been settled until now
now at this point of time we have not
provided the dot iso file yet which is
the installation file for the kali linux
that we downloaded from this website
as of right now we have only configured
the settings of the virtual machine so
we can press on finish
and we have kali linux in the list
now
to make the changes further we press on
edit virtual machine settings
the memory is supposed to give the ram
of the virtual machine
so devices with ram of 8 gb or
below that
giving high amount of ram will cause
performance issues and the host system
if the memory has some amount of free
storage left let's say on idle storage
my windows machine takes about 2 gb so i
have 6 gb of memory to provide although
if you provide all of the 6 gb it will
be much more difficult for the host
system to run everything properly so for
this instance we can keep it as 2gb of
memory for the virtual machine instance
similarly we can use the number of
processors and we can customize it
according to our liking let's say if we
want to use one processor but we want to
use two different cores we can select
them as well
hard disk is pre-set up as the scsi
hardest and it does not need to be
changed for the installation of this
operating system at all
cdid dvd this is where the installation
file comes
you can think of the iso file that we
downloaded as a pen drive or usb thumb
drive which is necessary to install an
operating system to provide this
we're going to select use iso image file
we're going to click on browse
go and go to downloads
and select the i am so file over here
select open
and we can see it is already loaded up
next in the network adapter it is
recommended to use nat
this helps the virtual machine to draw
the internet from the host machine
settings if your host machine is
connected to the internet then the
virtual machine is connected as well
there are some other options such as
host only or custom segments or lan
segments but those are not necessary for
installation
rest of them are pretty standard which
do not need any extra configuration and
can be left as it is
press ok
and now we can power on this virtual
machine
in this screen we can choose how we want
to proceed with the installation
we have a start installer option over
here
so we're going to press enter on that
we're going to wait for the things to
load from the iso file
the first step in the installation is
choosing the language of the operating
system
for this we can go with english as
standard
this is a location this will be used for
setting up the time and some of the
internal settings which depend entirely
on the location
of the user so for this we're going to
go with india
configuring the keyboard it's always
recommended to go with the american
english first many people make a mistake
of going with the indian keyboard if it
is possible and it provides a lot of
issues later on so it's always preferred
to go with the american english and if
later we see some necessity of another
keyboard dialect that is required we can
install it later but for now we should
always stick with american english as a
basic
at this point it's going to load the
installation components from the dot iso
file
it is a big file of 3.6 gb so it has a
lot of components that need to be put
into the virtual machine which can also
be used to detect hardware
once the hardware and the network
configuration is done by the iso file we
want to write a host name for the system
this hostname can be anything which is
used to recognize this device on a local
network or a lan cable let's say if we
use the name kali
domain name you we can skip it for now
it's not necessary as such for the
installation
this is the full name for the user
let's say we can provide the name as
simply learn as a full name
next we're going to set up a username
this username is going to be necessary
to identify the user from its you root
accounts and the subsequent below
accounts
for now we can give it as something as
simply123
now we have to choose a password for the
user now remember since this is the
first user that is being added onto this
newly installed operating system it
needs to be a password for the
administrator
we can use whichever password we like
over here
and use the same password below and
press on continue
at this point it's going to detect on
the components on which the operating
system can be installed
like here
there are multiple options like the use
entire disk use entire disk and setup
lvm this entire disk can set up
encrypted lvm for newcomers it is
recommended to just use the first one
since lvm encryption is something that
you can learn afterwards when you are
much more hands-on with the linux
operating system for now we are going to
use the use entire disk guided
installation and press on continue
when we set up the virtual machine on
vmware we had set up a disk capacity
there we gave our purpose 20 gb
that is the hardest which is being
discovered here
even though it is a virtual disk
on vmware it acts as a normal hard disk
on which an operating system can be
installed
so we select this one and press on
continue
here there is a multiple partition
system
all the operating systems that are
installed have different components one
is used for the keeping of the
applications one for the files other for
the ram management and other things for
newcomers it is always recommended to
keep it in one partition
and we're going to select that and press
on continue
this is just an overview of the
partition it's going to make as you can
see it has a primary partition of 20.4
gb and a logical partition of 1 gb used
for swap memory now these kind of naming
can be confusing for people who are not
well versed with linux operating systems
or in general virtualization but for now
you can go ahead and press on continue
as this will be fine
we can press on finish partitioning and
write changes to disk
and continue
it's just a confirmation page
as you can see it said that scsi3 is our
virtual hard disk of 20 gb disk capacity
we write the changes to the disk
we press yes and click on continue
at this point the installation has
started now this installation will take
a while depending on the
amount of ram provided the processors
provided and how quickly the performance
of the system is being hampered by the
host machine on quicker systems this
will be rather quick while on the
smaller ones this will take a while
since this is going to take some time to
install as it is being run on a virtual
machine with only 2 gb of ram we're
going to speed up this part of the video
so we don't have to waste any more time
just watching the progress bar
now that our core installation is
completed it's asking us to configure a
package manager the work of a package
manager on linux operating systems is
similar to the google play store on
android mobile devices and on the app
store for the apple devices
it's an interface to install external
applications which are not installed by
default let's say for google chrome or
any other browser which can be used to
browse the internet
at this point of time is ask us to
select a network mirror we're going to
select as yes and move forward with this
next
it's going to ask us for a http proxy
which we can leave it as blank and press
it as continue forward
at this point of time it's looking for
updates to the kali linux installation
this will fetch the new builds from the
kali server so the installation is
always updated to the latest version
now that the package manager is
configured we have the grub boot loader
the grub is used for selecting the
operating system while booting up
its core functionality is to allow the
operating system to be loaded correctly
without any faults
so at this point of time if it has
installed the grub bootloader to your
primary dive we can select this as yes
and press continue
remember the installation was conducted
on dev sda
so we're going to select installation of
the
loader on the same hard disk that we
have configured
we press this one and press continue
so now the grub bootloader is being
installed
the grub is highly essential because it
is it shows the motherboard where to
start the operating system from
even if the operating system is
installed correctly and all the files
are in correct order
the absence of a bootloader will not be
able to launch the os properly
as you can see the installation is
finally complete
so now we can press on continue
and it's going to finalize the changes
now you can see kali linux being booted
up straight away it doesn't check for
the iso file anymore since the operating
system is now installed onto the virtual
hard disk storage that we had configured
before
here we're going to enter our username
and password that we had set up before
and we have the kali linux system booted
up
and this is your homepage
we can see the installed applications
over here which are being used for
penetration testing by multiple security
analysts worldwide
all of these come pre-installed with
kali linux and others can be installed
using the apt package manager that we
had configured
we can see a full name over here
and with this our installation of the
kali linux is complete
in today's world in organizations most
valuable asset is its information or
data
this is true for all kinds of businesses
be it public or private
on a daily basis they all deal with
enormous amounts of sensitive
information
as a consequence terrorist groups
hacking teams and cyber thieves often
attack them
to ensure the safety and protection
businesses use a variety of security
measures and regularly update their
index
organizations must be proactive in this
age of digitalization by regularly
assessing and updating their security
every day hackers discover new methods
to breach firewalls
ethical hackers or white hath hackers
provide a fresh perspective on security
they conduct penetration tests to
validate security measures
generally they will penetrate your
networks and give you relevant
information about your security posture
once an organization has this knowledge
it may upgrade its security procedures
accordingly
the latest version of kali linux comes
with more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed
after reviewing every tool that was
included in backtrack developers have
eliminated a great number of tools that
either simply did not work
or which duplicated other tools that
provided the same or similar
functionality
occasionally when conducting penetration
testing or hacking we must automate our
activities since there may be hundreds
of conditions and payloads to test and
manually examining everything is time
consuming to improve our productivity we
utilize tools that come pre-packaged
with kali linux
these tools not only save us time but
also accurately capture and process the
data
the kali linux team is made up of a
small group of individuals who are the
only ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the repositories all of
which is done using multiple secure
protocols
restricting access of critical code
bases to external assets greatly reduces
the risk of source contamination
although penetration tools tend to be
written in english the developers have
ensured that kali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need to do for the
job
since arm based single board systems
like the raspberry pi are becoming more
and more prevalent and inexpensive the
development team knew that kali's arm
support would need to be as robust as
they could manage with fully working
installations
kali linux is available on a wide range
of arm devices and as arm repositories
integrated with the mainline
distribution so tools for arm are
updated in conjunction with the rest of
the distribution tools
let's begin with some terminal basics on
kali linux
when most people hear the term linux
they envision a complex operating system
used only by programmers however the
experience is not as frightening as it
appears linux is an umbrella term for a
collection of free and open source unix
operating systems
there are many variants like ubuntu
fedora debian
these are distributions which will be a
more precise term
when using a linux operating system you
will most likely utilize a shell which
is a command line interface that
provides access to the operating system
services the majority of linux
distributions shipped with a graphical
user interface also known as gui as
their primary shell this is done to
facilitate user interaction in the first
place
having said that a command line
interface is suggested due to its
increased power and effectiveness by
entering the commands into the cli tasks
that require a multi-step gui procedure
may be completed in a matter of seconds
we can start the terminal by clicking on
the prompt icon here on top
once the terminal is open
we can put up a comma who's another
command known as mkdir which is supposed
to stand for make directory and i write
nf2 shortage for
new folder too
if i open up the nf
you can see the new folder is created
this is how the pwd command works
another important command
to change directories it's called the cd
command let's say right now if i am in
nf i want to create a new file in an f2
folder or something else in the nf2
folder i have to shift to cd and f2
now if i write pwd
it will show the present working
directory of home simply learn desktop
nf and inside that i am in nf2 right now
it is done to navigate to the linux
files and this directories it requires
either the full path or just the name of
the directory if we have to move a
completely different folder on a
completely different file then we can
use the entire path like this
for now cd works another few commands is
we can write cd
dot dot
and it will come back one folder now the
pwd will be just nf and not nf2
let's say we are in this folder and we
want to go
a different file let's say if we just go
for cd
home
simpler
that's it
right now
these are the folders in our current
present working directory
we have the desktop the documents
downloads etc
from here we can again go to the desktop
using the same cd command
cross check the
changing of directories
and check the files again and yes there
we go nf how do we know this what are
the command that we are used to show the
files and folders that folder is known
as the ls command
ls can be used to view the contents of a
directory by default this command will
display the contents of your current
working directory if we add some other
parameters we can find the contents of
other directories as well
there are some hidden files as well in
linux which cannot be showed just with
ls for example if we just go to cdetc
which is a configuration folder for
linux
if we write ls now these are the files
that can be seen
if we want to see the hidden files we'll
have to add one more parameter here like
ls minus a and as you can see the number
of files have increased this time around
there are other things as well
that we can see with linux
ls minus al will show the hidden files
along with some of the parameters and
some of the permissions that has been
provided for each file
as you can see many of these files have
root access some of them can write some
of them can read
it differs file to file and the ls minus
al command is used to check each of
these files permission and change them
accordingly if needed
the next command that we can look for is
the cat command or concatenate
it is one of the most frequently used
commands and it is used to list the
contents of a file on the output
for example
let's say if i have a file at the
desktop
in this nf2 folder i will create a
document
create an empty file
e5
i'll open up the document
and i'll write it as
hello kali
i will save this up
now to change the directories from etc
to nf2 we have already discussed how to
use the cd command
using just the folder name now if you
want to go to the entire directory
we can write
cd
home
as you can see it is already prompting
us to complete the
name of the directory at this point we
just have to press tab
and it completes it for ourselves
next we already know we have to enter
the desktop
nf and nf2
and this brings us to the current
working directory here if we press ls
we can find a file over here now as
discussed for the concatenate it is used
to show the contents of a file so right
now if we press c80 which stands for
concatenate
e file
as you can see we have written hello
kali in the text file and we can see the
output right now
we can also use it to create new files
for example if we write cat
any file name such as e file 2
here we can write anything
hello kali
again
once we press ctrl c here we can check e
file two and we have hello kali again
printed over here we can see the same
using the concatenate command as well
if i press ls you can see we have two
files here
and i can go with cat
e file 2
and i have hello kali again this is how
the concatenate command works
apart from this it can be used to copy
there is a different command like called
cp which is used to copy the files from
one place to another mind you this is
not moving this is only going to copy
the command
for example currently our pwd which is
the present working directory is in the
nf2 folder as you can see over here
let's copy the e file tool to the nf
folder
we can write cp
e file 2
and give the path of the nf folder which
will be home
simply learn
desktop
and an f
now if i press ls i'll find both the
files and nf2 since i copied
to go back to the nf folder again we can
again use the same command of
we can again use the home
simply learn
desktop
and just nf no nf2 this time just enough
as you can see this will change back our
present working directory now when we
press ls
we will find the e file to file
and the nf2 folder and we can confirm
this using the gui as well
this is the nf folder and you can see
the nf2 folder and the e file to
document if i write cat e file to
get e file two
we can see the contents of the file now
this can be done using moving as well
for example if i go to cd nf2 which is
the inside folder it has both the
document files like e file and e file 2.
let's say i want to move the e file
completely from nf2 to nf1
instead of writing cp the command i am
going to use is mv
mve file and again give the path of the
folder into which i have to copy which
will be again home
simply learn
desktop
and nf
as you can see the contents of the nf2
have appeared here and e file has been
moved
from nf2 to nf
this is this nf2 and we don't find e
file here anymore if we press cd dot dot
and we go back to nf ls right now and we
can file both the files e file that we
moved and e file to that we copied from
the nf2 folder so this is how copying
and moving will work using the terminal
now this is just a simple one line
statement that might take a couple of
clicks when using gui this is why the
command line interface is considered to
be much more streamlined for linux
operating systems
another very important
command for linux operating system is
the sudo command
sudo is short for super user do
the command enables you to perform tasks
that require administrative or root
permissions we can think of it as how we
run programs as administrator on windows
systems it is not advisable to use this
cover for daily use because it might be
easy for an error to occur and the
permissions of root are very intricate
so new beginners are
advised to use the sudo command only
when absolutely necessary for example
sudo su
with this command i am giving this
terminal
a root permission
this su stands for this user
at this point it's going to ask for my
admin password
once i enter my password
and i now have root access
note how the password that i entered did
not show up here this is a security
measure to prevent people from snooping
on your root password which is the end
game of all this operating system
as you also can see the symbol changed
if the dollar symbol is showing its
source as a standard user when you
switch to root you can easily see a hash
symbol
this opens up a separate shell inside
this terminal command for example we can
exit out of the root user to the
standard user using the command exit and
once again we have the dollar sign and
the root has vanished over here there
are some commands that will only work
with administrative access for example
when updating the kali linux system we
have to use apt update
as you can see it says problem unlinking
the file because permission denied now
let's try this using sudo
sudo
apt update
as you can see it is updating the
package repositories which work as the
software installed on the system
this can be done using either writing
the sudo command every time we want to
perform a root access or we can just
write sudo su once and write apt update
alone
the fetching is complete over here
for the second example let's say i just
write sudo su and this time is not going
to ask me the password because at this
current terminal process i've already
provided the rules password once and it
is in memory right now
now
when we used to update the system we had
to write sudo apt update that was
because we were running it as a standard
user now we are running it as a root
user so all we have to write is apd
update
and it's going to continue its work
there you go
another command that can be useful is
the ping command
it's pretty self-explanatory it's going
to be checking the internet connectivity
you can be used to check internet
connectivity or you can see if there is
a local server on your system which
needs to be ping then you can check that
for example you have to write ping and
we can use either ip address or domain
let's say if you want to check that if
we can access google.com using this kali
linux installation or not we can write
ping
google.com and you can see it shows the
bytes being sent and received and how
much time it took to take up the request
this can be done for local systems as
well for example this installation of
kali linux is being run on a virtual
machine
once this machine is running i still
have my
whole host machine running over here the
ip address of which is
192.168.29 179.
if i try to ping this from here
as you can see the time to complete the
request is drastically low compared to a
website on the internet considering this
is on the local network
this is how the ping command is worked
and it can show you what kind of
packages are transmitted how many are
received if there was any kind of packet
loss between the connection window and
other details
a very important command when working
with the terminal for a long duration is
the history command
pretty self-explanatory there are so
many commands that are being run
sometimes people forget what was the
change they did or
what was the directory name they put a
history command helps to recover some of
the commands that we have written it
doesn't go all the way back but it takes
up many commands that were inputted in
the last few processes
this is how the history command works
these are some of the most commonly used
terminal commands if you want to learn
more about this terminal and every other
feature of this please let us know in
the comments section and we'll try to
make an in-depth tutorial special if you
could
repeat if you want to learn more about
the terminal please let us know in the
comment section and we will try to make
an in-depth tutorial specifically for
terminal commands on linux
moving on we learn how to configure
proxy chains on our system
proxy refers to the technique of
bouncing your internal traffic through
multiple machines to hide the identity
of the original machine it is a good
tool that hackers use to accomplish this
goal is proxy chains
essentially you can use proxy chains to
run any program to a proxy server
this will allow you to access internet
from behind a restrictive firewall which
hides your ip address
proxies even allows you to use multiple
proxies at once by chaining them
together one of the most important
reasons that proxy chains is used in a
security context is that it's easy to
evade detection attackers often use
proxies to hide their true identities
while executing an attack
and when multiple proxies are chained
together it becomes harder and harder
for forensic professional to trace the
traffic back to the original machine
when these proxies are located across
countries investigators would have to
obtain warranties in the local
jurisdictions where every proxy is
located
to see how proxychain works
let's open firefox first and check our
current ip address
write firefox
and there we go
as we can see firefox is now open
let's check our current ip address right
now
if we go to an address called my
ip.com
and you can see the easily detects our
country is in india and this is a public
ip address
now
if we move to the terminal again
here we can now write
proxy chains
minus h
what this minus h does is it finds a
help it it stands for the help file
this is for help file
what we found out using this is
proxychains has a config file here
etc proxychains4.conf
this is the config file found
using this config file we can customize
how our proxy change should work
if we want to open that we have to use
it in a text editor on windows we have
notepad
and other things like that microsoft
word to edit documents on linux we have
a tool called nano
to access the nano we use the command
nano and give the path of the file that
we want to check as of right now the
proxy change config file is located over
here so we're going to follow the path
there
chains 4
dot conf
and here we go we see the config file
there are three basic types of proxy
chaining here
we have a strict chain where all the
proxy in the list
will be used and they will be chained in
order
we have a random chain where each
connection made through proxy chains
will be done by a random combo of
proxies in the proxy list
and your dynamic chain
it's the same as strict chain but dead
proxies are excluded from the chain
and
here we can set up whichever type we
want
to enable or disable a particular type
we use the hash symbol here as you can
see right now all the lines have a
hashtag symbol at the front except this
one a dynamic chain
this is the current one being used let's
say if i want to use a strict chain
method so i can add a hash value here
and remove the hash here at one point of
time
any one of these three four types should
be enabled
let's go for the
dynam um dynamic chain
we can disable this trick chain by
putting the hashtag in front
and removing the dynamic chain
as you can see below we have few
commands to how to handle the nano text
editor this symbol
is known as the control button on your
keyboard now if we want to write out
which is synonymous to saving the file
supposed to go with control o so if i
press ctrl o on my keyboard it says file
name to write and we have to press enter
here since we want to overwrite the
proxychains4.conf file we don't want to
create a new file over here so just
press enter
and we get a permission denied this
permission denied we're getting is
because we have opened this
using a standard user etc is a system
folder to be able to use make some
changes we have to use it using a sudo
command
to exit this nano we have to use the
control x command we use control x
we're going to clear
and this time we're going to use the
sudo command
sudo
nano etc
proxy chains
4 dot co nf
and we have the same file open up again
now this time if you want to make a
change let's say we're going to add a
strict chain instead of a dynamic chain
which remove the hashtag from straight
we're going to use ctrl o for the save
file option
we're going to press enter and it says
root 160 lines
again if you want to reverse this change
we put the hashtag over here
enable dynamic chain
we press ctrl o
press enter and it says root 160 lines
now we can exit straight away using the
control x format
right now we have not provided any file
or a proxy chain we can have proxy ip
addresses from the internet but we have
to make sure that they are safe and they
don't snoop on our data
when there is no proxy change being
provided personally
it going it's going to use the tor
network but for that we have to start
talk
tor is a service in linux
to know more about the store we can
write sudo systemctl which is used to
know the status of services on the linux
operating system
and status of tor
system ctl sorry ah as instead of stl it
should be system ctl status tor as you
can see it is a toss service anonymizing
overlay network for tcp connections and
it's currently inactive now to start
this up
we have to write studio systemctl
start
dot
now if we repeat the same sudo system
ctl status store
as you can see it's active now
you can see the green logo over here
okay
to integrate the firefox and the browser
we can use the proxy chains command
directly over here we can write proxy
chains we can use firefox to launch our
web browser and let's say if we want to
visit google.com
we press enter
and the firefox window is launched
and it should open up google.com next
and there we go
if we go to
myip.com once again
as you can see we have a different ip
address
and the country is unknown as well
so this is how we can use proxychains to
anonymize
internet usage when using kali linux
next on an agenda is the ability to scan
networks using nmap
at its core nmap is a network scanning
tool that uses ip packets to identify
all the devices connected to a network
can learn more about nmap using the help
file
as you can see these are some of the
parameters that can be used when
scanning ports of our system you can see
the version and the url of the webs of
the service
over here
the primary users of nmap can be broken
into three group processes first the
program gives you detailed information
on every ip active on your network and
then each ipa can then be scanned
secondly it can also be used to
providing a lot of live hosts and open
ports as well as identifying the os of
every connected device
thirdly
nmap has also become a valuable tool for
users looking to protect personal and
business websites
using nmap to scan your own web server
particularly if you are hosting your
website from home is essentially
simulating the process that a hacker
would use to attack your site
attacking your own site in this way is a
powerful way of identifying security
vulnerabilities
as we already discussed the host windows
10 machine on the system has an ip
address a 192 168 29.179
if you want to test the os scan of the
system we're going to first get the root
permission over here
we use the sudo command and now we are
root user we are going to launch the
command nmap
minus o which is supposed to be an os
detection scan
the ip address we can use of the host
system
192.16
in a legitimate penetration testing
scenario we can use the ip address of
the vulnerability device over here
we are going to let it scan for a while
and it's going to give us some guesses
on what can the os be
as you can see the scan is done
and it has shown some of the ports that
are open
you can see the msrpc port open at the
https 443 port open which is used to
connect to the internet
and it has some aggressive os guesses as
well for example it thinks there's a 90
94 chance that it's going to be a
microsoft windows xp service pack 3.
that's partly because a lot of the
windows xp update packages are still
prevalent on windows
now that the os detection is confirmed
there are multiple more
details that we can gather from nmac
let's go with the nmap minus a command
which is supposed to capture as much
data as possible
there is also a speed setting
you can call it a speed setting or a
control setting
of the minus t
minus t ranges from t 0 to t 1 to t
through all the way up to t 5
this basically determines how
aggressively the victim is being scanned
if you scan slowly it will take more
time to provide the results but it will
also give a less chance for the
intrusion detection system on the
vulnerable machine firewall to detect
that someone is trying to penetrate the
network for now if you want to go with
somewhat of a high speed we can go with
the t4 and provide the same ip address
of the local machine i am trying to
attack
it's going to take a little bit of time
since it's trying to capture a lot of
information
as you can see the results are now
here
it launched a scan and took a few top
ports that are most likely vulnerable
from a windows xp perspective and it
showed
a few ports over here it has not shown
991 filtered ports which could not be
attacked anyway since they were closed
for outside access it shows a few
fingerprint settings like the connection
policies and the
port details
it shows an http options some other
intricate details that can be used when
you attacking its servers
it shows a vmware version that it's
running
and some few other ports over here
apart from that we also have the
aggressive os gases over here just like
we did with the minus o and you can see
this time it is showing windows 7 as 98
percent
no exact os matches since uh if there
was any exact voice matches we could
have seen 100 chances over here
this is a trace route a trace route will
be the time and the path a connection
request takes from the source to the
destination for example this request
went from 192.168.72.2
to a destination address since this is a
local machine it took only a single step
on multiple occasions where if you're
trying to access a remote system it's
going to be a number of traceroutes when
it jumps from firewall to firewall and
router to router
this is how we can use nmap to find
information about a system and find some
vulnerable ports we can access
moving on we have a tutorial on how to
use wireshark to sniff network traffic
to start using wireshark we are going to
have to
open the application first
now during installation of wireshark
there is an option to enable if non-root
users can be able to capture traffic or
not
in my installation i have disabled that
so i will be launching wireshark when
using the root user itself
also to capture data we need an external
wi-fi adapter
you can see it over here
in the vm tab removable devices
re-link 80 2.1 and wlan
this is an external wi-fi adapter which
is inserted into my usb system
you can see it over here if i write iw
config
this is the one wlan 0 this is
absolutely necessary because we need to
have a monitor mode
required we won't need it for sniffing
data on wireshark
right now but it's going to be necessary
later on in this tutorial as well as we
will see
for now we can just start up via shark
by writing its name on the command line
and it should start the program
here we go
here it's going to check which of the
adapters we want to use for example
right now the eth0 which is supposed to
stand for ethernet 0 port you can see
data is being transmitted up and down
we're going to select eth0
and we have started capturing data
you can see this
data request from the source so
destination and the time and the which
protocol it is following everything we
can see and we can see the ipv4 flags
here as well
as you can see over here
to capture internet traffic
we can try running firefox
if we just write wikipedia.com
and you can see the number of requests
increasing
okay this is spelling mistake wikipedia
here
you can see the application data of all
these requests going up
and they're connected to a destination
server of one zero through one zero to
one sixty six point two two four
now if we even if we check the
transmission control protocol flags over
here and so many more things
we cannot find anything beneficial as
you can see the information over here
is gibberish which is supposed to be
since it's supposed to be encrypted
now
this is possible due to this being an
https website hence you can see the lock
symbol over here and connection is
supposed to be secure
now what about http ports we have seen
many people recommend to not visit http
ports
repeat
we have seen many people recommend to
not visit http websites and even if we
have to visit to not provide any
critical information
for example let's go to a random
http page over here
as you can see this is
saying connection is not secure and this
is an http http page and not https
now let's check for some of the
information that is passing through this
this is a login form
let's say i have a legitimate account
over here if i write my account name
and my password is supposed to be
password1234
i press login
and
the password does not match because i do
not have an account over here but let's
say i did and i was logged in as
expected we can go to wireshark
we can use filters over here now all the
requests that i am sending it's a tcp
request so i can write a filter
containing tcp
contains
whatever string if it is being passed
let's say for the end username i write
my account name so i can just write my
account name over here
and press enter
to find a request over here now as you
can see
there are many flags over here if we go
to the http html form url encoded and
open up some of its flags
as you can see i can see my account name
and simply learn password over here this
is the same
details that i input on the website
let's say i did have a legitimate
account on this website i would have
logged in with no problems but anyone
who would be using wireshark to sniff on
the data can easily get my credentials
from here this is why it's recommended
to not provide any information on http
pages the security is not up to the mark
and always look for the lock symbol when
visiting any website or
making any internet transactions or
providing any information
this is how we can use wireshark to
detect transmission and sniff packet
data that is being transferred to the
network adapter
next we have to learn about what is
metasploit
the metasploit project is a computer
security project that provides
information about security
vulnerabilities and aids in penetration
testing and ids development
we can open up the terminal here we're
going to allow root access
and to open up metasploit the keyword is
msf console
it's going to take a little bit of time
to start it up
now the metasploit console has been
loaded
from here we can decide what type of
attack we want to launch and what kind
of exploits we can launch against
vulnerable targets
for example
like we already discussed i'm running
this virtual machine on a windows 10
host machine so if i open the command
prompt from my windows 10 over here
if i need to check the ip address once i
go with ipconfig
here you can see the ip address of this
local machine
moving on
if we have to attack that machine let's
say we want to see what kind of exploits
are going to work over there
now we already know that windows has
some common vulnerabilities one of those
vulnerabilities is the hta server
vulnerability hta is supposed to be a
html application but when past the right
payload it can be used to open a back
door into a system
to start off with the metasploit and
accessing such applications
we're going to use the command
use
exploit and the name of the reverse hta
server is this windows
misc for miscellaneous
hda
server
as you can see it already found this one
all right
now there are some options that we need
to set for this exploit to go through
for example you can see some of the
options over here
there is a payload the payload is
supposed to be the malicious file that
we are going to send on the html
application which allows us to give the
back door
for example right now the payload which
is the malicious file is a windows
meetup data reverse tcp
completely understandable now let's set
the lhost
lhost and r host and srv host should be
the one
where we are going to launch the attack
from for example
if we launched another tab of this
console
and we just press i f config
the ip address is
192.168.72 130.
so we're going to set the lhost as
192.168.72
0.130
and we're going to do the same thing
with srv host
we're going to set a port
where we need to capture the backdoor
access
next
the payload has already been set
this payload will launch a backdoor and
give us meter printer access to the
system
meterpreter is can be considered as an
upgrade of a normal command prompt shell
we will look into it once we get the
access in the first place
now that we have set the commands
we can press on exploit and press enter
now
you can see we have a url over here
we're going to copy this url
once the url is copied we take it into
the browser
and paste it
this will ask us to download this file
now as per browser security settings
this file should be blocked by default
we can decide to keep it and with the
correct formulation of this malicious
package even the website browser
antivirus softwares will not be able to
detect good payloads we're going to save
this file
and we're going to open it
publisher could not be verified if we
press run and we go back
to our metadata access over here
you can see it has already captured a
url f1 hd server and it is writing
delivering payload
just have to wait for a few seconds so
the payload is delivered
it has sent
this much amount of data meterpreter
session one is opened
and we should get the access soon
there we go
now
to understand where is the session set
we can write sessions
minus i
as you can see it has a meetup it over
here we're going to write
sessions minus i
the session id is one so we're going to
write one
and we have the metadata access now to
get a fair idea of the system
we're going to write sysinfo and it's
going to the computer name the os
architecture all these things we can
write the help command to see what are
the things that we can get out of the
system we can take screenshots we can
control the webcam and start a video
chat
we can take a lot of things over here
there are other commands as well where
we can change the file directory like
the cat command cd command there are so
many things that work in the normal cmd
which we can run on the metadata as well
now if you want to access this
command prompt of the system directly
we can go with this we have to write
shell
and there we go we are in the downloads
folder right now to see if this is the
same computer or not we're going to
write ipconfig
as you can see it is our
victim machine with 192 168 but
29.171 we can just press exit
and we're back with the meterpreter
access
this is how we can use meter filter and
metasploit to gain access to a windows
10 machine next let's take a look at how
we can get root access from a windows 10
system
we just learned how we can get a meter
beta access from a system
we can background this meter predator
session by writing background and
pressing enter
we can still we can still see the shares
section is minus i
it's still present over here
now
these kind of access are not
administrative access
these are the kind of back doors that
can be created for standard users but to
get a complete access of a system
including the program files the windows
documents we need to have root access or
administrative access to that we're
going to use another exploit
reminder that the meterpreter session of
the standard access is already present
and we're not messing with it right now
we're going to set up another session
albeit with the same machine
that exploit name is
use exploit windows
local
bypass uac
event viewer
and there we go
now if we check the options that we can
put in the system
we have to choose an exploit target
need to put a session as well
let's say we going to use the session
one this is the session that has the
meter beta access with the standard user
it doesn't have the system user
we're going to write
set session one
and we're going to run exploit run a few
commands and it opened a second
meterpreter session
as you can see it is the session 2.
if i write this info
you can still see i'm not the
system user right now i'm still
just
a normal user how can we check that
if we go to shell
and still cc user generally downloads
all these things
if i press exit
go back to the meter picture there is a
command on meta peter
get system it attempts to elevate your
privilege to that of the local system
which basically means you get promoted
into root access so if we write get
system
and due to pipe impersonation we now
have the system root access
as you can see now it has become x64 and
we are the admin users now if i go to
shell
i can easily go back
windows
and i can easily access these ones
this kind of control over the windows
folders and the
program files folders these kind of
things are not possible if you are not
an admin access or the command prompt
has not been run with admin permissions
this is how we can use privilege
escalation to get into an admin access
system
we use the second
exploit which was the bypass us event
viewer exploit
and essentially used it with the first
session
as you can read here windows escalation
usa protection bypass
it was first disclosed on 2016 but it
still works on some systems so let's
start out by learning what parrot
security is
para2s is a debian based linux
distribution with an emphasis on
security privacy and development
it is built on debian's testing branch
and uses a custom hard linux kernel
while being founded in 2013.
pirate security contains several hundred
tools targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer foreign sex and reverse
engineering it has become a
multi-platform solution accessible and
freely available to information security
professionals and hobbies
it features a distinct forensics mode
that does not mount any of the system
hard disks or partitions and has no
influence in the host system making it
more stealthy than regular mode
this mode is used on the whole system
when there is a need for executing
forensic procedures
in software development a rolling
release is a paradigm in which software
upgrades are rolled out constantly
rather than in batches of versions this
ensures that the software is constantly
up to date
a rolling release distribution such as
parrot security os follows the same
concept providing the most recent linux
kernel and software versions as they
become available on the market
the basic introduction to the operating
system out of the way let us have a look
at the bare minimum system requirements
necessary to be able to run this
operating system
first up we got a cpu requirement which
states that a one gigahertz dual core
cpu is the absolute minimum in order to
use parrot os while multiple core
systems will provide more optimum
performance a small beginner has been
included
a very distinct thing to be noted is
that the operating system can be
installed on all variants of chipsets be
32-bit 64-bit and the newly popular arm
portfolio of devices
unlike kali linux which requires some
amount of graphical acceleration needed
to display the operating system
correctly parrot os has no such
requirements and can be used with the
leanest of machines
taking into account the ram issue a
minimum of 256 mb to 512 mb free ram
provides the optimum usage scenarios
even when the os is installed on a hard
drive storage media it should
theoretically occupy around 8 gb
information which may extend up to 16 gb
depending on the tools being installed
out of the box
when it comes to booting options you
have the option of going with the legacy
bios settings or with the more modern
uefi settings
these are just some of the requirements
for the installation of parrot security
os
to understand this process more vividly
and to learn how visualization can help
install an os in our existing computer
please follow the link to our parrot
security installation video linked right
above
let's understand what some of the things
that make pirate security unique among
all the other penetration testing
operating systems
along with all the giant catalogue
scripts parent security has its own
custom hardened linux kernel which has
been modified explicitly to provide as
much security and resistance to hackers
as possible as a first line of defense
the configurations in the operating
system act as a second gateway taking
care of malicious requests and dropping
them off
this is particularly beneficial since
should there be a scenario with the
latest linux kernel is causing some
particular issue the parrot os
development team will most likely iron
it out first before passing it on as an
update
the custom hardened kernel wasn't
reasoning enough
parrot security developers managed to
install more hacking tools and scripts
to ensure a smooth transition for the
kali linux users
all the tools you found in kali are
present in piratos and then a few extra
ones for good measure this has been
achieved while keeping roughly the same
size of the installation file between
both operating systems
however it's not all productivity points
for pirate os they provide a choice
between two different desktop
environments the main desktop which
comes pre-installed by default and kde
for those unfamiliar with linux
terminology you can think of desktop
environments as the main ui for a linux
system
being highly modular in nature one can
use kali linux or parrot os while adding
another texture of environment which
they find appealing
by kali has only a single option
paratoast has managed to provide two
optimized bills with made desktop and
kde desktop ready made on the website
one of the primary advantages of parrot
os over kali is that it's relatively
lightweight
this implies that it takes frequently
less disk space and computing power to
function properly with as little as 320
mb of ram required
in reality parrot os is also designed to
operate successfully of a usb stick but
kali linux does not work well from a usb
stick and is generally installed in a
virtual machine
parrot os can be seen as more of a niche
distribution if you're searching for
something lighter than gal linux
there are multiple ways to go about with
this installation
many people prefer to install it
directly onto a hard disk where the
parrot security os will overwrite
whichever data the hard disk already has
now this is beneficial if you want to
preserve your data for the long term but
this might pose some trouble to people
who do not have a spare hard disk or do
not want to lose their current
installation of windows operating system
another way to use parrot security is by
using the live boot but whatever changes
you make to the live boot operating
system those changes are removed the
moment we restart or shut down the
system
a very good common ground between both
these installations is virtualization
using virtualization software like
vmware or virtualbox we can install
parrot security on our systems while
simultaneously saving our data and
having the convenience of a host machine
such as a windows operating system in
case things go wrong
to start the installation we first need
to get a iso file for the parent
security operating system
this can be found at the current website
parrotsac.org
once you enter the website move into the
download section
and
select the get security addition over
here
parrot security os has multiple desktop
environments to you to choose from
these desktop environments serves as a
different user interface for the user
for example right now we have the main
desktop and the kde desktop as you can
see from the screenshots both of these
look quite different while having a
similar look and feel to them
for our example let's go with the maid
desktop
we have two options either we can go
with the direct download or we can get
the torrent file
for this example if we press on the
download button
and our download will start
i have already downloaded this file but
the iso file provided over here will
serve as an installation it will have
around four and a half gb of space it
will be used to install this operating
system in vmware
once the file is downloaded we can close
this
and open vmware workstation
vmware can also be used as a player
version or the workstation version if
you have much more familiarity with
using virtualbox for virtualization
application we can use that as well
once the vmware is open
we click on file and select a new
virtual machine
for the first time installation we're
going to go with the typical and
recommended installation procedure
instead of an advanced one
if you have already installed multiple
virtual machine oss going with the
advanced option will give you much more
control over the hardware customization
but for now we're going to stick with
the typical option
moving on it will ask us for a source to
where to install the operating system
from
since you're going to use a live iso
first we're going to select the third
option which will be i will install the
operating system later and press next
as we already know parent security is a
debian derivative
so when selecting the guest operating
system type we're going to go with linux
and in the selection we're going to
choose whichever the highest version of
debian is along with a 64-bit os
we're going to click on next
we're going to name our virtual machine
let's say
parrot security
os
we're going to select the location
where we want to save
the virtual machine
this will have all the hard disks of the
operating system installation
we're going to click on next
for the disk size we're going to specify
how much of the current memory are we
going to allocate
this is the hard disk memory of the
operating system installation whatever
changes you make in the operating system
whatever applications we install on the
virtual instance will all be stored in
this amount of memory while it is
recommended to go with at least 15 gb of
storage you can go as high as possible
and we're going to select the
recommended 20 gb as written
when given the choice of storing the
virtual disk as a single or multiple
files many people want to keep their
virtual instance in a way so that helps
them stay portable people change systems
and sometimes they want to swap their
instances between the work and their
personal computer
if there is no portability in mind
storing the virtual disk as a single
file gives the best performance and
should be the recommended go to when
installing for the first time
we click on next here
and it's going to give us a summary of
the settings we have already settled
till now
we're going to press on finish
and there we go we have our installation
first step completed
here on out we're going to click on edit
virtual machine settings
here we're going to have a look at some
of the requirements that the parrot
security os will need
it is known to be a memory lightweight
operating system but just to have the
almost optimum performance we're going
to provide around 2 gb of ram from our
host system which is a windows 10
machine
when it comes to the processors
i'm going to increase it to 2 and the
number of goes to 2 as well so giving
out a total 4 processor codes to the
operating system now this depends on
what are your computer rig and how much
resources you can justify so these need
to be customized according to the system
at hand
hardest size has already been set at 20
gb and the rest of them are pretty
standard and we can go on
one thing that we need to make sure is
selecting the cd dvd ide
here we have to use a iso image file
over here
previously it should be used physical
drive and at auto detect we're going to
use a use iso image file over here
we're going to click on browse
we're going to go to where we have
downloaded the iso file which is over
here
and select it
press ok here
and we can now power on this virtual
machine
at this point of time there are two
options we can go with the try install
option using the graphical user
interface or we can go using the
terminal mode
to get a better user experience we're
going to go with the try install mode
specifically press enter
and it's going to start the live boot
iso
meanwhile
vmware has an
prompt over here but it will try to
install some vmware tools on it while
this is not mandatory it is much more
recommended to install these tools so
that you can get some additional
features like drag and drop with the
host system and many more things for now
we're going to close this prompt
as you can see
this is the live boot iso of the parrot
security operating system
currently it's running the mate desktop
as we have downloaded in the website
the liveboot iso is necessary to get a
good feel of the operating system there
are many good linux distros that have
this live boot option so that you can
give a try of the operating system
before installing it permanently
once you are in the live board we can
start up with the installation using the
shortcut
as you can see install parrot
i'm going to double click it
and this is a calamaris installer
choose your language as american english
and press next
you can select your time zone according
to your location
and we can go next
at this point of time you have to choose
the correct keyboard now what many
people
get confused is choosing their own
language keyboard what people must keep
in mind is what keyboard the laptop
provides
most of the systems that come pre-built
provide the english us keyboard so
whatever keyboard you choose make sure
to type here and test that all the
buttons including the superscript and
the subscript buttons are working
correctly before moving forward with
this
step once you've settled on the keyboard
that you need to install
you can go ahead
here it will ask you to select storage
device and the only option you are going
to get
is the amount of hardware storage you
have given
in the virtual machine settings we have
already provided 20 gb of storage we are
going to choose that
and we are going to erase this disk
manual partitioning can be useful when
you are going to install
parrot security on an operating system
or on a hard disk where it is already
including a windows os
for now we are going to select erase
disk and press next
we are going to give our full name let
it be simply learn
you can give the name of the computer
and this is the username which you will
use to log in
this is your root password that we are
going to give over here
the root password of this kali linux
will act as the administrative access
and will be necessary for making changes
to the system or installing an updating
software
enter the password
and repeat it over here
you have the option to log in
automatically without asking for the
password but for security purposes it is
recommended to keep this disabled
click on next
this is another summary of the
installation that we are going to move
forward with
have a look that whatever changes we
have made is according to your
requirements and once everything is
checked you can press on install
click on install now
and we're going to let it complete the
work
as you can see the installation of
parrot security is now completed we're
going to make sure that we have the
restart now button over here disabled
i'm going to click on done
we're going to shut down this live boot
iso
i'm going to click on menu
turn on the device
and shut down
but not restarting straight away because
if you remember correctly in the virtual
machine instance settings we had given
it an iso file
please remove the live medium and press
enter to continue we can just press
enter to continue
and it's going to shut down now to move
on we're going to click on edit virtual
machine settings
you're going to cd dvd and we're going
to use physical drive now
we're going to remove it from the iso
image file because the installation has
already been completed and we don't want
to use the same iso file again and again
by using physical drive over here it's
going to detect the 20 gb hard disk that
we have already provided and
installation is done on it
i'm going to press ok
and we're going to power on this virtual
machine for testing
make sure this you clicky s over here
this is the grub menu
at this we get different choices for
example which nvidia drivers off or with
some other advanced options
more often than not we're going to
choose the first option and press enter
if you remember clearly
we did not get the option of try install
or a terminal run just like we did in
the live boot iso since this is running
straight from the 20 gb hard drive
storage it's going to start the os
directly
now with the login screen you can see
our username over here as we provided in
the installation
we're going to enter our root password
and press enter
and this is a currently working desktop
of the parrot security operating system
we can open the terminal over here
and we're going to try a root password
and installation
to install
any software we're going to use the
keyword sudo
apt
install
and neofetch
we're going to use the root password
that we used to log in
going to press y for yes
this is just an additional step that
we're doing to check that the
installation is done correctly with the
correct amount of hardware requirements
that we had provided
now that we have installed neofetch
we can write the command neofetch
and this is going to give us some
information about our installation
you can see the os name as parrot os
4.11 is running on a vmware host it's
the kernel versions and some of the
other information like the number of
packages installed the current shell
version resolution of the vmware
instance that we are running the desktop
environment which is made as we had
downloaded once
and some other things you can see the
memory is supposed to be 1951 megabytes
which is supposed to equal around 2gb of
ram usage that we had provided
let us compare both these operating
systems directly with respect to their
hardware specifications and usability
in the end we can decide on what
distribution is fit for each type of
user
for a first point of comparison let's
take a look at the ramp required
for optimum performance of the operating
system which is highly essential when
trying to crack hashes or something of
similar nature ram usage is a very
important facet
while kali linux demands at least 1gb of
ram pirate security can operate
optimally with a minimum of 320 mb of
ram
for correctly displaying graphical
elements kali linux requires gpu based
acceleration while this is not the case
with parrot security os which doesn't
require any graphical acceleration
needed from the user side
once these operating systems are
installed on vmware using the liveboot
isos
they take up a minimum amount of hard
disk storage
both of these operating systems have a
recommended disk storage of minimum of
20 gb in kali linux and a minimum of 15
gb in parrot security so they can
install all the tools necessary in the
iso file
when it comes to the category and the
selection of tools karl linux has always
been the first in securing every single
tool available for hackers in the
penetration testing industry
parrot security on the other hand has
managed to take it up a notch
while specializing in wireless pen
testing parent security makes it a point
that all the tools that kali linux
provides has been included in the iso
while simultaneously adding some extra
tools that many users will have to
install from third party sources in kali
linux
being a decade-old penetration testing
distribution kali linux has formed up a
very big community with strong support
signature parrot security on the other
hand is still growing and it is
garnering much more interest among
veteran penetration testers and ethical
hackers
a primary drawback of kali linux is the
extensive hardware requirement
to perform optimally it requires higher
memory than parallel security it also
needs graphical acceleration while
demanding more virtual hard disk storage
pirate security on the other hand was
initially designed to run off a usb
drive directly thereby requiring very
minimal requirements from a hardware
perspective like just 320 mb of ram and
no graphical acceleration needed
this means pirate security is much more
feasible for people who are not able to
devote massive resources to either their
virtual machine or on their laptop hard
disk directly
with the comparison done between both of
these operating systems let's take a
look at the type of users both of these
are catered to
one can go with kali linux if they want
the extensive community support offered
by its users
if they want to go with a trusted
development team that have been working
on this distribution since many years
if they have a powerful system which can
run kali linux optimally without having
to bottleneck performance
and if they are comfortable with a
semi-professional environment which may
or may not be very useful for new
beginners one can decide to go with
parrot security if they want to go with
a very lightweight and lean distribution
that can run pretty much on all systems
it also has a lot of tools pre-installed
and some of them are not even present on
kali linux
it is much more suitable for
underpowered rigs where users do not
have a lot of hardware resources to
provide to the operating system and
thereby it is much more feasible for
people with underpowered laptops or no
graphical acceleration
compared to kali linux parrot security's
desktop environment is also relatively
easier to use for new beginners
for people who are just getting into
ethical hacking pallet security does a
relatively better job
of introducing them to the operating
system and to the various tools without
having to dump them into the entire
intricacies
in recent years the cost of data
breaches has steadily risen the
additional vulnerabilities that occur
due to the move to a remote workforce
dramatically enhance the chances for
cyber attacks and introduce several weak
points for hackers to exploit
additionally automated hacking assaults
and the capacity to exchange bitcoins by
a ransomware have increased the cost of
cybercrime in general
companies workforces have transitioned
to full-time work from her models which
gives rise to new attack surfaces
threat actors target the people who are
most vulnerable by taking advantage of
current events and shifting situations
to better understand this growth in
digital crime let us go through a few
statistics
2020 brought with it a slew of new
problems for both businesses and
consumers in the midst of a worldwide
epidemic forest fires and political
instability it's easy to overlook a
serious orbit less physical threat it
set a record for data loss due to cyborg
attacks as well as the sheer volume of
attacks
2020 is already outpacing its
predecessor
the graph below denotes the percentage
of companies that fell victim to at
least one cyber attack in the respective
year
with numbers growing steadily we are yet
to see the true crux of this digital
revolution
in situations like these penetration
testing has been a gift for
organizations worldwide while security
testing cannot guarantee a 100 solution
it can go a long way in securing those
critical data from falling into the
wrong hands
hey everyone this is bev from simple
learn welcome to this tutorial on
penetration testing let's go through
some of the topics we will be covering
today
we start by learning about penetration
testing and ethical hacking and the
different use cases in the it industry
next we know about the benefits of
penetration testing and how the help
organizations save money in the long run
moving on we familiarize ourselves with
the different types of penetration
testing or ethical hacking with each
serving a different category of
personnel
in the next section we read about the
five distinct phases in every ethical
hacking campaign and how they help clear
up the extensive report at the end of
every penetration testing session
finally we have a live demonstration on
how we can check for vulnerabilities and
the ways hackers can break into devices
without adequate security measures in
place
let's start by learning about
penetration testing in general
organizations can define penetration
testing based on the objectives of the
test
all networks applications devices and
physical security components are
included it imitates the behavior of
harmful individuals or the hackers
experienced cybersecurity specialists
use penetration testing to strengthen
our company's security posture and
eliminate any weaknesses that leave it
vulnerable to attacks
penetration testing when done correctly
goes beyond simply preventing thieves
from gaining unauthorized access to a
company's systems it generates realistic
scenarios that demonstrate how well a
company's present defenses might perform
in the face of a full-scale cyber
assault
the simulation aids in the discovery of
the sites of exploitation and the
testing of i.t breach security
businesses may acquire professional
unbiased third-party input on the
security procedures by conducting
frequent penetration testing
when testing while relatively time
consuming and costly can aid in the
prevention of highly destructive and
expensive breaches
a white hat hacker employs hacking
talents to find security flaws in
hardware software or networks on the
other hand whitehead hackers follow the
rule of law when it comes to hacking
instead of blackhead hackers
they assist firms in conducting
penetration tests to analyze the
security index and make the necessary
improvements
ethical hacking provides a full audit of
your security policies and in the case
of bug bounties can assist you in
identifying holes in existing
operational systems
it takes a far broader approach to cyber
security than penetration testing
whereas penetration testing focuses on
system flaws ethical hacking allows
actors to utilize any attack tactics
available to them
they can take advantage of system
misconfigurations send phishing emails
launch brute force password assaults
reach physical boundaries or do whatever
else they feel will get them access to
critical information
because thieves are progressively
changing up the approaches and launching
multi-layered complex attacks this is
incredibly useful for determining just
how exposed the organization is to cyber
threats
considering the vast domain that is
ethical hacking we have multiple
categories of penetration testing
methodologies let's cover them in the
next section
when configuring a security system
testing is critical to preventing
hackers from penetrating the perimeter
there are three sort of tests black box
grey box and white box
in the black box testing the tester
receives no information during the
penetration test
in this case the pentester takes the
method of an unprivileged attacker from
initial access and execution until
exploitation
this scenario is the most realistic
showcasing how an attacker with no
inside knowledge may target and
compromise an organization
however because of this it is also the
most expensive alternative
white box penetration testing which is
also known as crystal box testing
entails sharing all network and system
information with the tester which
includes network maps and passwords this
saves time and lowers the overall cost
of a project
a white box penetration test effectively
simulates a focused assault on a given
system using as many attack paths as
feasible
in a gray box penetration test also
known as a transparent box test very
restricted information is present with
the tester
grey box testing is beneficial for
understanding the extent of access a
privileged person may get and the
possible damage they could wreck
graybox tests achieve a mix between
depth and efficiency and may be used to
mimic either an insider danger or an
assault that has infiltrated the network
perimeter
now that we covered the basics of
penetration testing and the relative
categories one must know how these
testing campaigns benefit the
organizations conducting them
let us go through a few perks of
penetration testing
regular penetration testing helps your
business assess the security of online
applications internal networks and
external networks it also assists you in
understanding what security measures are
required to achieve the degree of
protection your company needs to protect
its people and assets
prioritizing these risks offer firms an
advantage in anticipating hazards and
preventing harmful assaults
penetration testing is similar to a real
life hacker rehearsing for a real life
hack
regular penetration testing helps you be
proactive in your real world approach to
reviewing the security of your it
infrastructure
the process identifies gaps in your
security allowing you to correct any
flaws before an actual attack happens
it is undeniably expensive to recover
from the effects of a data breach legal
fees id cleanup consumer protection
programs lost revenue and dissatisfied
customers may cost businesses millions
penetration testing regularly is a
proactive strategy to remain on top of
your security and may assist in
preventing financial damage from a
breach while safeguarding your brand and
image
penetration testing aid in meeting the
compliance and security duties imposed
by industry standards and regulations
such as pci hipaa fisma and iso 27001
having these tests done regularly helped
demonstrate due care and a commitment to
information security all while avoiding
the significant fines associated with
the non-compliance
with the entire process seeming to be a
lengthy ordeal what are the multiple
phases in the process
theoretically we have to follow a five
stage process
reconnaissance is the first phase of the
penetration test
in this phase the security researcher
collects information about the target it
can be done actively meaning you are
collecting information by sending a
request directly to the target and
interpreting it
passively where you are collecting data
without contacting the target or both
it helps security firms gather
information about the target system
network components active machines etc
this activity can be performed by using
information available in the public
domain and using different tools
the scanning phase is more tool oriented
rather than performed manually
the penetration tester runs one or more
scanner tools to gather more information
about the target by using scanners such
as war dialers port scanners network
mappers and vulnerability scanners the
penetration tester collects as many
vulnerabilities which help in turning to
attack a target in a more sophisticated
way
the third phase is gaining access of the
system
in this phase the penetration tester
tries to connect with the target and
exploit the vulnerabilities found in the
previous stage the exploitation may be
buffer overflow attacks denial of
service dos attacks session hijacking
and many more
pentester extracts information and
sensitive data from the servers by
gaining access using different tools
in the fourth stage the hacker has to
maintain access the penetration tester
tries to create a back door from himself
it helps the penetration tester to
identify hidden vulnerabilities in the
system and can later access the machine
should the need arise
in the final phase of clearing and
covering tracks the penetration tester
removes all logs and footprints which
help the administrator identify his
presence
this allows the penetration tester to
think like a hacker and perform
corrective actions to mitigate those
activities
with the cost of cyber security
platforms going up trained penetration
testers receive an excellent level of
remuneration for the efforts as per
reports the average yearly salary for a
penetration tester is 6 lakh indian
rupees of 110 000 dollars in the
american counterpart
finally let's go over some of the ways
hackers can identify vulnerable
positions on a system to gather
information in a live demonstration
in this demo we will start by setting up
a vpn connection that will allow us to
access to a vulnerable network by
creating a local virtual group over the
internet
we then try to scan the victim machine
for breachable entry points find the
username and password of the user in
question and eventually grab the root
password from the device
to start our demonstration we're going
to need a vulnerable machine to work on
now this vulnerable machine can be found
on the website known as tri hackme which
is a service catered towards penetration
testers
before we connect to the machine we need
to
join the network where the machine is
located
we can do that using an ovpn file which
is short for openvpn protocol
to connect to this ovpn file we're going
to go into a new workspace on parrot
security
we're going to activate the root
access
and we're going to connect to it
actus dot
o vpn
once we see the message initialization
sequence completed
we can be sure that we have connected to
the network which has the vulnerable
machine
now to start the vulnerable machine
we're going to click this button
and wait for a few seconds
as you can see it gives a one minute
countdown before it shows you the ip
address
now remember whatever the ip address we
receive here it is a machine being
launched on the try hackney servers but
we can
access that machine because of the ovpn
connection that we have just set up
using this file this ovpn file can be
found on the tryhackme servers profile
section which i downloaded beforehand
as you can see we now have the ip
address of our victim machine
let's try if we can reach this machine
or not
we're going to copy the ip address
and we're going to try and ping to the
machine
if the connection is successful and we
have joined the network we should be
able to see some response over here
as you can see we're receiving
request pings from the victim machine
which means that we have already joined
the victim network
now that we are confirmed we are able to
access the vulnerable machine
let's run the first step in a
penetration test which is reconnaissance
let's run up and map scan
we're going to use the flag of sv
so that we can know which version of the
service it is running
we're going to take up the ip address
and paste it here
this scan will only be possible if the
open vpn connection is up and running
as you can see it is still running
and we have our results over here
we're running the scan so that we can
find the services running on the host
machine that we will run and map against
we conclude that a web service is
running actually on port 80 as we can
see over here which is using the apache
server system
in addition to this there is a smb samba
service as well
running on ports one three nine four
four five
now that we know we have an apache
server we can use this ip address
to open it on the browser
okay
since the current home page is not
accessible we can use some other urls as
well
as apache servers are concerned there
are a certain set of urls that can be
used to open
however if we go to the url which is
ip address slash
development
this opens up a new folder
if we try to check the contents of these
files
this is for the dev.txt
you can see the version of the apache
http server that is being run
this is the dev dot text
if we go back and we check the second
file as well
it says the content c shadow has the
credentials
okay if we go back again
smb has been configured
which we have already founded and map
that it is running a samba server
now with this version of the apache
server we can find version specific
exploits that can be run on metasploit
but there is sometimes no no need of
that we can use another technique as we
now know that there are multiple users
that is being run over here
we can use a tool known as enum for
linux
what it does this is acts
at enumerates the windows and samba
systems
to run that command we're going to use
enum for linux
minus a
and we're going to take ip address of
the machine
i'm going to paste it here
what this will essentially do is provide
us usernames that are being stored in
the victim machine
it's going to take some time to find out
the usernames
once we find those out we can run the
necessary attacks
as we have already seen on the nmap it
is also happening in ssh port
so if you find the username and we find
a single hash that can be cracked we can
use the ssh to get inside the machine
right now we have to wait for the
results
of the enum for linux command
as you can see
we have found two users of the machine
known as k
and jan
i think we can stop the enumeration
right now since we have the two users of
this machine
next step what we can do is we can try
to ssh into the machine
now to run the ssh command we're going
to need the password of one of the users
for this example let's say we go with
the user of jan
to brute force we're going to use the
hydra
tool
there's like an example command
this is how we can use let me just copy
this
and paste it over here
all right
hydra minus cell user as we have already
decided we're going to use the user jan
and
we're going to use ssh
for the ip address we're going to copy
it from here
and paste it here
now for the password list we're going to
use a word list
which has a few passwords already
present in it
for this example i am going to use the
roku.txt file which has like millions of
passwords already stored in it
what the hydra will do it will try to
bypass the ssh
console on the machine using the
passwords present in the roku.txt file
we will give the path
of rock queue over here
like this
and we're going to run it
as you can see it's mentioned that it's
attacking ssh at this ip address
now this attack is going to take a while
and after this attack is done we are
going to get the ssh password which is
basically the credentials of the jan
user in the victim machine
for now i am going to stop this attack
what i would recommend is for you to run
this attack and write down the password
that you received in the comment section
below
the password that we receive from here
can be used to login into the machine
let's try that once
to ssh into the machine we're going to
the ssh user at the rate
ip address
we're going to write yes and press enter
now we're going to enter the password
that we have found after running the
hydra command
i'm going to type the password and press
enter
and we have logged in
as you can see
now
if we try to look around
there are no directories over here okay
so let's go one step back
give a space over here okay
let's go to the second users folder
okay
these are the contents of the k folder
and you can see there's a dot ssh folder
over here
so we're going to enter that
let's have a look the files in this
folder
and we can file an rsc id over here
which if i'm not wrong should be an rsa
private key
which can be used to ssh into the
machine here we go you can see it's a
big in rsa private key
and
it should end
here as well
now what this private key does this hash
will be used to log ssh into the machine
when using the user k
once this hash is cracked using hydra or
any other cracking software like john
the ripper we can easily use the
passphrase to login into the machine
with the user of k
what i am going to do is copy this
private key
i'm going to launch a new terminal
we'll create a new file known as nano id
paste the private key over here
and save it
as you can see we have saved the file
over here
now this hash can later be used to crack
into the machine using the user of k
this hash can be cracked using either
john the ripper hydra or there are other
cloud mechanisms that can be used to
crack this machine
after it is cracked
we can use the passphrase derived from
it to ssh into the machine
to perform the ssh entry we are going to
use this command ssh minus i
we're going to use the same file
which we received
we're going to write the username which
is k
10.10
we can just copy it from the
here
right
minimize this and paste the ap address
over here
or we can do one more thing we're going
to use the pseudo command together as
well
it's better
sudo ssh
enter the system password
this passphrase is the one that we
received after cracking the hash in this
id file
whichever password you received after
cracking this using hydra or john the
ripper please write the password in the
comments section so that we can know
that we have successfully cracked the
password we're going to write the
passphrase over here press enter
and as you can see we have entered the
system of k
here we're going to press
and we find
the backup file of the password i'm
going to write
cat
password back
and
here is the final root password
so as you can see we have now
we have now received the final root
password of the primary user and we have
already cracked the password of the
other user that is jan
so this is the entire process of how you
can use nmap to find out the vulnerable
points you can see which are the
softwares that are running which
versions they are running and which of
those versions have a legitimate claim
as
an insecure exploit
malware is a malicious software that is
programmed to cause damage to a computer
system network and hardware devices
many malicious programs like trojan
viruses worms and bots which cause
damage to the system are known as
malware most of the malware programs are
designed to steal information from the
targeted user
or to steal money from the target by
stealing sensitive data
let's take a look at the introduction
for two different types of malware virus
androgen
firstly let's take a look what exactly
is a virus program
a computer virus is a type of malicious
program that on execution replicates
itself
they get attached to different files and
programs which are termed as host
programs by inserting their code if the
attachment succeeds the targeted program
is termed as infected with a computer
virus
now let's take a look at the trojan
horse trojan horse program is a program
that disguises itself as a legitimate
program but harms a system on
installation
they hide within the attachments and
emails then transfer from one system to
another they create bad doors into our
system to allow the cipher criminal to
steal our information
let's take a look how they function
after getting installed into our system
firstly we have virus programs the
computer virus must contain two parts to
infect the system
first is a search routine which locates
new files and data that is to be
infected by the virus program
and the second part is known as the copy
routine which is necessary for the
program to copy itself into the targeted
file which is located by the search
routine now let's take a look at the
trojan horse functioning
for trojan horses entryway into our
system is through emails that may look
legitimate but may have unknown
attachments and when such files are
downloaded into the device the trojan
program gets installed and fixed the
system
they also infect the system on the
execution of infected application or the
executable file and attacks the system
now that we understand what virus and
trojans are let's understand different
types of virus
androgens let's take a look at different
types of viruses
the first one is known as the boot
sector virus this type of virus damages
the booting section of the system by
infecting the masterboard record which
is also known as mbr
this damages the boot sector section by
targeting the hard disk of the system
then we have the macro virus
micro virus is a type of virus that gets
embedded into the document related data
and is executed when the file is opened
they also are designed to replicate
themselves and infect the system on a
larger scale
and lastly we have the direct action
virus
this type of virus gets attached to
executable files which on execution
activates the virus program and infects
the system
once the infection of the file is
completed they exit the system
which is also the reason it is known as
a non-resident virus
let's take a look at different types of
trojans
the first type of trojan is the backdoor
trojan
they are designed to create a backdoor
in the system on execution of an
infected program
they provide remote access of our system
to the hacker this way the cyber
criminal can steal our system data and
may use it for illegal activities next
we have
cryxus trojan
they enter the system by clicking the
random pop-ups which we come across on
the internet
they attempt the user to give their
personal details for different
transactions or schemes
which may provide remote access of a
system to the cyber criminal
and the last trojan type is ransom
trojan
this type of trojan program after
entering the system blocks the user from
accessing
its own system and also affects the
system function
the cyber criminal demands a ransom from
the targeted user for the removal of the
trojan program from the device
now that we understand some details
regarding viruses and trojan let's solve
a question
the question is jake was denied access
to his system and he wasn't able to
control the data and information in his
system
now
the actual question is what could be the
reason behind this system's problem
option a macro virus option b ransom
trojan option c black dot version
give your answers in the comment section
now let's understand how to detect the
activity of viruses and trojan in our
system
to detect virus or trojan activity in
our system we can refer to the following
points
for viruses we have
slowing down of the system and frequent
application freeze shows that the
infection of the virus is present in the
system
then we have the viruses can also steal
sensitive data including passwords
account details
which may lead to unexpected log out
from the accounts or corruption of the
sensitive data
and lastly we have frequent system
crashes due to virus infection which
damages the operating system
for trojan we have frequent system
crashes and system also faces slow
reaction time
then we have there are more random
pop-ups from the system which may
indicate trojan activity
and lastly we have modification in the
system application and change of the
desktop appearance can be also due to
the infection of a trojan program
next let's take a look at a famous cyber
attack for virus and a trojan horse
for virus we have
the my doom virus which was identified
in the er 2004 which affected over 50
million systems by creating a network of
sending spam emails
which was to gain backdoor access into
our systems
next for the trojan horse we have the
emote trojan program
which is specifically designed for
financial theft and for stealing bank
related information
next we have few points for how to
prevent virus entry or trojan attack for
a system
the most basic way of virus protection
is to using antivirus and do regular
virus scan this will prevent virus entry
in the system and also having more than
one antivirus provides much better
protection
then avoid visiting uncertified websites
can also prevent virus entry into a
system
then we have
using regular driver updates and system
updates to prevent virus entry
for trojan we have using certified
softwares from legal sites to prevent
any trojan activity in our system
and also avoid clicking random pop-ups
that we often see on the internet
and lastly using antivirus and firewalls
for protection against trojan horses is
a good
habit now that we have reached the end
of the video let's take a look what we
learnt
for the first part
we saw the main objective of the virus
is to harm the data and information in a
system whereas for the trojan we have
stealing of the data files and
information
effect of viruses is more drastic in
comparison to the trojan horses
then we have viruses which are
non-remote programs whereas trojan
horses are remote accessed
and lastly
viruses have the ability to replicate
itself to harm multiple files whereas
trojan does not have the
replication ability let's take a look at
some of the famous botanic attacks
the first one is mirai botnet which is a
malicious program designed to attack
vulnerable iot devices and infect them
to form a network of bots
that on command perform basic and medium
level denial of service attacks
then we have the zeus bot
specifically designed for attacking the
system for bank related information and
data
now let's take a look at the agenda for
today's video
firstly we'll understand what is a
botnet
then we'll see how exactly a botnet
works
after that we'll learn some of the
architectures how our botnet works on
after in the end we learn how to protect
ourselves from botnet attacks
now let's see what exactly a botnet is
botnet refers to a network of hijacked
interconnected devices that are
installed with malicious codes known as
malware
each of these infected devices are known
as bots the hijack criminal known as bot
order remotely controls them
the bots are used to automate
large-scale attacks including data theft
server failure malware propagation
and denial of service attacks
now that we know what exactly a botnet
is
let's dive deeper into learning how
botnet works
during the preparation of a botnet
network the first type involves
preparing the botnet army after that the
connection between the botnet army and
the control server is established
and the end the launching of the attack
is done by the bot order
let's understand through our
illustration
firstly we have a bot order that
initiates the attack
according to the control server commands
the devices that are infected with the
malware programs and begins to attack
the infected system
let's see some details regarding the
preparation of the botnet army
the first step is known as the prepping
the botnet army
the first step is creating a botnet is
to infect as many as connected devices
as possible
this ensures that there are enough bots
to carry out the attack
this way it creates bots either by
exploiting the security gaps in the
software or websites or using phishing
attacks
they are often deployed through trojan
horses
for the next step we have
establishing the connection
once it hacks the device as per previous
step it infects it with the specific
malware that connects the device back to
the control bottom server
a bot holder uses command programming to
drive the bot's actions
and the last step is known as launching
the attack
once infected a bot allows access to
admin level operation like gathering and
stealing of data reading and rewriting
the system data
monitoring user activities performing
denial of service attacks
including other cyber crimes now let's
take a look at the botnet architecture
the first type is known as client server
model the client server model is a
traditional model that operates with the
help of a command and control center
server
and communication protocols like irc
when the bot order issues a command to
the server it is then relayed to the
client to perform malicious actions
then we have peer to peer model
here controlling the infected bots
involves a peer-to-peer network that
relies on a decentralized approach that
is the pods are topological
interconnected and acts as both c and c
servers that is the server and the
today hackers adopt this approach to
avoid detection and single point failure
in the end we will see some points on
some countermeasure against botnet
attacks
the first step is to have updated
drivers and system updates
after that we should avoid clicking
random pop-ups or links that we often
see on the internet
and lastly having certified antivirus
anti-spyware softwares and firewall
installed into a system will protect
against malware attack
jane is relaxing at home when she
receives an email from a bank that asks
her to update her credit card pin in the
next 24 hours as a security measure
judging the severity of the message jane
follows the link provided in the email
on delivering her current credit card
pin and the supposedly updated one
the website became unresponsive which
prompted her to try sometime later
however after a couple of hours she
noticed a significant purchase from a
random website on that same credit card
which she never authorized
frantically contacting the bank jane
realized the original email was a
counterfeit or a fake message with a
malicious link that entailed credit card
fraud
this is a classic example of a phishing
attack
phishing attacks are a type of social
engineering where a fraudulent message
is sent to a target on the premise of
arriving from a trusted source
its basic purpose is to trick the victim
into revealing sensitive information
like passwords and payment information
it's based on the word phishing which
works on the concept of baits
if a supposed victim catches the bait
the attack can go ahead which in our
case makes jane the fish and the fishing
emails the bait
if jane never opened the malicious link
or was cautious about the email
authenticity an attack of this nature
would have been relatively ineffective
but how does the hacker gain access to
these credentials
a phishing attack starts with a
fraudulent message which can be
transmitted via email or chat
applications
even using sms conversations to
impersonate legitimate sources is known
as fishing which is a specific category
of phishing attacks
irrespective of the manner of
transmission the message targets the
victim in a way that coaxes them to open
a malicious link
and provide critical information on the
requisite website
more often than not the websites are
designed to look as authentic as
possible
once the victims submit information
using the link be it the password or
credit card details the data is sent to
the hacker who designed the email and
the fake website
giving him complete control over the
account whose password was just provided
often carried out in campaigns or an
identical phishing male sent to
thousands of users the rate of success
is relatively low but never zero
between 2013 and 2015 corporate giants
like facebook and google were tricked
off of 100 million dollars due to an
extensive phishing campaign where a
known common associate was impersonated
by the hackers
apart from credit access some of these
campaigns target the victim device and
install malware when clicked on the
malicious links
which can later function as a botnet or
target for ransomware attacks
there is no single formula for there are
multiple categories of phishing attacks
the issue with jane or the hacker stoler
bank credentials falls under the
umbrella of deceptive phishing
a general email is sent out to thousands
of users in this category hoping some of
them fall prey to the scam
spear phishing on the other hand is a
bit customized version the targets are
researched before being sent an email
for example if you never had a netflix
subscription sending you an email that
seems like the netflix team sends it
becomes pointless
this is a potential drawback of
deceptive phishing techniques
on the other hand a simple screenshot of
a spotify playlist being shared on
social media indicates a probable point
of entry
the hacker can send counterfeit messages
to the target user while implying the
source of such messages being spotify
tricking them into sharing private
information
since the hacker already knows the
target use of spotify the chances of
victims taking the bait increase
substantially
for more important targets like ceos and
people with a fortune on their back the
research done is 10 full which can be
called a case of whaling the hackers
prepare and wait for the right moment to
launch their phishing attack often to
steal industry secrets for rival
companies or sell them off at a higher
price
apart from just emails farming focuses
on fake websites that resemble their
original counterparts as much as
possible the prevalent method is to use
domain names like facebook with a single
o or youtube with no e
these are mistakes that people make when
typing the full url in the browser
leading them straight to a counterfeit
web page which can fool them into
submitting private data a few more
complex methods exist to drive people
onto fake websites like arp spoofing and
dns cache poisoning but they are rarely
carried out due to time and resource
constraints
now that we know how phishing attacks
work let's look at ways to prevent
ourselves from becoming victims
while the implications of a phishing
attack can be extreme protecting
yourself against these is relatively
straightforward
jane could have saved herself from
credit card fraud had she checked the
link in the email for authenticity and
that it redirected to a secure website
that runs on the https protocol even
suspicious messages shouldn't be
entertained
one must also refrain from entering
private information on random websites
or pop-up windows irrespective of how
legitimate they seem
it is also recommended to use secure
anti-phishing browser extensions like
cloudfish to sniff out malicious emails
from legitimate ones
the best way to prevent phishing is
browsing the internet with care and
being on alert for malicious attempts at
all times
so here is a question for you if both me
and my friends receive the same email
that instructs us to change our spotify
password before the end of the day even
though one of us never used spotify
what bracket does this phishing attack
fall under
one whaling
two
spear fishing three deceptive fishing
four
farming
think about it and leave your answers
below in the comments section and three
lucky winners will receive amazon gift
vouchers
cyber attacks are becoming more
prevalent due to the pandemic where work
from home is the norm and people spend
possibly more than half their day with a
laptop but we cannot stop every attack
at the root we must be informed and
vigilant to phishing attacks among
others to safeguard our data it's the
year 2015 and richard has just finished
playing games on his computer
after a long gaming session richard
tries to shut it down to find some
random text file on the desktop that
says ransom note
the text file mentioned how a hacking
group had encrypted richard's game files
and private documents
and he had to pay a ransom of 500 worth
of bitcoin in the specified bitcoin
address richard quickly checked his
files only to see them being encrypted
and unreadable
this is the story of how the tesla crypt
ransomware spread in 2015 which affected
thousands of gamers before releasing the
master key used for encrypting the files
so
what is ransomware
for richard to be targeted by such an
attack you must have installed
applications from untrusted sources or
clicked an unverified link
both of them can function as gateways
for a ransomware breach
ransomware is a type of malware that
encrypts personal information and
documents while demanding a ransom
amount to decrypt them
this ransom payment is mainly done using
cryptocurrency to ensure anonymity but
can also employ other routes
once the files are encrypted or locked
behind a password a text file is
available to the victim
explaining how to make the ransom
payment and unlock the files for it
just like richard found the ransom note
text file on his desktop
even after the money has been paid
there's no guarantee that the hackers
will send the decryption key or unlock
the files
but in certain sensitive situations
victims make the payment hoping for the
best having never been introduced to
ransomware attacks before this gave
richard an opportunity to learn more
about this and he began his research on
the topic
the spread of ransomware mostly starts
with fishing attacks
to know more about phishing attacks
click the link in the button above
users tend to click on unknown links
received via emails and chat
applications promising rewards of some
nature
once clicked the ransomware files
installed on the system that encrypts
all the files or blocks access to
computer functions
they can also be spread via malware
transmitted via untrusted application
installation or even a compromised
wireless network
another way to breach a system with
ransomware is by using the remote
desktop protocol or rdp access
the computer can be accessed remotely
using this protocol allowing a hacker to
install malicious software on the system
with the owner unaware of these
developments coming to the different
types of ransomware
first we have locker ransomware which is
the type of malware that blocks standard
computer functions from being accessed
until the payment to the hackers is
complete
it shows a lock screen that doesn't
allow the victim to use the computer for
even basic purposes
another type is crypto ransomware which
encrypts the local files and documents
in the computers
once the files are encrypted finding the
decryption key is impossible unless the
ransomware variant is old and the keys
are already available on the internet
scareware is fake software that claims
to have detected a virus or other issue
on your computer
and directs you to pay to resolve the
problem
some types of scareware lock the
computer while others simply flood the
screen with pop-up alerts without
actually damaging files
to prevent getting affected by
ransomware
richard could have followed a few steps
to further enhance his security
one must always have backups of their
data
cloud storage for backup is easy but a
physical backup in a hard drive is
always recommended
keeping the system updated with the
latest security patches is always a good
idea
apart from system updates one must
always have reputed antivirus software
installed
many antivirus software like kaspersky
and bitdefender have anti-ransomware
features that periodically check for
encryption of private documents when
browsing the internet a user must always
check for the lock sim on the address
bar which signifies the presence of
https protocol for additional security
if the system is infected with
ransomware already there is a website
nomoreransome.org
it has a collection of decryption tools
for most well-known ransomware packages
it can also help decrypt specific
encrypted files if the list of
anti-ransomware tools didn't help the
victim
so here's a question for you
what should be the first course of
action after a ransomware attack
one contact the criminal authorities
two
run antivirus scan for the entire system
three
recover from local or cloud backups
four
isolate device from the parent network
think about it and leave your answers in
the comments section and three lucky
winners will receive amazon gift
vouchers
ransomware attacks have become
increasingly common due to the shift in
corporate work culture from in office to
work from home
in march 2021 a chicago-based company
called cna financial was attacked by
ransomware that affected nearly 75 000
users
the company was later forced to pay out
40 million dollars to get their system
access back
ransomware cost businesses more than 75
billion dollars per year and we must
take the necessary steps to incur as
minor damage as possible so that was
ransomware in a nutshell a growing
concern among security professionals
worldwide to understand the key logging
problem better let's take a look at an
example
this is june she works in a business
firm where she manages the company's
data regularly
this is jacob from the information
department who's here to inform her
about some of the security protocols
during the briefing she informed him
about some of the problems her system
was facing with which included slow
reaction speed and unusual internet
activity
as jacob heard about the problems with
the system he thinks of the possibility
what could be the reason behind these
problems her system was facing with
the conclusion that he came across was
the key logging issue
unknown to the problem her system was
facing with she asked him about some of
the details regarding it
for today's topic we learn what exactly
keyloggers are and how they affect our
system what are the harmful effects that
keylogging can bring into the system
for today's agenda we learn what exactly
the key logging program is
then we'll see how the system gets
infected what are different methods how
the key logging issue enter into the
system
then we'll take a look at different
types of methods how to detect the key
logging issue into the system
then we'll take a look at different
types of keyloggers that are present and
how they affect differently into the
system
then we'll take a look how the hackers
use the recorded data that has been sent
by the key logging program
and then we'll take a look at a case
where the mobile devices get affected
with the key logging issue
and lastly we'll take a look what are
different prevention methods available
to prevent the system from getting
infected by the key logging issue
to begin with we learn what exactly the
key logging program is
as the name suggests keylogger is a
malicious program or a tool that is
designed to record keystrokes that are
typed during data input and record them
into a log file
then the same program secretly sends
these log files to its origin
where they can be used for malicious
acts by the hacker
now that we know what the key logging
program is let's take a look how they
enter into the system
searching for a suitable driver for a
system can often lead to the
installation of the key logging program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are installed into our system
then
if we use unknown links or visiting
unknown websites which come through
unknown addresses can also be a reason
behind a key logging issue entering into
the system
and lastly there are often cases where
different pop-ups that we often see on
social sites or different media sites
can lead to the installation of key
login program into a system
now that we know how the problem gets
into the system let's take a look how to
identify whether the system is infected
by the key logging issue
the key logging issue can be identified
if there are often cases when a keyboard
lags behind the system
the data that we enter sometimes is
stuck in between when we type through
the input
then there are cases when the system
freeze occurs unknowingly to what
exactly could be the reason behind them
and also there are delayed reaction time
for different applications that run on
the system
and lastly there are different cases
when we often see suspicious internet
activity on the system that we don't
know about this could lead to the
identification of a problem into the
system
now we'll take a look at different types
of key loggers that are present on the
net which can harm our system
differently
the first problem that keyloggers arouse
is api based the most common key logging
case which uses apis to keep a log of
the type data and share it to its origin
for malicious purposes
each time we press a key the key logger
intercepts the signal and lockset
then we have form grabbing based key
loggers as the name suggests they are
based key loggers that store the form
data that is if we often use waveforms
or different kinds of forms to enter
different data they can be recorded into
the system by the program and send it to
its origin
then we have kernel-based keyloggers
these keyloggers are installed deeply
into the operating system where they can
hide from different antivirus if not
checked properly and they record the
data that we type on the keyboard and
send it to its origin
and lastly we have hardware keyloggers
these keyloggers are present directly
into the hardware that is they are
embedded into system where they record
the data that we type on the keyboard
now let's take a look how hack is
differentiate different type of recorded
data and exploit them
when hackers receive information about
the target they might use it to
blackmail the target which may affect
the personal life of the target and also
blackmail them for different money
related issues
then in case of company data that is
recorded by the key logging program can
also affect the economic value of the
company in the market which may lead to
the downfall of the company
also in some cases the key logging
program can also log data about military
secrets which may include nuclear codes
or security protocols which are
necessary to maintain the security of a
country
now let's take a look whether mobile
devices get infected with the key
logging issue or not
in the case of hand devices infection of
keyloggers are low in comparison to the
computer systems as they use on-screen
keyboard or virtual keyboard
but in some cases we often see different
kinds of malicious programs getting
installed into the hand device if we
often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites
and also the device that is infected
with the keylogging issue or different
kind of malicious program can often lead
to the exploitation of data that
includes photos emails or important
files by the hacker or the cyber
criminal that install the particular
malicious program into the system
now to prevent our system from getting
infected by the key locking program
let's take a look at different points
the first point includes using of
different antivirus softwares or tools
which can prevent the entering a
malicious program into the system
then keeping system security protocols
regularly updated is also a good habit
and lastly using virtual keyboard to
input our sensitive data which may
include bank details login details or
different passwords related to different
websites
now that we have some understanding
about the topic of keyloggers let's take
a look at the demo to further increase
the knowledge about the topic
for the first step we have to download
some of the important libraries that are
required into the system
which is
this library
now we'll run it
the system says
the library is already installed into
the system
now let's take a look what exactly
modules are required from the particular
library
from this library we'll import
the keyboard module which will help us
to record the data that we type on the
keyboard
now
from the same we'll also import
key module
and the listener module
and also
the logging module
which will help us to record the data
into a log file
for the next part
we'll write a piece of code that will
allow us to save the data that is
recorded by the program into our text
file that will be named as
key underscore log text file along with
the date and time stamp
let's take a look
now
we'll provide it with the file name
that will be given as
k log
dot
txt file
and also so the part where the format of
the data is recorded
put the brackets over here
to contain the file name
now we will write the format in which
the data will be recorded into the log
file
which will be given as
the format would be
the message and the timestamp which
would be given as
along with
the
timestamp
given as percentage
and ending it with the bracket
now for the next step we'll design
two of the functions that will be used
into the program that will be termed as
while press function and while release
function let's take a look
while
press function
would be a function
that will come into play when the
keyboard key has been pressed
is
pressed
and
this would go for the
format that we designed
in the above line
and
logging
the pressed key
info
a string file
to be recorded
into the
log file
now
now we will design
a function that is
while
release
that will come into play
when
the escape key has been
pressed that is the program will
dominate itself and the program will
stop from running
and in the end
we require for the functioning of the
program to loop these functions that is
while press and while deletes to
continue its cycle
that will be going for
file
press
and
on
release will contain
while release
function
as
listener
and now
this part
would join the different threads and
store them into the log file
now that we have completed the code for
the program let's run it
we have to wait for a moment so the
program runs it
now to verify the program let's open
notepad
and on the notepad
we'll write
hello
world which will be the basic whether
the program is working or not
let's take a look
and we will go for the main page on
jupyter notebook
and refresh the page
go to the bottom
over here
we see the keylog text that is the text
file that we created
let's open it
and over here we have the data
that is created
as we started with
note
then this is a hello world part that we
created just now
which shows that the program we created
is working properly
let's take a look at some of the
detection methods for keylogger in a
system
first one is
the keystrokes that we make become
sluggish that is the reaction speed from
the hardware keyboard which is slower
than
usual then we have instances where our
system gets hanged or freezes in between
the work
there are also cases when there is
suspicious unusual activity in the
internet
and lastly there are some unknown
programs that are running in the
background of the system
these four are general cases where we
can observe whether the system is
infected with a keylogger program or not
to better understand key logging
activity in a system let's take a look
at the demo for the same
for the first step let's execute the key
logging program in a system
over here i am using a python keylogging
program
and if you want to know more about the
key logging program in python you can
watch our previous video on what are
keyloggers
let's begin now
let's execute the program
and wait for a second or two for the
program to continue execution
ok let's take a look whether the program
is working properly
we can see that the key logging program
would create a text file named key
underscore log
let's take a look
key underscore log seems like the
program is working fine
let's try typing something on the
notepad
hello world
now let's see whether the recorded data
comes
seems like the program is working fine
the data is recorded hello world
with exclamation marks
along with the time
now let's try detecting the keylogger
program using different detection
methods
for the first step
you can access your settings
where you should go for windows update
over here you would often see some of
the
updates regarding security measures that
is the very basic step if you want to
detect key logging activity in your
system
let's take a look at the second
detection method
for this you can use a start option
and type
task manager
using the task manager app you can see
some of the programs that are displayed
these programs are the ones that are
currently working or executed
in my system right now if you see any
unusual program that is being executed
without your knowledge
may refer to a keylogger program
and if you find any unusual program that
is being executed on your system right
now
you should
right click on the
program and choose option n-task this
will immediately end the task that is
being executed which might protect your
data from being recorded
let's take a look at the third option
how we can detect the key loggers
in the task manager use the option
startup
int startup option represents the
softwares or programs that get executed
when the system is turned on
if you see any unusual program or
software mentioned in any of these in
your system you might have to
disable that
this represents there's an
unusual program or a malicious tool that
has been executed when you start up your
system
which may relate to a keylogger problem
and the last method to detect keylogger
activity is
to type something
if you feel there is some restrictions
or there is a gap between when you type
the key
on your keyboard and the reaction speed
becomes
slow even by a millisecond
this might represent there is a program
that is interfering with the keyboard
if you use the following detection
methods you might save yourself from
being spied on or getting your data
recorded that you type on your system
jude is waiting at the airport to hop on
her flight back home when she realizes
that she missed making an important bank
payment
she connects her laptop to the public
wi-fi at the airport and goes ahead to
carry out the bank transaction
everything goes well and jude completes
her transaction
after a couple of days she was wiped off
her feet when she learned that her bank
account was subjected to a cyber attack
and a hefty amount was wiped from her
account
after getting in touch with the bank
authority she learned that her account
was hacked at the airport
she then realized that the public wifi
she used might have caused her this
trouble
jude wishes that had her bank transfer
escaped the hacker's eyes she would not
have been a victim of a cyber attack
bank officials advise her to use a vpn
for future transactions especially when
connecting to an open or public network
like most of us jude had come across the
term vpn several times but didn't know
much about it and little did she think
that the repercussions of not using a
vpn would be this bad
let's understand how the hacker would
have exploited jude's transaction in the
absence of a vpn
in this process jude's computer first
connects to the internet service
provider isp
which provides access to the internet
she sends her details to the bank's
server using her ip address
internet protocol address or ip address
is a unique address that recognizes a
particular device be it a laptop or
smartphone on the internet
when these details pass through the
public network the hacker who passively
watches the network traffic intercepts
it
this is a passive cyber attack where the
hacker collects jude's bank details
without being detected
more often or not in such an attack
payment information is likely to be
stolen
the targeted data here are the victim's
username passwords and other personal
information
such an unsecured connection exposed
jude's ip address and bank details to
the hacker when it passed through the
public network
so would you have been able to secure
her transaction with the help of a vpn
well yes
picture jude's bank transaction to be
happening in a tunnel that is invisible
to the hacker
in such a case the hacker will not be
able to spot her transaction and that is
precisely what a vpn does
a virtual private network more often
known as vpn creates a secure tunnel
between your device and the internet
for using a vpn jude's first step would
be to install software-based technology
known as the vpn client on her laptop or
smartphone that would let her establish
a secure connection
the vpn client connects to the wi-fi and
then to the isp
here the vpn client encrypts jude's
information using vpn protocols
data is encrypted to make sure it is
secure
next the vpn client establishes a vpn
tunnel within the public network that
connects to the vpn server
the vpn tunnel protects jude's
information from being intercepted by
the hacker
jude's ip address and actual location
are changed at the vpn server to enable
a private and secure connection
finally the vpn server connects to
jude's bank server in the last step
where the encrypted message is decrypted
this way jude's original ip address is
hidden by the vpn and the vpn tunnel
protects her data from being hacked
this explains how vpn makes your data
anonymous and secure when it passes
through the public network
and the difference between a normal
connection and a vpn connection
after learning about this jude was
certain that she should start using a
vpn to carry out her online transactions
in the future
this is also applicable to each one of
us
even if you work remotely or connect to
public wi-fi using a vpn is the safest
option
in addition to providing a secure
encrypted data transfer vpns are also
used to disguise your whereabouts and
give you access to regional web content
vpn servers act as proxies on the
internet
this way your actual location cannot be
established
vpn enables you to spoof your location
and switch to a server to another
country and thereby change your location
for example by doing so you can watch
any content on netflix that might be
unavailable for your region given the
current scenario cyber attacks are on
the rise now more than ever
so we have to stay alert and protect our
digital information
if you are interested in protecting
networks and computers from cyber
criminals a cyber security career is
what you should venture into
so what are you waiting for get
certified with simply learn and become a
cyber security expert let's move on to
learning about the tor network
tor shot for the onion router it's an
open source privacy network that permits
users to browse the web anonymously the
tor was initially developed and solely
used by the u.s navy to protect
sensitive government communications
before the network was made publicly
available
the digital era has disrupted the
traditional way of doing things in every
sector of the economy the rapid rise in
development and innovation of digital
products has given way to frequent data
breaches and cyber thefts in response
consumers are increasingly opting for
products that offer data privacy and
cyber security
tor is one such underground network that
was implemented for the purpose of
protecting users identities the tor
network is one example of the many
emerging technologies that attempt to
fill a data privacy void in a digital
space plagued by cyber security concerns
the tor network intercepts the traffic
from your browser and bounces a user's
request of a random number of other user
ip addresses
then the data is passed to the user
requester final destination
these random users are volunteer devices
which are called as nodes or relays
the tor network disguises your identity
by encrypting the traffic and moving it
across different tower relays within the
network
the tor network uses an onion routing
technique for transmitting data hence
the original name of onion router
to operate within the tor network a user
has to install the tor browser any
address or information requested using
the browser is transmitted through the
tor network it has its own feature set
which we will be covering over later in
this video
as we discussed already the data passing
through the tor network must follow a
unique protocol known as the onion
routing protocol let us learn more about
its unique characteristics
in our normal network usage the data is
transmitted directly
the sender has data packets to transmit
which is done directly over a line of
communication with either a receiving
party or a server of some kind
however since the data can easily be
captured while being transmitted the
security of this exchange is not very
reliable
moreover it becomes very easy to trace
the origin of such requests on many
occasions websites with questionable and
controversial content are blocked from
the isp this is possible since the isp
is able to detect and spy on user
information passing through the network
apart from isps there is a steady chance
of your private information being
intercepted by hackers
unfortunately easy detection of the
source and contents of a web request
make entire network extremely vulnerable
for people who seek anonymity over the
internet
however in the onion routing protocol
things take a longer route we have a
sender with the top browser installed on
the client system the network sends the
information to node 1's ip address which
encrypts the information and passes it
on to node 2's address which performs
another encryption and passes it on to
node 3 address
this is the last address which is also
known as the exit node
this last node decrypts the encrypted
data and finally relays the request to
the final destination which can be
another device or a server end
this final address thinks the request
came from the exit node and grants
access to it the encryption process
across multiple computers repeats itself
from the exit node to the original user
the tor network obfuscates user ip
addresses from unwanted surveillance by
keeping the user's request untraceable
with multiple servers touching the data
it makes the tracking very difficult for
both isps and malicious attackers
now that we understand the way tor works
let us learn more about the tor browser
the top browser was developed by a
non-profit organization as a part of the
tor project in 2008 and its first public
release was announced
the tor browser is a browser fork from
the popular firefox that anonymizes your
web traffic using the tor network
if you are investigating a competitor
researching an opposing litigant in a
legal dispute or just think it's creepy
for your isp or the government to know
what websites you visit the top browser
might be the right solution
before the top browsers were developed
using that network to maintain anonymity
was a huge task for everyday consumers
starting from the setup to the usage the
entire process demanded a lot of
knowledge and practice the top browser
managed to make it easy for users to
traverse the relay server center and
guarantee the privacy of the data
exchange
a major feature of the tor browser is
the ability to delete all browser
history cookies and tracking data the
moment it is closed
every new launch of the browser opens an
empty slate having a usage habits from
being tracked and singled out
a major feature that is the highlight of
the tor network is the availability of
onion links
only a small portion of the world wide
web is available to the general public
we have the deep web that contains links
that are not allowed to be indexed by
standard search engines like google and
bing
the dark web is a further subset of the
deep web which contains onion links
tor browser gives you access to these
dot onion websites which are only
available within the tor network
onion is a special used top-level domain
which designates an anonymous onion
service which is also known as a hidden
service similar to the links of the deep
web these onion links provide services
like online shopping cryptocurrency and
many other products not available in the
consumer internet space
often being considered as a haven for
illegal activities and sales onion links
provide both information and assets in a
private manner without the risk of
spying by authorities
browsing the web over tor is slower than
the clear net due to the multiple layers
of encryption
some web services also blocked or users
tor browser is also illegal in
authoritarian regimes that want to
prevent citizens from reading publishing
and communicating anonymously
journalists and dissidents around the
world have embraced store as a
cornerstone of democracy and researchers
are hard at work at improving tor's
anonymity properties
let us take a look at some of the
advantages of using the tor browser over
standard web browsers
the highlight of using the tor browser
is to maintain anonymity over the
internet the cause for such requests can
differ from person to person but all of
these concerns are answered by the tall
network touting the information via
multiple nodes and relay servers make it
entirely difficult for the isp to keep a
track of usage data
the entire top project is designed to be
completely free and open source
allowing the code for the browser to be
inspected and audited by third parties
helps in the early detection of faulty
configurations and critical bugs it is
present for multiple operating system
starting from laptops to mobile devices
a number of websites are blocked by
governments for a variety of reasons
journalists under authoritarian regimes
have difficulty in getting the word out
regarding the situation
since the onion routing protocol
transfers data between multiple servers
of random countries the domains being
blocked become available when used via
tor
usage of these encryption messaging
platforms is easily enforced using the
tor browser which otherwise would have
been a difficult task under oppressive
circumstances
many people believe that a vpn offers
the same benefits as the top browser
let's put both of them to the test and
see the differences between them
coming to the first point of difference
tor is completely free and open source
all of the code for the browser and the
network can be audited and has been
cleared for security concerns
when it comes to vpn there are many
different brands which have open source
clients but the same cannot be said for
their counterparts
some have partly open source while some
have completely locked up their code so
that they cannot be stolen further
moving on tower has multiple relay
points in its data transfer protocol
between the server and the receiver
there are three different ip nodes that
number can increase but it will always
be more than two
once the data is passed from the
cylinder it goes through all of those
delay points while in the case of a vpn
the connection is made from the client
device to the vpn server and then to the
requested destination there is no other
ip node that comes into work here
thereby making the connection a one to
one between the client and a vpn
as a next point since store handles
multiple layers of encryption and the
data passes through multiple systems
along the way the performance is slow
compared to a vpn where the performance
is relatively fast due to the less
number of nodes the data passes through
similarly the multi-layer encryption of
tor is consistent if you use tor browser
every single request passes with the
same layer of encryption and follows the
same routing protocol in the case of a
vpn different companies offer different
levels of encryption some have multi-hop
some prefer a single one-to-one
connection and these kind of differences
make the choice much more variable
finally the nodes and relays being used
in the tor network are volunteer there
is no company holding over them so
jurisdiction becomes relatively
straightforward whereas in the case of
vpns many such vpns are hosted by adware
companies or are being monitored by
central governments to note the usage
information
now that we have a better understanding
of the tor browser and its routing let
us take a look at how the tor browser
can anonymize and protect our internet
usage
on opening up the tor browser for the
first time this is the page that you are
going to be welcomed with we have the
option of connecting to the tor network
before we start our browsing
so let's press connect
and we can see that it is connected
coming to the anonymization
let's check my current location on
google chrome
currently is showing as navi mumbai in
maharashtra
if we check the same link on the tor
browser we should get a different
address
now every link that we open in the tor
browser will be little delayed and the
speed will be hampered because of the
multiple layers of encryption like we
discussed now as you can see
it's showing a german ip and the state
of bavaria
this is how the anonymization works
there is no vpn configured there is no
proxy attached it's straight up this out
of the box settings that come inbuilt
with the tor browser
similarly we have an option of cleaning
up the data
let's say if you want to refresh your
location and you want to use a different
id for the next browsing session
if you just restart it once
and you can have to check it again
we should be seeing a different country
this time
as you can see we have netherlands right
now so this is how you can keep
refreshing your address you can keep
refreshing your host location so that it
cannot be tracked when browsing the
internet
like we discussed we have some onion
links that can only be used on the tor
network as you can see these kind of
links do not open in the google chrome
browser
but once we copy these over to the tor
browser
as you can see we have opened the hidden
wiki which is available only on the tor
network
this is kind of an alternative wikipedia
website where we can find articles to
read and more information to learn
similarly we have another onion link
over here
which is once again available only for
the tall browser
now these kind of delays are expected
but they are a valid compromise because
they maintain the anonymity that many
people desire
similarly we have found a hidden wallet
which is a cryptocurrency wallet which
is specifically for dark web members
this operates over the top network and
this is used by mostly journalists and
people who want to anonymize their
internet transactions when it comes to
dealing money
all of the transactions that occur over
the tor network are almost impossible to
track therefore these kind of
cryptocurrency wallets are very big on
the deep web this is just one example
while having multiple different wallets
for every single cryptocurrency
available with every aspect of corporate
culture going online and embracing cloud
computing there is a plethora of
critical data circulating through the
internet all worth billions of dollars
to the right person
increasing benefits require more complex
attacks and one of these attacks is a
brute force attack
a brute force or known as brute force
cracking is the cyber attack equivalent
of trying every key on your key ring and
eventually finding the right one
brute force attacks are simple and
reliable there is no prior knowledge
needed about the victim to start an
attack most of the systems falling prey
to brute force attacks are actually well
secured
attackers let a computer do the work
that is trying different combinations of
usernames and passwords until they find
a one that works
due to this repeated trial and error
format the strength of password matters
a great deal although with enough time
and resources brute force will break a
system since they run multiple
combinations until they find the right
passcode hey everyone this is bev from
simply learn and welcome to this video
on what is a brute force attack
let's take a look at the topics we need
to cover today
we start by learning about what a brute
force attack is and its reliability as a
hacking technique
next we take a look at a step-by-step
approach to how the hackers can take
control of a system using brute force
techniques
moving on we learn about the harmful
effects of getting our personal devices
brute forced or compromised and how it
can affect not only our devices but our
friends and family as well
we also understand a few steps that we
can enforce to make a better security
system against brute force attack
specifically
and finally we have a demonstration that
explains how the brute force mechanism
works in a real world situation
but before we begin make sure you
subscribe to our simply learn channel
and click the bell icon to never miss an
update from us
let's begin with learning about brufo's
attacks in detail
a brute force attack also known as an
exhaustive search is a cryptographic
hack that relies on guessing possible
combinations of targeted password until
the current password is discovered
it can be used to break into online
accounts encrypted documents or even
network peripheral devices
the longer the password the more
combinations that will need to be tested
a brute force attack can be time
consuming and difficult to perform if
methods such as data obfuscation are
used and at times downright impossible
however if the password is weak it could
merely take seconds with hardly any
effort
dictionary attacks are an alternative to
brute force attacks where the attacker
already has a list of user names and
passwords that need to be tested against
the target it doesn't need to create any
other combinations on its own
dictionary attacks are much more
reliable than brute force in a real
world context but the usefulness depends
entirely on the strength of passwords
being used by the general population
there is a three-step process when it
comes to brute forcing a system
let's learn about each of them in detail
in step one we have to settle on a tool
that we are going to use for brute
forcing
there are some popular names on the
market like hashcat
hydra
and john the ripper
while each of them has its own strength
and weaknesses each of them perform well
with the right configuration
all of these tools come pre-installed
with certain linux distributions that
cater to penetration testers and cyber
security analysts like kali linux and
parrot security
after deciding what tool to use we can
start generating combinations of
alphanumeric variables whose only
limitation is the number of characters
for example while using hydra a single
6-digit password will create 900 000
passwords with only digits involved
add alphabets and symbols to that sample
space and that numbers grows
exponentially
the popular tools allow customizing this
process
let's say the hacker is aware of the
password being a specific 8-digit word
containing only letters and symbols
this will substantially increase the
chances of being able to guess the right
password since we remove the time taken
to generate the longer ones we omit the
need for including digits in such
combinations
these small tweaks go a long way in
organizing an efficient boost force
attack since running all the
combinations with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time
in the final step we run these
combinations against the file or service
that is being broken we can try and
break into a specific encrypted document
a social media account or even devices
at home that connect to the internet
let's say there is a wi-fi router
the generated passwords are then fed
into the connection one after the other
it is a long and arduous process but the
work is left to the computer other than
someone manually clicking and checking
each of these passcodes
any password that doesn't unlock the
router is discarded and the brute force
tool simply moves on to the next one
this keeps going on until we find the
right combination which unlocks the
router
sometimes reaching the success stage
takes days and weeks which makes it
cumbersome for people with low computing
power at their disposal however the
ability to crack any system in the world
purely lead to bad password habits is
very appealing and the general public
tends to stick with simple and easy to
use passwords
now that we have a fair idea about how
brute force works let's see if we can
answer this question
we learned about how complex passwords
are tougher to crack by brute force
among the ones listed on the screens
which one do you believe will take the
longest to be broken when using brute
force tools
leave your answers in the comment
section and we will get back to you with
the correct option next week
let's move on to the harmful effects of
getting a system compromised due to
brute force attacks
a hacked laptop or mobile can have
social media accounts logged in giving
the hackers free access to the victim's
connections
it has been reported on multiple
occasions where compromised facebook
accounts are sending malicious links and
attachments to people on their friends
list
one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to distributing spam
this reduces the chance of circling back
the source to a single device which
belongs to the hacker
once brute forced a system can spread
malware via email attachments sharing
links file upload via ftp etc
personal information such as credit card
data usage habits private images and
videos are all stored in our systems be
it in plain format or root folders
a compromised laptop means easy access
to these information that can be further
used to impersonate the victim regarding
bank verification among other things
once a system is hacked it can also be
used as a mail server that distributes
spam across lists of victims
since the hacked machines all have
different ip addresses and mac addresses
it becomes challenging to trace the spam
back to the original hacker
with so many harmful implications
arising from a brute force attack it's
imperative that the general public must
be protected against such
let's learn about some of the ways we
can prevent ourselves from becoming a
victim of brute force attacks
using passwords consisting of alphabets
letters and numbers have a much higher
chance of withstanding brute force
attacks thanks to the sheer number of
combinations they can produce
the longer the password the less likely
it is that a hacker will devote the time
and resources to brute force them
having alphanumeric passwords also
allows the user to keep different
passwords for different websites this is
to ensure that if a single account or
password is compromised due to a breach
or a hack the rest of the accounts are
isolated from the incident
two-factor authentication involves
receiving a one-time password on a
trusted device before a new login is
allowed
this otb can be obtained either via
email sms or specific 2fa applications
like authy and aegis
email and sms based otps are considered
relatively less secure nowadays due to
the ease with which sim cards can be
duplicated and mailboxes can be hacked
applications that are specifically made
for 2fa cores are much more reliable and
secure
captchas are used to stop bots from
running through web pages precisely to
prevent brute forcing through their
website
since brute force tools are automated
forcing the hacker to solve captcha for
every iteration of our password manually
is very challenging the capture system
can filter out these automated bots that
keep refreshing the page with different
credentials thereby reducing the chances
of brute force considerably
a definite rule that locks the account
being hacked for 30 minutes after a
specific number of attempts is a good
way to prevent brute force attempts
many websites lock account for 30
minutes after three failed password
attempts to secure the account against
any such attack on an additional note
some websites also send an email
instructing the user that there have
been three insecure attempts to log into
the website
let's look at a demonstration of how
brute force attacks work in a real-world
situation
the world has gone wireless with wi-fi
taking the reins in every household it's
natural that the security will always be
up for debate
to further test the security index and
understand brute force attacks we will
attempt to break into the password of a
wifi router
for that to happen we first need to
capture a handshake file which is a
connection file from the wifi router to
a connecting device like a mobile or a
laptop
the operating system used for this
process is parrot security a linux
distribution that is catered to
penetration testers all the tools being
used in this demo can easily be found
pre-installed in this operating system
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
to start our demo we're going to use a
tool called airgarden which is made to
hack into wireless network specifically
at this point it's going to check for
all the necessary scripts that are
installed in the system
to crack into our wi-fi and to capture
the handshake file we're going to need
an external network card
the significance of the external network
card is a managed mode and a monitor
mode
for now the wlx1 named card is my
external network adapter which i'm going
to select
to be able to capture data over the air
we're going to need to put it in monitor
mode as you can see above it's written
it is in managed mode right now
so we're going to select option two
which is to put the interface in monitor
mode
and its name is now wlan 0 monitor
the monitor mode is necessary to capture
data over the air
that is the necessary reason why we need
an external card since a lot of inbuilt
cars that come with the laptops and the
systems they cannot have a monitor mode
installed
once we select the mode we can go into
the fifth which is the handshake tools
menu
in the first step we have to explore for
targets and it is written that monitor
mode is necessary to select a target
so let's explore for targets
and press enter
we have to let this run for about 60
seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this ess id is
supposed to be the wi-fi name that we
see when connecting to a network jio24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the wi-fi
this bss id is supposed to be an
identifier somewhat like a mac address
that identifies this network from other
devices
the channels features on one
or two or there are some many channels
that the networks can focus on
this here is supposed to be a client
that is connected to one such network
for example
the station that you can see 5626 this
is supposed to be the mac address of the
device that is connected to a router
this bssid is supposed to be which wi-fi
it is connected to for example 5895 d8
is this one
which is the jio24 router
so we already know which router has a
device connected to it and we can use
our attack to capture this handshake
now that we it has already run for one
minute now that we press ctrl c
we will be asked to select a target see
it has already selected the number five
which is the jio24 router as the one
with clients so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake for
select network 5
and we run our capture handshake
it says we have a valid wpa wpa2 network
target selected and that the script can
continue
now to capture the handshake we have a
couple of attacks a d auth or a d or air
replay attack
what this attack does is kick the
clients out of the network
in return when they try to reconnect to
the wi-fi as they are configured that
way that when a client is disconnected
it tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the handshake
for our demo let's go with the second
option that is the dior air replay
attack
select a timeout value let's say we give
it 60 seconds
and we start the script
you can see it capturing data from the
jio24 network and here we go
we have the wpa handshake file
once the handshake file is captured
can actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
handshake it has verified that a pmk id
from the target network has successfully
been captured
this is the file that is already stored
so dot cap file for the path we can
let's say we can keep it in a desktop
okay we give the path
and the handshape file is generated
we can already see
a target over here same geo 24 router
with the bss id
now if we return to its main menu
we already have the handshake file
captured with us now our job is to brute
force into that handshake capture file
the capture file is often encrypted with
the security key of the wifi network if
we know how to decrypt it we will
automatically get the security key
so let's go to the offline wpa wp to
decrypt menu
since we'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option one
now to run the brute force tool we have
two options either we can go with the
aircrack or we can go with the hashcat
let's go with aircac plus crunch which
is a brute force attack against a
handshake file
we can go with option 2.
it can already detect the capture file
that we have generated
so we select yes
the bssid is the one which
denotes the jio24 router so we're going
to select yes as well the minimum length
of the key for example it has already
checked that the minimum length of a
wi-fi security key which is a wpa to psk
key will always be more than 8 digits
and below 64 digits so we have to select
something in between this range so if we
already know let's say that the password
is at least 10 digits you can go with
the minimum length as 10
and as a rough guess let's say we put
the maximum length as 20.
the character set that we're going to
use for checking the password
will affect the time taken to brute
force
for example if we already know that or
we have seen a user use the password
while connecting to the router as
something that has only numbers and
symbols then we can choose accordingly
let's say if we go with only uppercase
characters and numeric characters
go with option 7
and it's going to start decrypting
so how aircrack is working right here
you can see this passphrase over here
the first five or six digits
are
a
it starts working its way from the end
from the last character it keeps trying
every single combination you can see the
last the fourth character from the right
side the d it will eventually turn to e
because it keeps checking up every
single character from the end
this will keep going on until all the
single characters are tested and every
single combination is tried out
since the handshake file is encrypted
using the security key that is the wpa2
key of the router
whichever pass phrase is able to decrypt
the handshake key completely will be the
key of the wi-fi router
this is the way we can brute-force into
wi-fi routers anywhere in the world
apart from individuals organizations
worldwide that host data and conduct
business over the internet are always at
the risk of a ddos attack
these ddos attacks are getting more
extreme with hackers getting easy access
to botnet farms and compromised devices
as can be seen in the graph three of the
six strongest ddos attacks were launched
in 2021 with the most extreme attack
occurring just last year in 2020
lately cyber criminals have been
actively seeking out new services and
protocols for amplifying these ddos
attacks
active involvement with hack machines
and botnets allow further penetration
into the consumer space allowing much
more elaborate attack campaigns
apart from general users multinational
corporations have also had their fair
share of problems github a platform for
software developers was the target of a
ddos attack in 2018.
widely suspected to be conducted by
chinese authorities this attack went on
for about 20 minutes after which the
systems were brought into a stable
condition
it was the strongest ddos attack to date
at the time and made a lot of companies
reconsider the security practices to
compare such attacks
even after years of experimentation ddos
attacks are still at large and can
affect anyone in the consumer and
corporate space
hey everyone this is bev from simply
learn and welcome to this video on what
is a ddos attack
let's take a look at the topics we will
be covering today
we start by learning what is a ddos
attack and how it works on a phase by
phase level
we learn about the distant categories in
ddos attacks and the potential aim of
hackers when they launch a ddos attack
campaign
we also look at some preventive measures
that can be taken to protect oneself
from these ddos attacks
finally we have a demonstration of how
such attacks can hamper the working of a
server system using vmware and parrot
security operating system
but before moving forward make sure you
are subscribed to the simply learn
youtube channel don't forget to hit the
bell icon to receive updates about more
informative videos from our channel so
let's learn more about what is a ddos
attack
a distributed denial of service attack
or ddos is when an attacker or attackers
attempt to make it impossible for a
service to be delivered
this can be achieved by thwarting access
to virtually anything servers devices
services networks applications and even
specific transactions within
applications
in a dos attack it's one system that is
sending the malicious data or requests a
ddos attack comes from multiple systems
generally these attacks work by drowning
a system with requests for data
this could be sending a web server so
many requests to serve a page that it
crashes under the demand or it could be
a database being hit with a high volume
of queries
the result is available internet
bandwidth cpu and ram capacity become
overwhelmed
the impact could range from a minor
annoyance from disrupted services to
experiencing entire websites
applications or even entire businesses
taking offline
more often than not these attacks are
launched using machines in a botnet a
botnet is a network of devices that can
be triggered to send requests from a
remote source often known as the command
and control center
the bots in the network attack a
particular target thereby hiding the
original perpetrator of the ddos
campaign
but how do these devices come under a
botnet and what are the requests being
made to the web servers
let's learn more about these and how dos
attack work
a ddos attack is a two-phase process
in the first phase a hacker creates a
botnet of devices
simply put a vast network of computers
are hacked via malware ransomware or
just simple social engineering
these devices become a part of the
botnet which can be triggered anytime to
start bombarding a system or a server
on the instruction of the hacker that
created the botnet
the devices in this network are called
bots or zombies
in the second phase a particular target
is selected for the attack
when the hacker finds the right time to
attack all the zombies in the botnet
network send these requests to the
target thereby taking up all the servers
available bandwidth
these can be simple ping requests or
complex attacks like syn flooding and
udp flooding the aim is to overwhelm
them with more traffic than the server
or the network can accommodate the goal
is to render the website or service
inoperable
there is a lot of wiggle room when it
comes to the type of ddos attack a
hacker can go with
depending on the target's vulnerability
we can choose one of the three broad
categories of ddos attacks
volume based attacks use massive amounts
of bogus traffic to overwhelm a resource
it can be a website or a server
they include icmp udap and spoofed
packet flood attacks
the size of volume based attack is
measured in bits per second
these attacks focus on clogging all the
available bandwidth for the server
thereby cutting the supply shot
several requests are sent to the server
all of which warrant a reply thereby not
allowing the target to cater to the
general legitimate users
next we have the protocol level attacks
these attacks are meant to consume
essential resources of the target server
they exhaust the load balancers and
firewalls which are meant to protect the
system against the ddos attacks
these protocol attacks include syn
floods and smurf ddos among others and
the size is measured in packets per
second
for example in an ssl handshake server
replies to the hello message sent by the
hacker which will be the client in this
case but since the ip is spoofed and
leads nowhere the server gets stuck in
an endless loop of sending the
acknowledgement without any end in sight
finally we have the application level
attacks
application layer attacks are conducted
by flooding applications with
maliciously crafted requests
the size of application layer attacks is
measured in requests per second
these are relatively sophisticated
attacks that target the application and
operating system level vulnerabilities
they prevent the specific applications
from delivering necessary information to
users and hawk the network bandwidth up
to the point of a system crash
examples of such an attack are http
flooding and bgp hijacking
a single device can request data from a
server using http post or get without
any issues
however when the requisite botnet is
instructed to bombard the server with
thousands of requests the database
bandwidth gets jammed and it eventually
becomes unresponsive and unusable
but what about the reasons for such an
attack there are multiple lines of
thought as to why a hacker decides to
launch a ddos attack on unsuspecting
targets let's take a look at few of them
the first option is to gain a
competitive advantage
many ddos attacks are conducted by
hacking communities against rival groups
some organizations hire such communities
to stagger their rivals resources at a
network level to gain an advantage in
the playing field
since being a victim of a ddos attack
indicates a lack of security the
reputation of such a company takes a
significant hit allowing the rivals to
cover up some ground
secondly some hackers launch these ddos
attacks to hold multinational
corporations at ransom
the resources are jammed and the only
way to clear the way is if the target
company agrees to pay a designated
amount of money to the hackers
even a few minutes of inactivity is
detrimental to a company's reputation in
the global market and it can cause a
spiral effect both in terms of market
value and product security index
most of the time a compromise is reached
and the resources are freed after a
while
tdos attacks have also found use in the
political segment
certain activists tend to use ddos
attacks to voice their opinion
spreading the word online is much faster
than any local rally or forum
primarily political these attacks also
focus on online communities ethical
dilemmas or even protests against
corporations
let's take a look at a few ways that
companies and individuals can protect
themselves against edos attacks
the company can employ load balancers
and firewalls to help protect the data
from such attacks
load balancers reroute the traffic from
one server to another in a ddos attack
this reduces the single point of failure
and adds resiliency to the server data
a firewall blocks unwanted traffic into
a system and manages the number of
requests made at a definite rate it
checks for multiple attacks from a
single ip and occasional slowdowns to
detect a ddos attack in action
early detection of a ddos attack goes a
long way in recovering the data lost in
such an event once you've detected the
attack you will have to find a way to
respond for example you will have to
work on dropping the malicious ddos
traffic before it reaches your server so
that it doesn't throttle and exhaust
your bandwidth
here's where you will filter the traffic
so that only legitimate traffic reaches
the server
by intelligent routing you can break the
remaining traffic into manageable chunks
that can be handled by your cluster
resources
the most important stage in ddos
mitigation is where you will look for
patterns of redos attacks and use those
to analyze and strengthen your
mitigation techniques for example
blocking an ip that's repeatedly found
to be offending is a first step
cloud providers like amazon web services
and microsoft azure who offer high
levels of cyber security including
firewalls and threat monitoring software
can help protect your assets and network
from ddos criminals
the cloud also has greater bandwidth
than most private networks so it is
likely to fail if under the pressure of
increased tdos attacks
additionally reputable cloud providers
offer network redundancy duplicating
copies of your data systems and
equipment so that if your service
becomes corrupted or unavailable due to
a ddos attack you can switch to a secure
access on backed up versions without
missing a beat
one can also increase the amount of
bandwidth available to a host server
being targeted
since tdos attacks fundamentally operate
on the principle of overwhelming systems
with heavy traffic simply provisioning
extra bandwidth to handle unexpected
traffic spikes can provide a measure of
protection
the solution can prove expensive as a
lot of that bandwidth is going to go
unused most of the time
a content delivery network or a cdn
distributes your content and boosts
performance by minimizing the distance
between your resources and end users it
stores the cached version of your
content in multiple locations and this
eventually mitigates ddos attacks by
avoiding a single point of failure when
the attacker is trying to focus on a
single target popular cdns include
akamai cdn cloudflare aws cloudfront etc
let's start with our demo regarding the
effects of ddos attacks on a system
for a demo we have a single device that
will attack a target making it a dos
attack of sorts
once a botnet is ready multiple devices
can do the same and eventually emulate a
ddos attack
to do so we will use the virtualization
software called vmware with an instance
of parrot security operating system
running
for a target machine we will be running
another vmware instance of a standard
linux distribution known as linux lite
in a target device we can use wireshark
to determine when the attack begins and
see the effects of the attack
accordingly
this is linux like which is a target
machine
and this is parrot security which is
used by the hacker when trying to launch
a ddos attack this is just one of the
distros that can be used
to launch the attack we must first find
the ip address of our target
so to find the ip address we open the
terminal
we use the command ifconfig
and here we can find the ip address now
remember we're launching this attack in
vmware now the both the instances of
parrot security and linux light are
being run on my local network so the
address that you can see here is
192.168.72
which is a private address
this ip cannot be accessed from outside
the network basically anyone who is not
connected to my wi-fi
when launching attacks with public
servers or public addresses it will have
a public ip address that does not belong
to the 192.168 subnet
once we have the ip address
we can use a tool called
hping3
hping3 is an open source packet
generator and analyzer for the tcp ip
protocol
to check what are the effects of an
attack we will be using wireshark
wireshark is a network traffic analyzer
we can see whatever traffic that is
passing through the linux light distro
is being displayed over here with the ip
address the source ip and the
destination ip as to where the request
is being transferred to
once we have the dos attack launched you
can see the results coming over here
from the source id which will be parrot
security now to launch the hping3
command we need to give sudo access to
the console which is the root access
now we have the root access for the
console
the hping3 command will have a few
arguments to go with it which are as you
can see on the screen
minus s
and a flood
a hyphen v
hyphen p80
and
the ip address of the target which is
192 168 72.129
in this command we have a few arguments
that such as the minus s which specifies
syn packets like in an ssl handshake we
have the syn
request that the client sends to the
server to initiate a connection
the hyphen flood aims to ignore the
replies that the server will send back
to the client in response to the syn
packets here the parent security os is
the client and linux slide being the
server
minus v stands for verbosity as in where
we will see some output when the
requests are being sent
the hyphen p80 stands for port 80 which
we can replace the port number if we
want to attack a different port and
finally we have the ip address of our
target
as of right now if we check wireshark it
is relatively clear and there is no
indication of a ddos attack incoming
now once we launch the attack over here
we can see the
request coming in from this ip which is
192 168 72.128
till now even the network is responsive
and so is linux light
the requests keep on coming and we can
see the http
flooding has started in flood mode
after a few seconds of this attack
continuing
the server will start shutting down
now remember linux light is a distro
that can focus on one that serves as a
back end
remember linux light is a distro and
such linux distros are served as backend
to many servers across the world for
example a few seconds have passed from
the attack
now the system has become completely
irresponsive this has happened due to
the huge number of requests that came
from pilot security
you can see whatever i press nothing is
responded even the wireshark has stopped
capturing new request because the cpu
usage right now is completely 100
and at this point of time anyone who is
trying to request some information from
this linux distro or where this linux
distro is being used as a backend for a
server or a database cannot access
anything else the system has completely
stopped responding and any request any
legitimate request from legitimate users
will be dropped
once you stop the attack over here it
takes a bit of time to settle down now
remember it's still out of control but
eventually the traffic dies down and the
system regains its strength
it is relatively easy to gauge right now
the effect of a dos attack now remember
this linux light is just a vm instance
actual website servers and
web databases they have much more
bandwidth and are very secure and it is
tough to break into
that is why we cannot use a single
machine to break into them that is where
a ddos attack comes into play what we
did right now is a dos attack as in a
single system is being used to penetrate
a
target server using a single request
now
when a ddos attack multiple systems such
as multiple pirate security instances or
multiple zombies or bots in a botnet
network can attack a target server to
completely shut down the machine and
drop any legitimate request thereby
rendering the service and the target
completely unusable and inoperable
as a final note we would like to remind
that this is for educational purposes
only and we do not endorse any attacks
on any one domains only test this on
servers and networks that you have
permission to test on the important
question is how to become a certified
ethical hacker in order to become a
certified ethical hacker you need to
pass the certified ethical hacker or the
ceh exam from ec council which tests the
broad knowledge of subject matter that
is required for someone to be an
effective ethical hacker well since its
inception in 2003 the certified ethical
hacker has been the absolute choice of
the industry globally it is recognized
worldwide and has been endorsed by
governmental agencies like the nsa the
ch exam is also is accredited by nc
which adds credibility and value to the
credential members the ces exam is
computerized proctored exam you'll have
four hours to complete 125 questions
there are some sources of information
that mentions that in order to pass you
need to score about 60 to 80 percent the
actual percentage of questions that you
must answer correctly varies from exam
to exam and depends on the difficulty of
the exams delivered when you take the
exam the harder the questions that are
asked the fewer questions you need to
get right to pass the exam if you get
easier questions then you will need to
get more of the questions right to pass
the exam however keep in mind that when
you take the actual exam at the testing
center the passing grade may vary the ch
certification exam cost five hundred
dollars plus an additional eligibility
fee of hundred dollars the exam duration
is for four hours the questions are all
multiple choice the exam is only
available in english as of today
candidates can take the ces exam online
using a remotely proctored service from
anywhere in the world 24 7 as long as
they have a computer equipped with a
webcam and a microphone let's discuss
the exam outline the exam is broken into
seven domains networking and information
background covers about 32
analysis assessment covers 12
security covers 23
tools system programs 29
procedures methodology 9
regulation policy 2 percent and ethics 3
percent let's discuss these domains a
little more in detail networking and
information background this first domain
of the ceh exam is designed to test your
knowledge of everything that you need to
know to practice ethical hacking which
isn't specific to any information
security domain the objectives of this
domain include network and communication
technologies next is information
security threats and attack vector such
as malwares oas top 10 etc the final
objective covers information security
technologies such as mobile technologies
telecommunication technologies backups
archiving etc analysis assessment this
domain of the certified ethical hacker
exam is designed to test your knowledge
of what goes into performing a
penetration test or ethical hacking the
objectives of this domain are
information security assessment and
analysis and information security
assessment process combination of ethics
and regulation policy domains covers
five percent of the total exam weightage
the objectives of these domains are
ethics of information security which
covers what is considered ethical and
unethical from the perspective of the
ceh certification not only you will be
expected to behave ethically you will be
expected to adhere to a code of ethics
next objective is information security
policies laws acts which covers some of
the major information security
regulations and the evaluation of
organizational security policies this is
an important procedures methodology this
is an important domain and carries a
weightage of nine percent there are two
objectives the first objective covers
information security procedures which is
the step-by-step methods that is used to
identify prevent and enforce security
controls against unwanted behavior the
next objective is information security
assessment methodologies which covers
security assessments to determine
security gaps that may pose a risk to
the organization tools systems programs
this domain carries the maximum
weightage of 29
and so you should expect the maximum
number of questions from here this
domain is heavily focused on knowledge
of the specific systems programs and
tools used in ethical hacking there are
three objectives first objective covers
information security systems such as
firewalls intrusion detection and
prevention systems siem solutions etc
next objective covers information
security programs that are used to
secure a whole system against malicious
attackers these programs include
antivirus anti-spyware anti-risk wear ad
blockers anti-root kit etc the final
objective covers information security
tools used for performing foot printing
and reconnaissance performing
enumeration conducting network scanning
performing web application hacking etc
the security domain is the second
largest domain on the exam with 23
percent weightage this domain is divided
into three objectives the first
objective covers information security
controls such as administrative controls
technical controls and physical controls
the second objective information
security attack detection covers various
methods to detect attacks against an
organization's information security the
final objective information security
attack prevention covers proactive
methods that organizations can use to
protect themselves from malicious
attackers from malicious attacks let us
understand the importance of the ca
certification before getting to know
about its content
so why should you take up the ch version
11. the certified ethical hacker is the
most trusted ethical hacking
certification and a recommended one by
employers around the globe
since the introduction of the ca
certification in 2003 it is globally
recognized as a standard within the
information security field the ch
version 11 by ec council continues to
keep up to the standard and it
familiarizes the latest hacking
techniques and teaches you advanced
hacking tools and exploits used
the ch version 11 aligns with the
current cyber security market
requirements and adds the latest
advancements in the cyber security field
the ca certification helps and trains
you to think like a hacker and this in
turn helps you beat a hacker and defend
your network after obtaining the ca
certification you'll be a certified
ethical hacker a certified ethical
hacker is a skilled professional working
in a red team environment who safeguards
networks and understands attack
strategies and mimics the skills of
malicious hackers certified ethical
hackers discover vulnerabilities in a
system and operate with permission from
the system owners only
so who can become a certified ethical
hacker and who can take up the ca
certification let us have a look at that
now
in the first case to be eligible for the
ca certification exam you need to attend
the official training from authorized ec
council training partners it can be an
online training or tutor-led training
from easy council learning partners only
then are you eligible to take up the ca
certification exam
so a candidate who has completed an
official ec council training is eligible
to take up the exam without going
through the application process
or in the second case in order to be
considered for this credential you need
to have at least two years of work
experience in the information security
domain and you must pay a non-refundable
application fee and submit an
eligibility application form
once it is approved you can take up the
ch exam after the application is
approved you can purchase the test
voucher
in the latest version of the ceh we will
see the addition of various core
concepts moving on to our next topic let
us see how different the ch version 11
is and few of its objectives
firstly it outlines ethical hacking
concepts cyber kill chain concepts and
overview of information security and
various laws and regulations related to
information security this certification
briefs you about the faces of system
hacking attacking techniques and how you
can maintain access
it also briefs you about footprinting
concepts and ways of utilizing
footprinting tools along with necessary
countermeasures
the next objective is to familiarize
with vulnerability assessment along with
the hands-on experience of various
scanning tools
next we have cybersecurity threats like
malware threats analysis of various
worms viruses and trojans various
malware concepts packets sniffing
concepts and techniques have been
introduced into this domain
it also highlights the concepts related
to social engineering denial of service
attacks sql injection and evasion
techniques it also speaks about wireless
hacking concepts and mobile device
management
the concept of operational technology is
a new addition this time
next is getting acquainted with security
solutions like firewalls honeypots ips
their evasion and protection
our fifth point is knowing various
topics in cryptography like encryption
algorithms public key infrastructure and
cryptanalysis
moving on the next objective is to
incorporate padded security os as it
offers better performance on lower
powered laptops and machines when
compared to kali linux
next is to learn to recognize and deal
with iot based vulnerabilities and
attacks with the ch version 11 course
that covers the latest iot hacking tools
you would be required to ensure the
safety of iot devices
our next point is with respect to the
evolving cloud industry you would need
to learn how to identify and defend
cloud-based threats and attacks
the latest version of ch includes new
operating systems and windows 10
configured with domain controller and
vulnerable web applications for
improving hacking skills
finally what is different is that more
than 50 percent of the ch version 11
course is dedicated to practical skills
in live ranges by our ec council labs ec
council leads in this aspect of the
industry now that we saw the ch exam
objectives let us look into the ch exam
topics weightage
as you see on your screens this is a pie
chart with 9 domains in ch along with
their weightages you can prepare for
your exam accordingly
let us move on and take a closer look at
each of these domains their respective
subdomains and their descriptions
our first domain is information security
and ethical hacking overview
this domain consists of questions from
information security cyber kill chain
concepts ethical hacking concepts
various hacking concepts and information
security laws and standards
you can expect a total number of eight
questions from this domain the weightage
of this section is six percent
the second domain is reconnaissance
techniques under the subdomains we have
footprinting and reconnaissance at first
this covers various topics like
footprinting concepts footprinting
methodology email footprinting
footprinting through web services dns
footprinting footprinting through social
engineering etc
the next subdomain in this section is
scanning networks
scanning networks covers various
concepts like scanning tools host
discovery port and service discovery os
discovery draw network diagrams scanning
beyond ids firewall
etc and our third subdomain under
reconnaissance techniques is enumeration
various topics like snmp enumeration ntp
and nfs enumeration smtp and dns
enumeration and enumeration counter
measures are covered under this
subdomain
a total of 26 questions will be asked
from this domain under footprinting and
reconnaissance you will have 10
questions and under scanning networks
and other 10 and finally under
enumeration you will have six questions
a total weightage of 21
is given to this particular topic
our third domain is system hacking faces
and attack techniques
under our third domain our first sub
domain is about vulnerability analysis
this subdomain covers topics on
vulnerability assessment vulnerability
classification vulnerability assessment
solutions and tools and various
vulnerability assessment reports our
next sub-domain is about system hacking
you have concepts like gaining access
cracking passwords vulnerability
exploitation escalating privileges
maintaining access covered under this
subdomain and finally we have malware
threads under this domain malware
threads incorporate concepts like apt
concepts trojan concepts virus and worm
concepts malware analysis and so on a
total of 21 questions will be asked from
this domain
under vulnerability analysis there will
be nine questions asked system hacking
and other six questions and finally
under malware threats you will have six
other questions asked that can be that
sums up to a total 21 with a weightage
of 17 for this domain
our fourth domain is about network and
perimeter hacking
here you have various sub domains and
one of it is social engineering under
social engineering you will be asked
questions based on social engineering
techniques insider threats impersonation
on social networking sites identity
theft and so on you'll also have various
question on the sniffing concepts as it
is another sub-domain
you can also expect questions from the
denial of service subdomain here
questions related to botnets and ddos
attacks will be asked
various session hijacking concepts are
another crucial part of this domain
the final subdomain is about evading ids
firewalls and honeypots
here various concepts on ids ips
firewall and honeypots are covered you
will need to understand how to evade ids
and firewalls and how to detect
honeypots
a total number of 18 questions will be
asked from the fourth domain that was
network and perimeter hacking and the
weightage for this domain is 14
our fifth domain is about web
application hacking and our first sub
domain in it is hacking web servers
this incorporates concepts related to
web server attacks web server attack
tools patch management and so on
the next subdomain is about hacking web
applications here you have various
concepts related to bypass client side
controls analyze web applications
footprint web infrastructure attack
access controls and how to perform
injection attacks and so on
finally under the sql injection
subdomain
you will have questions based on sql
injection the types of sql injection the
sql injection methodology sql injection
tools aviation techniques and sql
injection counter measures
here a total of 20 questions will be
asked from this domain
and that is a weightage of 16 percent
will be given to the web application
hacking domain
our six domain is solely devoted to
wireless network hacking
this domain focuses on hacking wireless
networks various wireless concepts
wireless encryption wireless threats
wireless hacking tools various hacking
methodologies bluetooth hacking and
wireless counter measures are covered a
total of eight questions will be asked
from this domain with a weightage of six
percent
our seventh domain is all about mobile
platform iot and ot hacking our first
subdomain here is hacking mobile
platforms
here the concepts that are touched upon
are mobile platform attack vectors
hacking android os hacking ios mobile
device management and mobile security
guidelines and tools
our next sub domain here is about iot
and ot hacking which covers concepts on
iot hacking tools its methodologies
counter measures and it also speaks
about ot concepts ot attacks ot hacking
tools and ot counter measures
you have a total of 10 questions asked
from this domain with a weightage of 8
percent the next domain is very
interesting and it is all related to
cloud the cloud computing domain covers
concepts based on cloud computing
server-less computing cloud computing
threats cloud hacking and cloud security
the weightage given to this domain is
six percent with the total number of
questions of seven and finally we have
cryptography as our ninth domain
as the name suggests this domain covers
topics based on cryptography concepts
encryption algorithms cryptography tools
public key infrastructure email
encryption disk encryption cryptanalysis
and counter measures
and seven questions will be asked from
this domain with a weightage of six
percent now that you saw the ch exam
topic's weightage let us have a closer
look at the ch exam details let us first
have a look at the ch exam based on mcqs
the exam title is certified ethical
hacker with the exam code of 312-50
this exam will have 125 questions with a
time limit of 4 hours the test format is
multiple choice questions
the pass percentage varies ideally
between 60 to 85 percent
now let's have a look at the ch
practical exam details in order to gain
the ch master recognition it is
mandatory that you take up the ch
practical exam as well
the exam title is certified ethical
hacker practical and this practical exam
will have 20 questions with the duration
of six hours
the exam format will be ilab cyber range
and finally the passing score for the ch
practical exam is at 70 percent after
clearing both the mcq based exam and the
practical exam you can get the ch master
recognition now that we had a look at
the ch exam details let us have a look
at the career prospects for a
professional with this certification
let's look at the critical skills you
need to become a certified ethical
hacker
first is coding
ethical hackers should have an excellent
grasp of the various programming
languages and understand the coding
techniques to gain access to any
software
it will help you understand the tools
hackers develop to infiltrate a security
system
some of the popular coding languages
ethical hackers need to know are python
javascript php and sql
coming to the second skill
so ethical hackers should know the
basics of different operating systems
specifically linux as it is more secure
than any other operating system most web
servers run on linux operating system
gaining access to this server to check
for false is another must have skill for
ethical hackers
now they also need to understand how
firewalls work as well
coming to the
third skill so to become an ethical
hacker you must understand both wired
and wireless networks they must know
networks like dhcp
nat and subnetting to investigate the
different interconnected machines in a
network and the possible security
threats that this may create now moving
on to the fourth skill
having good knowledge of wireless
technologies like wired equivalent
privacy or wep
wi-fi protected access or wpa and wi-fi
protected setup or wps will help ethical
hackers guard systems against sending
information via hidden streams ethical
hackers need to grasp how to write sql
statements for in-band out-of-band and
blind sql attacks which can swiftly
compromise the database operation and
the date holes cryptography deals with
transforming a normal text message to a
non-readable form during the
transmission to make it incomprehensible
for hackers
an ethical hacker ensures that
conversation between different people
within the organization does not leak
now coming to the final skill
ethical hackers additionally require
analytical thinking and problem solving
skills to succeed at this job
they should be able to reverse engineer
security frameworks come up with
uncommon ways to break into a network
this also requires thinking outside the
box
now companies across various industries
hire ethical hackers for several job
roles so once you become a certified
ethical hacker you can get into multiple
job roles let's look at a few of them
first we have security analyst
the security analysts execute security
systems to safeguard the organization's
networks data and also help to maintain
security standards
they document the security breaches and
measure the damage cost security
analysts also analyze the security
issues thoroughly to identify the root
cause
the second job role we have is
penetration tester so penetration
testers conduct tests and purposefully
try to exploit existing computer systems
and software to identify and correct
system weaknesses
they implement solutions to enhance data
security and provide recommendations
based on an assessment of hardware and
software systems
the third job role we have for a
certified ethical hacker is security
engineer
so security engineers understand
complicated technical issues and manage
them with a fast paced business
environment
they also conduct proactive research to
investigate security vulnerabilities and
recommend suitable strategies
and finally we have the job role of a
security consultant
cyber security consultants are highly in
demand today and are amongst the heavily
paid professionals a cyber security
consultant is responsible for protecting
sensitive data that come from various
aspects of the digital world they evade
security risks and prevent cyber attacks
security consultants study security
criteria or cybersecurity criteria
security systems and validation
procedures
now before we go further i have another
question for you people
so which
role do you think is the most exciting
do let us know your responses in the
comments section of the video we would
be glad to hear from you
now moving
ahead with the increasing number of
cyber attacks across the globe ethical
hackers are in demand like never before
very recently a united nation official
warned that cyber crime went up by 600
percent during the kobe 19 pandemic
as per the government data presented in
parliament
india alone reported 1.16 million cyber
attacks in 2020
that's almost 3x times more than 2019.
now according to cyber security ventures
cyber threats will cost nearly 6
trillion u.s dollars in 2021.
cyber security ventures also expects
global cyber crime costs will grow up by
15 per year over the next five years and
reach 10.5 trillion us dollars annually
by 2025.
now there is a huge shortage of ethical
hacking professionals globally according
to the bureau of labor statistics the
information security industry is
expected to grow 32 percent in the next
decade
another report by cyber security
ventures tells that the world will have
3.5 million unfilled cyber security jobs
by the end of 2021
according to a report by the data
security council of india the indian
cyber security services industry is
expected to grow to about 7.6 billion
dollars in 2022 and would be worth 13.6
billion dollars by 2025. so companies
are looking for trained ethical hackers
who can protect their networks and
safeguard them from potential threats a
few of the industries that heavily rely
on ethical hackers are healthcare
companies financial institutions energy
companies and government agencies
with ample opportunities lying ahead
what's stopping you from starting a
career in cyber security
with the world churning virtual cyber
attacks are constantly flooding new
headlines
kovit 19 accelerated the current digital
transformation and the year 2020
witnessed several data breaches
since technology has become more
intertwined with our daily lives it is
no surprise that the need for skilled
cyber security professionals is
increasing
on that note hey everyone welcome yet to
another exciting video by simply learn
which will take you through the top
cyber security career options available
today but before we begin if you're new
here and haven't subscribed already make
sure to hit the subscribe button and
that bell icon for interesting tech
videos every day
there is a significant lack of skilled
cyber security professionals who can
tackle the cyber security challenges
faced daily hence a career in cyber
security is demanding and equally
rewarding
finding the right career path in the
cyber security industry isn't always
easy here we are here to help you with
that
there are a few prerequisites for a
career in cyber security the basic one
being a bachelor's degree in a subject
relating to cyber security
however if you don't have a relevant
degree you can always take up relevant
cybersecurity certifications and
kickstart your cybersecurity journey
a few other skills like networking
knowledge of operating systems and cloud
security are required to start and grow
your cyber security career you can check
out our video on the top 5 cyber
security skills to know more
cyber security jobs vary from entry
level to executive management and
everything in between there are several
cyber security paths available today it
is best if you start with entry level
and then move on to the next level with
the help of certifications and relevant
experience
here let us have a look at the top 5
cyber security job roles today
the first job role is that of a network
engineer
network engineers construct and
administer a company's computer networks
they are responsible for installing
configuring and supporting network
equipment they also configure and
maintain firewalls switches and routers
this entry-level cyber security job can
help you start your journey to become an
ethical hacker
the annual average salary of a network
engineer in the us is eighty-five
thousand and ninety-eight dollars and in
india it is around five hundred ten
thousand rupees
second on our list is information
security analyst as an information
security analyst your primary duty is to
protect sensitive information
information security analysts create and
implement plans for preventing cyber
attacks they monitor data access and
ensure compliance with policies
depending on the cyber threat they
decide if it has to be resolved or
escalated further in the u.s an
information security analyst earns 89
and 140 annually and in india they earn
6 lakh 42 and 756 rupees
third on our list is ethical hacker they
are also known as penetration testers
they are network security consultants
who identify and exploit system
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do
they probe and test the network using
various penetration tools and software
they also design new penetration tools
and document the test results in the us
a certified ethical hacker earns around
93 000 on an annual average basis and in
india they make around 5 lakh rupees
the fourth job role that we are going to
talk about is security architect
security architects research and plan
the security elements for their
organizations they design robust
security structures that are capable of
preventing malware attacks
a security architect approves the
installation of routers vpn and
firewalls their duties go beyond just
architecture building and including
formulating company procedures
guidelines and user guides
security architects in the us make a
handsome sum of 124 000 a year on an
average and in india they make nearly 21
lakh 80 000 rupees
and finally fifth on our list is chief
information security officer ciso they
are senior level officers in an
organization they ensure the safety of
the information they develop implement
and maintain information security and
risk management programs they also
interact with stakeholders and regularly
brief them with information security
concerns
the average annual salary of a chief
information security officer in the
states is a whopping
165 thousand dollars annually and in
india it is 22 lakh 22
and 845 rupees
several companies are looking for
skilled cyber security professionals
philip siemens google microsoft and ge
to name a few with passion the right
amount of experience and relevant
certifications you can grow your cyber
security career you can check out simply
learn cyber security expert master's
program to equip you with the necessary
skills needed to become an expert in
this rapidly growing domain
this course will help you learn various
methods as to how you can protect your
infrastructure secure your data run risk
analysis achieve compliance and much
more choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1 000 plus
hours of video content for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
the books we are going to talk about in
this live session will familiarize you
with hacking on the whole these books
will introduce you to new ideas and help
you solve problems reading in general is
great as it helps with your thought
process and keeps you mentally alert it
is important that you use the
information in the upcoming books only
for lawful purposes
so let's get started and see the best
books which can help you with hacking
the first book we have is the basics of
hacking and penetration testing
this book is written by patrick
ingretzen for all your beginners out
there if you're clueless about how to go
about hacking then this is a good read
for you all having said that this book
is not just for beginners but even for
those individuals who are only exposed
to superficial penetration testing logic
this book dives deep into the tools and
processes that are used by penetration
testers to gain access to the systems
the basics of hacking and penetration
testing book will help you achieve a
better understanding of offensive
security as well you'll be acquainted
with various phases of ethical hacking
here
the book contains seven chapters and it
focuses on hacking tools such as
backtrack linux google reconnaissance
nmap nessus metasploit and hacker
defender rootkit to name a few the fun
part is that each chapter consists of
hands-on exercises that help you
interpret and implement results in each
phase this book is apt for students
beginning infosec professionals and
security consultants
the second book we have is hacking a
beginner's guide to computer hacking
basic security and penetration testing
it is written by john slavio
this is yet another go-to book for
beginners this book can be your first
step to a career in ethical hacking it
will cover all the basics with respect
to hacking security and pen
testing the tools covered in this book
are history of hacking types of hackers
various types of hacking attacks basic
hacking tools and software and hiding ip
address it also speaks about mobile
hacking hacking an email address
penetration testing and spoofing attacks
up next we have hacking the art of
exploitation
it is written by john erickson this book
has two editions one which was published
in 2003 and the other in 2008.
this book is famous for the hacking
approach it teaches it focuses on
network security and computer security
it helps you understand how to develop
exploits rather than just using them if
you want to up your ethical hacking game
then this book definitely requires a
read
hacking the art of exploitation in its
second edition introduces you to c
programming from a hacker's perspective
out of the plethora of concepts that you
will learn in this book few crucial ones
are that you will learn to program
computers using c and shell scripts you
will also be able to outplay security
measures like intrusion detection
systems having said that you will also
learn to hijack tcp connections crack
encrypted wireless traffic and speed up
brute force attacks
let's now have a look at the next
ethical hacking book on our list and
that is kali linux ethical hackers
cookbook
this book revolving around kali linux is
written by himanshu sharma
kali linux is primarily used for
advanced penetration testing and also
for security auditing it contains
numerous tools that are geared towards
various security tasks such as security
research penetration testing and so on
this book will help you get started with
installation and configuration of kali
linux which will enable you to perform
your tests
in addition to that you will learn to
perform web application exploitation
using tools such as burp you will also
be acquainted with performing network
exploitation using metasploit and by a
shark lastly you will know how to
conduct advanced penetration testing
these were few of the concepts you will
be learning besides a lot more others in
the book
at number 5 we have metasploit the
penetration testers guide
this book is written by four authors
david kennedy jimmy gorman
devon kearns and martija haroni the
metasploit framework is a powerful tool
for hackers to exploit ip addresses and
ports in it
this framework makes discovering and
exploiting vulnerabilities easy
but for first time users it can be a
little tricky hence this book will teach
you all about metasploit
you will learn the frameworks interfaces
module system and more as you launch
simulated attacks after which you will
move on to advanced penetration testing
techniques which include network
reconnaissance client-side attacks
wireless attacks and targeted social
engineering attacks you will also learn
to integrate nexpose nmap and message
with metasploit to automate discovery
up next we have penetration testing a
hands-on introduction to hacking
this book is written by georgia reedman
as the name suggests this book shows an
insight into penetration testing
a penetration tester discovers security
weaknesses in operating systems networks
and applications penetration techniques
are used to gauge enterprise defenses
this book focuses on the core skills and
techniques a penetration tester requires
here you'll go through the prime stages
of an actual assessment which includes
gathering information untravel
vulnerabilities gaining access to
networks and so on
in addition to the above you will learn
to crack passwords with the techniques
of brute forcing and word lists bypass
antivirus software automate attacks and
you will also learn to use metasploit
framework for launching exploits and for
writing your own metasploit modules out
of the many other learnings
moving on to our next book we have the
hackle playbook 3.
the hacker playbook 3 practical guide to
penetration testing is written by peter
kim
this is the third iteration of the
hacker playbook series it brings with
itself new strategies attacks exploits
tips and tricks
besides all the new concepts it also
highlights a few techniques from the
previous versions many schools have this
book incorporated in their teaching
the hacker playbook 3 red team edition
acquaints you with the red team red
teams simulate real world advanced
attacks to test your organization's
defensive teams a red teamer will
accurately test and validate the overall
security program reading the hacker
playbook 3 will help you advance your
offensive hacking skills and attack
parts in addition to that it also
focuses on real-world attacks
exploitation custom malware persistence
and more
this heavily lab based book will
incorporate several virtual machines and
custom the hacker playbook tools
at number eight we have black hat python
python programming for hackers and pen
testers
justin seats is the author of this book
as you know python is a very strong
programming language and it comes to
great use when creating powerful and
effective hacking tools python is the
chosen language by many security
professionals across the world and many
exploit frameworks are written in python
in this book you will go through the
darker side of python's capabilities
like infecting virtual machines writing
network sniffers creating trojans etc
this book covers some networking
fundamentals interesting network tooling
web applications windows privilege
escalation tricks and more this book as
the author says is a fun
read moving on at number nine we have
the web application hackers handbook
finding and exploiting security flaw
it is written by david started and
marcus pinto
this new edition focuses on updated web
applications exposing them to attacks
and executing fraudulent transactions
this web application hackers handbook is
updated to speak about the latest
step-by-step methods for attacking and
defending the large range of ever
evolving web applications
it also discusses new remoting
frameworks html5 ui redress and hybrid
file attacks to name a few it looks into
attacking authentication attacking the
application server finding
vulnerabilities in source code etc if
you have already mastered the first
edition you can focus on new concepts in
this one
now let's head to our last book on our
list
at 10 we have web security testing
cookbook systematic techniques to find
problems first
the author of this book is parkour hope
and ben walther
security testing is quite often a
neglected one when it comes to the tests
performed on web applications but it is
a very crucial one this book teaches you
how to check for the most common web
security issues it also acquaints you
with installing and configuring free and
good security testing tools
you will also understand how your
application communicates with users and
this book will help you build tests
pinpointed at ajax functions and help
you automate the tests with the
knowledge of this book and the free
tools used here you can defend your site
so those were the top 10 books for
ethical hacking
now that you had a look at the books
let's move on and see how simply learn
can help you become an ethical hacker
simply learn provides a certified
ethical hacker ch version 10 course this
ca certification training course
provides you hands-on training that will
help you master the techniques used to
penetrate network systems and defend
your system against it
simply learns ethical hacking courses
aligned with the latest ch version 10 by
ec council here you will learn about
trojan's back doors and countermeasures
ids firewalls and honeypots advanced
hacking concepts network packet analysis
mobile and web technologies and advanced
log management this course content
includes an introduction to ethical
hacking penetration testing and ethical
hacking concepts
it also speaks about sql injection iot
hacking and cryptography to name a few
there are no prerequisites to take up
this certification training course in
this video we will run you through the
top 20 ethical hacking interview
questions based on concepts like
networking software and programming
operating system and applications cyber
attacks and cryptography so let's get
started but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
from simplylearn let's start off with
question one what is a firewall
now this is a very good question and
normally a very basic answer that i've
ever heard is that a firewall is a
hardware and a software firewall but
that's the functionality of a firewall
that is what how we can install a
firewall but there are different types
of firewalls and there is a specific
functionality that the firewall is
created for
right so firewall is either a hardware
or software
but its responsibility is for blocking
either incoming or outgoing traffic
from the internet to your computer they
secure a network so essentially the
firewall will allow a connection to
happen or disallow a connection to
happen it won't go beyond that that's
the basic functionality of a firewall
okay so based on the
configurations that you have done based
on the rules that you have created on
the firewall it will then based on those
rules identify whether some traffic is
allowed in that network or some traffic
is
to be blocked from entering that network
so as the screen shows
the firewall rules will analyze whether
the traffic is good
if yes it will allow if the traffic is
bad it will block the traffic and not
allow that connection from happening in
the first place
now there are few common types of
firewalls that also need to be included
in the answer to this question and the
first one is a packet filtering firewall
these are the most common types that you
will come across which analyze packets
and lets them pass through only if they
match an established security rule set
now here people do get confused when we
say that we analyze packets people think
that these firewalls will analyze the
contents of that packet which is not
correct
when a definition for a packet filtering
firewall says that these firewalls
analyze packets it means that they are
only analyzing the source and
destination ip addresses port numbers
and the protocols that are mentioned in
those packets
these firewalls do not have the
capability of deep packet inspection or
dpi as it is known if that capability
comes into the picture you're basically
looking at an intrusion detection system
or intrusion prevention system in
today's world called as a next-gen
firewall
okay so a packet filtering firewall
essentially will only analyze data
packets for its source and destination
ip addresses port numbers and the
protocol that is being utilized it will
then map that information to the rules
that are there on the firewall
and based on those rules it will either
allow that a connection to happen or
disallow that connection from happening
the second type of is a proxy firewall
these firewalls filter network traffic
at the application level so when you say
application level they work at the layer
7 of the osi model packet filtering
firewalls since we have mentioned that
they've worked on ip addressing and port
numbers will work on
the network layer of the osi model also
on the transport layer because you also
look at protocols
proxy firewalls will work at layer 7
which is the application layer of the
osi model and we'll deal with
application level protocols such as http
https ftp smtp and so on so forth
and the third one is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall these
filter packets at the network transport
and application layers so they basically
do
the job of the first and the second type
of firewalls
the packets are compared to known
trusted packets but now the first
question is if there is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall why do
we have type one and type two firewalls
like packet filtering and proxy
firewalls that is because that is how
the firewalls have evolved we started
off with the packet filtering then we
added functionality to it and so on so
forth so if a question comes what is a
firewall you start off with the
option saying it is a hardware or
software this is the responsibility the
functionality of a firewall
is to allow good traffic and disallow
bad traffic based on the rules that have
been configured on the firewall and then
you've got basically three types of
firewalls packet filtering proxy and
stateful multi-layer and just include a
brief description of each of these
firewalls so that's question one moving
on to the question two
what is a vpn
vpn is also called a virtual private
network it is a connection between a vpn
server and a vpn client
so it basically creates an encrypted
tunnel between the client and the vpn
server which is then utilized to
secure the connections that you're
making with the internet so as you can
see in the diagram
the user has a vpn client installed on
their machine the vpn client then
creates an encrypted tunnel to the vpn
server
and through this tunnel encrypted data
is transmitted which can then be
processed by the vpn server
uh sent to the internet information can
receive can be received back by the vpn
server the vpn server will encrypt that
data back and send it back to the user
so if there is a man in the middle
attack that is happening or a hacker
trying to eavesdrop on the communication
mechanism they will not be able to do so
because of the encrypted terminal it is
very difficult to decrypt this or hack
through this encrypted tunnel
it is possible but it is very difficult
to achieve that then question number
three how do you keep a computer secure
now this is going to be a very generic
question so you want to put your best
foot forward and you want to identify
the most common methodologies on how you
can keep a computer secure
so when you talk about computers the
first thing that you want to talk about
is authentication mechanisms where you
want multi-factor authentication or
two-way authentication to ensure that
your accounts are kept secured now if
you look at using passwords depending on
how passwords are being stored by the
application
password attacks can
be possible either a brute force attack
or a dictionary based attack
uh or even password guessing attacks are
possible to mitigate those kind of
attacks you will need multi-factor
authentication
to ensure that accounts are kept secure
now even if we are using multi-factor
authentication we also want to look at
secure passwords
which means
that the password is complex enough to
withstand most of the common attacks and
a brute force attack or a dictionary
attack is just not possible so we want
to randomize our passwords we want to
create a complexity where a password
meets standards such as
me has at least
one lowercase one uppercase character
has numerics
and
special characters and is randomized is
not based on a dictionary word doesn't
contain usernames email addresses phone
numbers or anything that is personal to
that particular user
third keep regular updates which means
that there will be patches that will be
released for the application for the
software that you are utilizing download
the patches install them on a regular
basis to ensure that you are secured
against the most recent attacks that
have been identified
install a good antivirus
could be a internet security suite which
will have an antivirus intrusion
detection system a firewall
and will help you protect yourself
against ransomwares malwares
and any script-based attacks
also have a specialized firewall on your
system could be a host-based firewall or
a network-based firewall to ensure that
attacks are kept at a minimum and you
have your network definitions in place
to allow or disallow connections from
happening to your devices
have anti-phishing software installed as
well to ensure that you are not getting
any spam mails even if you do you are
able to identify that
and not fall free or victim to those
spam mails
phishing attacks are generic
where they are directed towards
individuals
and they prey
on the killability of that particular
individual so our nigerian frauds or the
lotteries that we win on a regular basis
of hundreds of million dollars
those messages the emails that we
receive they are all phishing emails
where
they're basically
prone to victimize the user and then
drop them off money or
install some malware
or do some other malicious activity
if you want to enhance encryption about
data that you have stored on your
devices or on your or that is accessed
by your software or being transmitted by
your software use encryption encrypt
your data whether it is at rest whether
it is in motion or whether it is at use
thus reducing data leakage and data loss
possibilities and finally in the
foremost secure your dns dns is the
domain name server which is utilized
by
computers to resolve domain names to ip
addresses
if a dns poisoning attack is possible
where your dns settings have been
modified by an attacker and you are
redirected to a malicious dns server
that server is going to redirect you to
another malicious application which may
have a malware or a malicious software
as a payload
also you don't want people to know your
dns servers and the queries that you're
making so you want to use secure dns or
dns over https to encrypt your dns
queries as well
so in a nutshell if you follow these
eight steps
your devices your computers your
applications are going to be as secure
as possible moving on to question number
four what are the different sources of
malware now malware stands for malicious
software right
malware is basically a software that
poses as a legitimate software but has a
payload of a trojan virus spyware
keylogger or some malicious software
that is going to have
a negative impact on security of your
particular device
so the question here is what are the
different sources of malware we want to
identify the most common
sources through which malwares infect
end user devices in today's world and
you can start with pop-up ads
so most of the websites if you're
visiting untrusted sites if you're being
redirected to sites that you don't know
about there'll be a lot of pop-ups
coming your way where it says you're the
1 millionth visitor to this site please
click here to download your gift
or it will say
congratulations on winning a particular
product for visiting this page and so on
so forth there are some instances where
you can see a banner which is flashing
at you on top of the page and says that
there are eight
uh infections that have been identified
on your computer click here to download
an antivirus to clean the infections so
all of these pop-ups
are there as a social engineering attack
as a phishing attack to make gullible
people click on those links and download
those malwares now the software that is
posing as a security software itself can
be a malicious software which is going
to install a trojan or a virus or a bot
on your machine compromising the
security of that machine
the second is removable media usbs and
humans have a fascination with usb so if
you find a usb lying around
it's a free usb you get excited about it
and you want to
take it home you want to plug it into a
machine and see what's on the usb worst
case scenario you format it and you've
got a free usb to utilize higher the
capacity the better but that is one of
the most easiest way people
use malware to
uh to be deployed on unsuspecting users
if there is a usb lying around
why would why would somebody want to
forget a usb it's most likely planted
over there as a social engineering
attack so that a global person is going
to pick it up
plug it into their device if the device
is not secured enough
it is going to install the malware
right
uh then documents and executable files
this is where your viruses and uh all
those creeps in so let's say you're
surfing on the internet you're looking
for a software
uh and you find the software on a
particular website you do not verify the
trustworthiness of that site and you
just download and install that software
now that software could be malware as
well thus if you're surfing on the
internet you're downloading files from
different locations you have to research
the website you have to research the
source to ensure that it is trustworthy
and only then are you going to download
and execute those files thus internet
downloads as well and when we say
internet downloads it's not just
untrustworthy sites we go to torrents
we go to uh
the dark web or the deep web and
searching for other softwares especially
those who are researching security right
we always want we are always on the
lookout of new softwares and we are
always on those forums which may not be
so much trustworthy
and we just download those files and
start installing them that is a very bad
scenario right so you have to be very
careful what you are downloading from
the internet your anti-viruses your uh
anti-phishing mechanisms your threat
intelligence mechanisms uh have those uh
mechanisms installed and you want to
verify where your downloads are coming
from then your network connections if it
is a p2p connection it is a local area
network connection or a metropolitan
area network you have to verify whom
which devices are connected to your
machines and you have to validate those
connections before you want to trust
those devices
and before you connect to them
if you are on a public wi-fi you
probably don't want to connect to a
public wi-fi in the first place
then comes email attachments
there are so many attachments that come
across in today's world most of them in
a zip format or a rar format
uh
some of them come as document files
where there are macros hidden within
them macros are scripts that are
recognized by microsoft office files
right
and then finally there are these
malicious advertisements that we find
online right uh let it be facebook let
it be whatsapp let it be uh
any social media platform that you go or
even your search engines
their job is to display ads their job is
not to verify whether the ad is legit or
not it is for us as consumers to be
careful and validate that ad and verify
whether it is a genuine ad or not so
just don't start clicking on
uh any of the ad trusting uh the
platform that you're on
be uh be sure that you are investigating
that so these are the most common
sources of malware and the end user
will always get infected by one of these
mechanisms then moving on to question
number five
how does email work
now this is a very uh
can be a complex question uh but we have
to keep it as simple as possible
and we have to identify that there are
uh two servers
while both of them either using smtp
which is a simple message transfer
protocol
where
in this scenario john
wants to send an email thus got an email
client installed on their machine which
is connected to the mail exchange server
which has a dns server which maps
the routing and which maps the exchange
server and inboxes
so when john composes that message and
clicks on send john should be connected
to a mail exchange server where the
email is sent through that particular
person's inbox so so john's inbox will
then
uh be validated and that email will then
be sent through the dns server
uh through the internet and will be
received by the recipient mail server so
at this point in time john also requires
the recipient's
email address so in this case this is
jack so jack something dot com would be
uh the email address
so while john is composing uh the two
field will have jack's email address the
from field will have john's email
address the subject field will have
whatever they want to convey as a
message the message body will have the
message itself and then when
john clicks on send it will go to their
exchange server the exchange server will
then validate the inbox and identify
where that inbox is located for jack and
then through the internet it will be
sent to the uh to the mail server of
jack
the mail server will then identify the
proper
inbox that it now that that email needs
to be sent to and it will store that
email in that particular inbox when jack
opens their computer
and accesses their inbox this email from
john will be already waiting for them
and they can respond to it the same way
john had sent that email
moving on to question number six what is
black box and white box testing so when
you are testing a software or you are
testing your infrastructure there are
two different
tests that you can conduct the first one
is a black box the second one is a white
box in a black box test there is no
knowledge that is shared with the tester
so let's say you're an ethical hacker
and you have been awarded a contract by
an organization to test the current
application that they have developed now
they are not going to give you any
information they are not going to tell
you what the application is they just
probably give you an ip address and a
port number where the application is
hosted and now you have to file in your
own queries and try to figure out what
the application is try to gather
information see what uh what information
can be gathered in the first place and
based on that you're going to figure out
your way identify vulnerabilities and
see if any of those vulnerabilities can
lead to an security incident so without
any knowledge zero knowledge of the id
infrastructure or the source code that's
a black box attack or a black box test a
white box test on the other hand is
where full knowledge of the id
infrastructure or the source code is
shared
so the ethical hacker has complete
knowledge
and based on the knowledge they are then
going to test out the system to see if
there are any flaws that they can
identify right so
why would these two audits be important
because the first one a black box audit
emulates the attack of a outsider a
external hacker sitting outside the
organization trying to figure their way
in whereas a white box attack can
emulate the attack of an insider so a
disgruntled employee within that
organization misusing their access
controls or the access rights
to make uh unvalidated profits right so
somebody's corrupt who has been bribed
who wants to sell out company secrets
based uh so they're going to try to find
out vulnerabilities try to steal data
and try to sell it on the uh gray market
right so a white box would emulate a
internal attack a black box would
emulate an external attack the next
question is
what are the steps involved in hacking a
server or a network so this is more of
an ethical hacking question you're
looking at devices and for and the
interviewer asks you
what kind of steps are involved what are
the activities that you would do
in hacking a server or a network now
there are no specific steps that you
would define because every hack is going
to be unique but it has a hack can be
classified in five different steps
which are quite generic right so the
first step will always always be the
recognizing step
also known as
information gathering phase also known
as footprinting or fingerprinting uh
depending on what exactly you're doing
but in this phase
the attacker gathers all the evidence
all the information that is possible
about the targets that they want to
attack
so here you are trying to get to know
the victim so you can launch specific
attacks towards them you want to
identify what operating system they are
utilizing what ip addresses mac
addresses the versions of the operating
systems and applications the patch
levels find out vulnerabilities find out
whatever information is possible find
out the information about the
person who who's using those computers
so you can launch social engineering
attacks and so on so forth so the first
step is all about gathering enough
information
based on which you can launch further
attacks
once you have that information comes the
second phase which is known as the
scanning phase
this is more of a technical phase so you
have
in the first step you've got your ip
addresses domain names maybe even
network maps and you have identified
which devices are available now in the
scanning phase you're going to identify
live devices
and then you're going to scan them for
open ports processors protocols services
you're going to identify vulnerabilities
you're going to enumerate them to
identify more information from them thus
at this point in time you will have
identified a certain set of
vulnerabilities or a certain set of
security loopholes that you can misuse
once you have identified those
you are going to the next step which is
the gaining access tip
in this you're actually going to execute
your attacks based on the
vulnerabilities that you have found and
you're either going to gain access to
that particular system by installing a
trojan or destroy the system by
installing a virus or install a spyware
or a keylogger whatever you wanted to
achieve so in the gaining access phase
you would have
based on the knowledge that you gain in
the first and the second phase you're
going to launch your attacks and you're
going to try to gain access to that
particular device
then the next step is where you're going
to maintain that access now that you
have hacked into that device it is not
necessary that you will always
be able to get access to that device uh
suppose you have cracked the password of
that particular user and the user
changes that password after a few days
your attack is worthless so what you're
going to do here is you're going to
maintain your access
so this is
where it is assumed that you want
repeated access to that device and thus
you're going to install a keylogger or a
trojan or some mechanism which will
still allow you to get access to that
device without the knowledge or the
authorization of that particular user
and finally the last step is where
you're going to cover your tracks so
whatever activity that we have done so
far will have created logs and will have
created information
based on which the victim will come to
know that they have been compromised and
may be able to trace that activity back
to you
so to prevent the user or the victim
from realizing that they have been
hacked and to prevent them to discover
who has hacked them
you want to cover your tracks by
deleting logs and any references that
point to that particular activity you're
going to hide the files that you have
created so you've installed a trojan or
a key logger
these will create files and directories
you're going to hide them so that they
are not discovered you're going to hide
processes that have been created you're
going to try to hide all the activity
that you have done so that to conceal
the actual attack
and preventing the user from realizing
that they have been compromised
so these are the five steps that will be
involved in hacking a server network
application or any computing device you
will come across the next question
refers to what are the various sniffing
tools now this is a network-based attack
where you're trying to capture uh data
packages that that are being transmitted
over the network and then you're going
to analyze them to see if you can
capture any sensitive information like
usernames passwords bank details or any
anything of that sort now these tools
will also depend on which operating
system you are utilizing for example msn
sniffer would work on microsoft
operating systems
eater cab would be based on linux and so
on so forth so on the screen you'll see
six different sniffing tools that work
on different operating systems wireshark
is uh something that is common both on
windows and linux
it is used to analyze network in detail
it is the de facto tool that you will
come across in most of your ethical
hacking trainings in most
of your organizations when they want to
do
data captures
data capturing or packet capturing is
not only done by hackers to gather more
information but it is also a known
troubleshooting technique used by
administrators and network
administrators to analyze any issues
that may be going on in the network
right so while the first tool you see on
the screen is wireshark like we stated
is available for windows linux uh as
well
then there is tcp dump which again has
the same capability of wireshark but is
a command line version whereas wireshark
also has a gui a graphical user
interface
tcp dump is available on linux
msn sniffer it's a very old tool
uh
when we had msn messengers msn messenger
is no longer there but
microsoft does or did have a microsoft
message analyzer tool uh which they have
stopped development since 2015
but that's another tool that is specific
for microsoft operating systems from
microsoft that can be installed together
more information then you got it cap
which is
a tool to launch man-in-the-middle
attacks data capturing and is is
essentially a linux command line based
tool
then d sniff is another password and
network capturing tool which can help
you capture data package prominently a
linux
two
same with eatery
this is a graphical tool which will
allow you to
capture data data traffic and map
protocols and identify which ip
addresses have been communicating with
what essentially all of the tools have
similar functionality except that
some have additional functionality like
launching manual attacks or uh capturing
or having specific filters that will
help you identify and troubleshoot some
network issues that you may be facing
question nine what is sql injection sql
stands for
structured query language which is a
language that is used by most of your
databases or your relational databases
the variations of your database would be
mysql microsoft sql
oracle sql
you'll have ibm databases all of these
databases utilize the structured query
languages to interact with the
applications now all of these databases
have their own syntax so you'll have to
study most of these databases based on
which applications and which databases
you want to provide security for
but as the name suggests sql injection
vulnerability or structured query
language injection vulnerability
is where a user can maliciously inject a
sql input
or a sql statement in a query
and
send it to the database and evoke a
response response out of it
so this vulnerability is not
specifically to the database it the
vulnerability lies more in the
application and the coding of that
application so when the application
receives a query which it needs to be
forwarded to the sql
database we need to configure at the
application level
of what queries are allowed and what
queries are not allowed so there are
different various aspects
of how to manage a sql injection
vulnerability but the basic flaw lies in
the application where
invalidated input is accepted and sent
forward to the database where the
database might confuse it into an
executable statement and thus create a
response that was not warranted
there are various types of sequel
injections as shown on the screen
in-band sequence injection where you can
look at an error based or a union based
injection a blind sql injection where it
is either boolean based or a time-based
attack and then an out-of-bound sql
injection
essentially you're looking at databases
and you're looking at application
security where you want to encourage
secure coding practices so in
unvalidated input is mitigated the next
question is what is spoofing
now in spoofing you're basically
assuming the identity of another person
so here the attacker pretends to be some
other person or an organization and
sends you an email that appears to be a
legitimate email it looks almost genuine
it has been constructed to replicate
what a genuine email would have been
and it is very difficult to spot a fake
one
there are different ways to identify
whether email is genuine or not
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
moving on to the next question what is a
distributed denial of service attack or
a ddos attack now generally a denial of
service attack is an attack where
legitimate users are prevented access to
the resources that they legitimately can
access right so for example if it is a
bandwidth-based attack
the attacker consumes the bandwidth of
the network in such a way that there is
no more bandwidth left for legitimate
users to access the network
now a single device may not be able to
generate that much amount of
traffic to consume the bandwidth of a
huge server thus the attacker will
construct a botnet
and through that botnet they will launch
a distributed denial of service attack
to the target victim right so a botnet
uh there are two uh terms that you want
to look at over here the first term is a
bot and the second one being the botnet
itself bot is a software that once
installed on a victim's machine allows
the hacker to
send remote commands to that machine
that will
make it to generate some activity
once we have enough machines
on which such bots have been implemented
the collection of these machines would
be known as a botnet
so an attacker would then instruct this
entire botnet to start generating data
traffic to be to be sent to the targeted
network or to the targeted server which
will then pop down the server
thus crashing it and preventing users
from accessing that particular resource
the next question is how to avoid our
poisoning or arp now first let's
understand what arp is arp stands for
address resolution protocol which is a
protocol used by computers to
communicate over the network
once your computer boots up
it starts a discovery process of
identifying its neighbors so if i'm in a
particular subnet
my machine will proactively send out a
arp request an address resolution
protocol to find out which other
machines are within the same network and
which are live once it sends out a query
a live machine will respond to that
query along
with its mac address
this information is then
stored in what is known as a arp table
or an arp table on the machine's
cachet so whenever my machine now wants
to send out a packet to this particular
machine it will go to the arp table it
will identify the ip address and the
associated mac address it will print
that onto the data packet as a
destination
and destination mac and send that packet
across to the switch the switch will
then identify the mac address and send
the packet to the relevant machine that
is connected to that particular switch
now to confuse the switch into sending
it to a different machine
our poisoning attack is created this
attack is generally
launched to
create a man in the middle attack
now to prevent this arm poisoning from
happening in the first place there are
three different aspects that we can
utilize first we can use packet
filtering
which will filter out and block packets
that are the same source address data so
you have identified some malicious ip
addresses and you want to block out some
ip addresses so you're using a packet
filter firewall where you have
constructed the firewall to filter out
certain packets
originating from particular range of ip
addresses this firewall and this
technique will then block those kind of
packets coming in
second keeping away from trust
relationships organizations will develop
protocols that do not depend on trust
relationships and thus you want to
keep this protocol away from there once
you have created a trust relationship
uh these machines should not be sending
out arp requests to other machines in
the first place since uh that
translation has been defined and these
machines know whom to communicate with
such kind of protocols should then be
disabled
or you can use arp spoofing software so
there are some there are software's out
there that will look for arp spoofing
and prevent that from happening in the
first place so if somebody has sent out
a spoofed arp packet
that packet will be picked up by this
software
and it will be mitigated of
network visualizers like glass wire
antiviruses like so force
they have inbuilt capabilities of
identifying uh our op spoofing attacks
and mitigate them in the first place in
the next question we are going to
discuss what is ransomware now
ransomware is a type of malware that
blocks victims to access personal files
and demands ransom to regain access
there are three categories before we go
into the categories let's just revisit
what ransomware is let's start with the
word malware malware is a malicious
software that poses as a legitimate
software but has a payload that will
have a security impact on your machine
so in this instance uh viruses trojans
all of these can be classified under
malware so can ransomware a trojan is a
software that will give you a backdoor
access to
a particular device a virus will do some
destructive activity on that device a
ransomware will basically encrypt the
data of that particular user from on
that particular machine thus rendering
that my that data inaccessible to the
users themselves
and in turn will demand the ransom to
provide access to that particular data
so the three types of ransomwares the
first one is scareware which uses social
engineering to cause anxiety or the
perception of a threat to manipulate
users into buying unwanted software so
this preys on the gullibility of humans
where you can see a pop-up appearing on
your screen which can scare you into
believing that you may have been
attacked or there is a virus on your
machine and then instructs you to
download a particular software to
mitigate that particular virus now
the malware will be in this software
that you will be downloading and then a
ransomware will be installed and your
data will be encrypted
screen lockers uh
where
locking uses computers by preventing
them from logging in and displaying an
official looking message you will see a
screen saver once you boot up which
prevents you from accessing the login
page so it will not allow you to log
into your own machine but it will give
you a warning that your data has been
encrypted and you need to connect to a
particular email address and send bit to
send over there
to get a decryption key to access your
own data and then the encrypting so
ransomware displays a message demanding
payment in return for the private
asymmetric key which is needed to
decrypt the symmetric keys for encrypted
file so once your files have been
encrypted you might just have a blank
screen in front of you where you'll
receive a warning message uh where it
instructs you to pay up a ransom in
bitcoins or in some cryptocurrency to
some particular digital e-wallet which
is not traceable and once you make that
payment they will send you the
decryption key and then you can access
your data then talking about the next
question what is the difference between
an active and a passive cyber attack now
when we talk about cyber attacks cyber
attack is activity that is caused by a
malicious user who wants to try to
get access or do some security incidents
on the victims devices so there are two
ways that can happen it's either in an
active manner or a passive manner in an
active manner the intruder attempts to
disrupt a network's normalcy modifies
data and tries to alter the system's
resources so this is more active where
the attacker will proactively
trying to
destroy the network so that
communications fail or they might try to
modify the data where we're using a
ransom where they can encrypt it or they
might delete that data using a virus or
steal that data using a trojan or they
might even alter the data
so that it is no longer trustworthy
whereas in a passive attack the intruder
intercepts data traveling through a
network here the intruder eavesdrop but
does not modify the message so they're
just listening in they're just observing
what is going on they're not
manipulating the data they're not
stealing anything it's just that they
are monitoring the activity that's going
on the next question what is a social
engineering attack now social
engineering attack is a people
people-based attack the victim here is
the human by itself the vulnerability
also lies in the human it may be
executed through a computer but
end of the day the gullibilities of the
human so it is the art of manipulating
people so that they end up giving up
confidential information
now
we always read in the papers where
somebody got manipulated their passwords
got hacked and somebody's life savings
got wiped out
right because they shared the otp with
someone or they shared up
the password with someone now creating a
scenario where these people will fall
prey to this attack and share this kind
of personal information
to unknown people that is where the
social engineering attack comes in
creating that scenario which will ensure
that these people give out this
confidential information now there are
three categories in this attack one the
first one is a phishing attack second is
a sphere phishing attack and a third is
a railing attack now phishing attack is
basically a generic attack
it is targeted to the world at large
whoever falls prey to that attack
will be a victim
whereas a spear phishing attack is a
targeted attack towards a specific
individual or a group of individuals or
towards an organization so there is a
lot more research that goes into spear
phishing where you analyze the victim
you try to figure out what the
vulnerabilities are and you tailor make
or you customize the attack
to that particular vulnerability once
you have that attack you launch it
against those people those people
will then fall prey to this attack and a
whaling attack is where you're attacking
top level executives so the c-level
executives of an organization
politicians movie stars wealthy and
powerful people
so any of these people when they're
attacked it will be known as a wailing
attack
next question what is man in the middle
attack now this is something that we had
touched based when we talked about arp
where the arp poisoning attack needs to
be executed
to leverage a man in the middle attack
now
in the man in the middle attack
the attacker attacking computer takes
the ip address of the client unaware of
this the server continues to communicate
with the attacker now if you remember in
a previous question we have also talked
about spoofing so in this scenario
attacker has spoofed their ip address to
replicate themselves as a genuine client
and now with that spoofing in mind they
might either through our poisoning
attack or just because of the spoofed ip
address become a man in the middle that
means that they are now
each dropping on the conversation
between the actual
client and the server by posing
themselves as a server in this scenario
the attacker is now
a go between between the client and the
server and can eavesdrop and can copy
the data if they want they can modify
the data as well so as you can see on
the screen the attacker becomes man in
the middle which means that they are now
dropping on the conversation that is
happening between the client and the
server the next question
who are black hat hackers and whitehead
hackers the main thing is the
differentiation between a black hat
hacker and a white ted hacker now our
black hat hackers are skilled
individuals who illegally hack into a
system the motive behind such an attack
is mostly for monetary gain these
individuals are known also known as
security crackers now if you look at
your criminal hackers those who have
malicious intent those who do hacking
for the intent of personal gain or for
the matter of disruption the main thing
that blackhead hackers
lack
is authorization they are not authorized
to do the activity that they are about
to do and they are going to get
unauthorized access to devices or to
data which is going to cause losses to
the organization involved
whereas on the other side a white hat
hacker are also known as ethical hackers
these are the individuals who discover
vulnerabilities in a computer network
and they help the organizations mitigate
these vulnerabilities they help the
organizations defend themselves from
black hat hackers so the main difference
between these two types of hackers a
black hat and a white hat is the intent
and the authorization so black hat
hackers will have malicious intent they
will try to personally gain from that
attack
from by finding out vulnerabilities they
also will not have authorization to
conduct whatever activity they are doing
whereas on the other side whitehead
hackers will be hired by organizations
they will provide authorization for
certain activity that the whitehead
hacker can do
to find out those vulnerabilities once
those vulnerabilities have been find out
found out by the white hat hacker they
will report it to the management and
guide them in implementing security
controls to mitigate those
vulnerabilities the main difference
between a black hat and a white hat is
the authorization and the intent the
next question what are honey pots
now honey pots are
a very interesting device that can be
introduced in a network uh these
basically are decoy servers that are
implemented in a network to attract the
attention of an attacker
it is there to lure an attacker
into
attacking that particular device
thus creating a security blanket blanket
for the rest of the devices
so if an attacker has been able to
bypass a firewall and is now trying to
scan a particular network when they scan
they will come across various devices
that are there in the network they will
then proceed to do a vulnerability scan
on these devices the honeypot at that
point in time will provide as an approve
as an attraction to these attackers
because it will
demonstrate some vulnerabilities to the
hacker which will divert their attention
so these vulnerabilities are simulated
on these devices these actually do not
exist but the moment the attacker then
starts interacting with the honeypot the
honeypot will identify that as a
malicious traffic and will warm the one
the administrator about a possible
attack that is going on the
administrator will then investigate
through the honeypot of what activity is
going on and then reconfigure the
security controls to block the attacker
or mitigate the attack itself right so
it is more of a decoy server
that will showcase or simulate some
vulnerabilities to an attacker thus to
lure them
and safeguard the rest of the network
moving on to the next question define
cryptography encryption and decryption
now cryptography
is used by security professionals to
scramble data
into non-readable format
which is used in securing that
information
so it involves converting data from a
readable format into a non-readable
format and then reversing it back to
readable format again
for example the word computer is now
scrambled into looking like an
unreadable format now if you look at
this word that it has been scrambled
into it would be very difficult for a
human to figure out
what the actual world was
now in this scenario we have taken an
algorithm where we have made a
shift of the alphabet where we have
added two alphabets the current one so c
plus two becomes e
o plus two becomes q m plus two becomes
o so we have done a shift of two and
thus the key over here for this
algorithm is the alphabet plus two so
any person who figures that out will be
able to unscramble this and convert this
back into readable text
the fact of scrambling a readable text
data into something that is unreadable
by using a particular key is what
cryptography is all about
now as we discussed the decryption again
is
replacing the alphabet and taking it
further back by two characters so e
minus 2 becomes c q minus 2 becomes o o
minus 2 becomes m and so on so forth so
anybody who knows this key
the shift key
anybody will able to
decrypt this particular character so
this depends on the user if i want to
utilize alphabet plus five then the
spacing the shifting of that character
will be the fifth character from that
particular character
and so on so forth and now the last
question what is the difference between
cipher text and clear text
cipher text refers to the text which is
encrypted and totally undesirable
the message received after decryption is
known as clear text this text is
comprehensible so the word computer is
clear text that means that it has not
been treated to any cryptographic
measures it does what it is intended to
be
however if the moment we encrypt it that
means we scramble it into unreadable
text by using any of the algorithms that
we'll be looking at
that text is known as a cipher text
and without the key this becomes
unreadable
the clear text as discussed is the plain
word that we have utilized we are using
the english language in this instance so
the plain word computer is the clear
text once we add the encryption layer to
it
we get the cipher text to it
hope you all enjoyed learning about
ethical hackers and the lucrative
profession
if there are any queries based on this
topic feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and we will get
back to you as soon as possible
subscribe to our channel for more
informative videos like this and thank
you for watching
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you